Heute im Rasenfunk.
Das ist ein Märchen! Ein unglaubliches Märchen! Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga!
Eckball, Langer fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Der S ist vor allem das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier ist die Ligatour. Und ihr habt es schon gesehen, hier ist eine XXL-Folge. Warum? Weil ihr es euch verdient habt. Und weil meine Gäste Bock drauf hatten. Gott sei Dank, da sind wir alle gut davongekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und bei Blue Sky. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass wir heute, zumindest kurz, auf jedes Team dieser 2. Männer Bundesliga zurückblicken, auf die Hinrunde jedes Teams natürlich. Ich begrüße hier bei mir Eva-Lotta Bohle. Hallo Eva, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich finde es ja super interessant, dass Sie jetzt Philipps Dujilkovic von Darmstadt ausgeliehen haben. Also ich finde das sowieso von Darmstadtseite sehr merkwürdig, weil das glaube ich der Rekord-Transfer von Darmstadt 98 in der letzten Saison war, mit über zwei Millionen oder so. Und den jetzt zu Kaiserslautern auszuleihen, finde ich schon wilden Move, irgendwie, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber ich denke mal, da will man eben so ein bisschen Backup für Acher haben. Und das muss ich sagen, finde ich tatsächlich einen sehr interessanten Transfer, den ich mir durchaus vorstellen könnte. Also er ist für mich auch eher ein Zweitliga-Stürmer, aber das könnte ich mir tatsächlich ganz gut vorstellen, dass er eine ganz gute Rolle bei Kaiserslautern spielen könnte.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine Reaktion darauf, dass Terence Boyd in der vergangenen Song schon noch ein ziemlich guter Stürmer war. Dann wurde von Acher schon in den Schatten gestellt. Und er hat dann gegen Fürth gespielt. Und man merkt dann schon, dass er mittlerweile auch schon in die Jahre gekommen ist und halt einfach nicht mehr dieses Leistungslevel, das er mal hatte vor einiger Zeit, einfach über 34 Spieltage hinwegbringen kann. Und deswegen ist es schon gut, sich da offensiv zu verstärken. Auch wenn man ist offensiv gut, aber wenn man sieht, die fünf meisten Schüsse der Liga, dann könnte er noch viel mehr rausspringen. Ja, Storjel Kovic fand ich auch gut in der zweiten Liga und ich bin sehr gespannt. Also die Offensive mit Ache und ihm zusammen, vielleicht sogar, die hätte schon eine gewisse Wucht auf jeden Fall.
Aber es gibt ja noch die andere Seite des Feldes, habe ich schon gesagt. Zweit schlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Gibt es denn da auch Hoffnung darauf, dass das mal besser wird? Weil Trainer-Effekt ist verpufft, das haben wir ja jetzt gerade schon thematisiert. Auch wenn es enger war in manchen der jüngeren Spiele, jetzt dann unter Gramozis. Aber die Seite des Balls müsste man ja auch irgendwie in den Griff bekommen. Und im Schnitt kassiert man ja fast zwei Tore pro Spiel. Über zwei Tore sind es ja sogar.
Man hat ja noch mal reagiert und hat Al Mami Touré verpflichtet, der mit Frankfurt noch vor einiger Zeit international erfolgreich war. Das war ja schon mal ein Schritt hin zu mehr defensiver Stabilität. Wobei der jetzt ja, glaube ich, in dieser Vorauswahl für den Afrika Cup schon wieder ist. Mir leider entfallen, für welches Land, aber auf jeden Fall ist er für Mali. Er ist auf jeden Fall auch wieder da berufen. Das heißt, da würde eine wichtige Stütze, die man eigentlich eingeplant hat, wieder wegfallen. Auch in der zweiten Liga spielt der Afrika Cup eine Rolle. Noch ein bisschen weniger als in der Bundesliga bei manchem Verein, aber er wird eine Rolle spielen. Ansonsten ja, ich finde das auch nicht allzu überraschend. Ich fand auch, als ich den FCK live gesehen habe gegen Fürth, nicht wirklich sattelfässig defensiv, weil auch von den Spielernahmen ist da jetzt mir niemand rausgestochen, der wirklich da extrem Stabilität gebracht hat. Das sind halt auch typische Zweitligaspieler. Zum Beispiel Kevin Kraus hat da ja gespielt oder spielt immer mal wieder. Hat bei auch, glaube ich, mal mit dem Jörn, beim KSC-Schwerpunkt damals, so Spieler, die halt einfach schon so okay für die 2. Liga, aber wo man auch nicht mehr so die krasse Entwicklung nach oben wahrscheinlich sehen wird. Und die hat dann einfach, muss man auch sagen, gegen manche Vereine dann einfach auch da nicht mithalten können bei der offensiven Qualität. Selbst Fürth, die jetzt noch nicht so viele Tore schießen hätten, die haben beim FCK noch mehr schießen können, die haben sich da relativ leicht durchspielen können durch die Abwehr. Also irgendwie, da gibt es wenig, was mir Hoffnung macht, abgesehen von Almami Toure. Schauen wir mal, wie oft er in der Grunde noch spielen kann.
Schauen wir, ob er mal auf Touren kommt und ob Agnar Rache, wie ich ihn ab jetzt immer nennen werde, wann er zurückkommt. Das ist die Situation bei Kaiserslautern und bei Spielern, die in der 2. Liga nicht mehr mithalten können. Sind wir da beim FCK 04 gelandet? Ich weiß es nicht. Zumindest ist Schalke jetzt dran. Rang 14, 20 Punkte sind es immerhin, muss man fast sagen. Immerhin ist auch immer was los, wenn Schalke spielt. Nicht nur im Stadion, sondern auch auf dem Spielfeld. 31 Tore geschossen, 35 kassiert, das heißt 66 Torbeteiligungen in Spielen mit Schalke. Da ist immer was geboten, aber da ist auch viel Drama geboten. Und Kevin hat die ehrenvolle Aufgabe, zu versuchen, uns das irgendwie näher zu bringen. Kevin, was ist los auf Schalke?
Tja, was ist los auf Schalke, das ist eine Frage, die kann ich, glaube ich, auch nicht vollends beantworten.
Gut, dann machen wir weiter mit Magdeburg. Damit wäre ich ja wieder dran.
Da wären wir gesplittet dran. Was ist los auf Schalke? Eigentlich ist auf Schalke das los, was da seit Jahren los ist und wieso es auch bergab gegangen ist. Es ist immer ganz, ganz, ganz viel im Umfeld an Unruhe drin. Jeder weiß, wie dieser Verein wieder zur wahrer Größe gebracht werden kann. Man spricht dann irgendwann mal davon, dass man bald wieder um die Deutsche Meisterschaft mitspielen möchte.
Spricht da wirklich jemand von oder sind das nicht nur Urban Legends?
Das sind wahrscheinlich vor allem irgendwelche Menschen, die in diesem Verein leider was zu sagen haben, die davon träumen. Ich habe den Verein vor einigen Jahren kennengelernt, beruflich in der Natur, und damals waren es Trainer wie Mirko Slomka oder auch Jens Keller dort, die nachhinein betrachtet richtig gut performt haben mit diesem Verein, Champions League gespielt haben, sehr weit oben gelandet sind und immer wieder daran gescheitert sind, weil sie im Umfeld nicht gut ankamen, also nicht bei den Fans jetzt unbedingt, sondern bei den Strippenziehern, sage ich mal, auch bei gewissen Medien, Konzernen und so weiter und so fort, und sind daran gescheitert, weil sie dann da widerspenstig waren, wie zum Beispiel auch in Evalin, der hätte es, glaube ich, auf Schalke auch niemals geschafft, weil er viel zu sehr aneckt, und das haben die bis heute nicht weggekriegt. Plus diese sportliche Planung, die seit Jahren auch schon immer ein Würfelspiel von außen betrachtet ist, weil die sportliche Führung teilweise entweder gar nicht da ist, also nicht besetzt ist im Amt, oder viel zu oft wechselt, als das da eine Philosophie, wie man früher so schön gesagt hat, der Verein hatte eine Philosophie, dass die dort mal durchgesetzt werden könnte. Denn wenn man mal überlegt, was ist denn die Philosophie vom FC Schalke 04, die scheint einfach zu sein, in die erste Liga zurückzukehren. So, das ist die Philosophie vom FC Schalke 04. Früher stand der Verein für knappen Schmiede, für viel Talent im Unterbau, für harte Arbeit. Man kennt dann natürlich einhergehend mit den Kumpels. Man hatte ein Image in dem Verein. Und all das ist sehr, sehr verblasst in den letzten Jahren. Da hat Schalke arg darunter gelitten, hat sich davon bisher nicht erholt, wenn man jetzt das Ganze vom Image her mal angeht. Vom sportlichen her hat man in diesem Sommer etwas Interessantes versucht. Man hat einmal mit dem Trainer weitergemacht, mit dem man abgestiegen ist, der aber natürlich auch, glaube ich, auf Platz acht der Rückrundentabelle gelandet war an der Bundesliga. Das hat aber nicht gereicht mehr. Ich meine, es wäre acht gewesen, bin mir gerade unsicher. Ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben, aber nicht den Platz.
Müßte stimmen, das habe ich auch so im Kopf.
Ja, also da hat man gesagt, okay, alles gut. Signale sind positiv, Team hat er erreicht. Wir wagen das, wir machen mit dem Herrn Reis weiter. Der dann letztes Alter erfolgreich damit war, dass man sehr viel gepresst hat, also Pressing gespielt hat, die die Vereine überrascht hat. Vor allem nach der Hinrunde, die Schalke nur vier in der Bundesliga hatte, und der wollte dieses Spielkonzept quasi eins zu eins transferieren in die zweite Bundesliga, hat dabei leider halt nicht bemerkt, dass in der zweiten Liga viele Vereine spielen, die sich halt –auch obwohl sie eine mindere individuelle Klasse haben in der Gesamtbesetzung als natürlich die Bundesliga, versuchen sie aber gerade dadurch viel, viel mehr in der taktischen Flexibilität sich zu verdingen, sage ich mal, und breiter aufzustellen. Das sehe ich bei unserem Verein, also beim SCP, das sehe ich aber auch bei ganz vielen anderen Vereinen. Es ist echt schwierig, ein Team zu finden, wo du sagst, die machen starr nur die eine Sache, und wenn da jemand draufpresst, dann fallen die in Ohnmacht und können gar nicht mehr reagieren. Man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich traue dem Kollegen Reis das schon durchaus zu, dass er auch erkannt hat, dass in der 2. Liga wieder gespielt wird, aber offenbar hat die Mannschaft das nicht auf den Platz bekommen, denn sie haben weiter versucht, dieses Spiel aus der 1. Liga in der Hinrunde zu spielen, mit vermindertem Personal, also von der Qualität her. Wir hatten ja auch ein paar Abgänge, einige Neuzugänge mit einem neuen Kapitän, Ron Schallenberg, großer Hoffnungsträger, der hofiert wurde, wie noch kein Spieler, der aus Paderborn irgendwo hin gewechselt ist. Einen Interview nahm anderen Home-Story und schlagt mich tot. Irgendwelche Interviews auf dem Balkon am Trainingsplatz.
Es gibt eine Ron Schallenberg-Home-Story, und ich weiß davor nichts.
Nein, das war überspitzt ausgedrückt. Man hat ihn quasi wochenlang nur noch auf den sozialen Kanälen gesehen. Im Sommer beim FC Schalke 04, wo ich mich gewundert habe. Ja, bei uns war er einer der Big Player in Paderborn. Aber wie kann denn –er hat ja auch mit den besten Werte in der zweiten Liga gehabt in den letzten Jahren. Aber wie kann denn ein FC Schalke 04 sich komplett dann auf den –Das war mir einfach too much. Das war für mich auch surreal, dass das so abläuft. Vor allem, wenn da alteingesessene Spieler rumlaufen. Therode und Co., Polta und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Fährmann, also sehr viele mit großem Ego, die in so einem Moment sicherlich auch denken, da kommt so einer aus Paderborn und der ist jetzt ja eine neue Star hier oder was? Hoffnungssäge. Also auch das ist so eine explosive Mischung vielleicht gewesen. Das ist so nie nach außen gedrungen. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob es stimmt, aber ob man da auch Ron so einen Gefallen getan hat, als relativ junger Spieler in so einem gewaltigen Umfeld so viel Druck auf die Schultern zu hängen in der ersten Saison, wage ich mal zu bezweifeln. Weil das hat ja damals in Paderborn auch schon nicht geklappt. Da ist er erst einmal verliehen worden nach Ferl und ist dann zurückgekehrt und dann unter Steffen Baumgart halt groß geworden. Also groß im Sinne des SC Paderborn.
Ja, so, dass Schalke nur viel in der Home-Story-Bane macht. Das ist quasi…
Also das sind so ein paar Sachen. Ich kann das gar nicht so an einem speziellen Punkt festmachen. Ich glaube, das können auch sehr wenige, weil Schalke wirklich ganz vorgewilderte Spiele auch hatte in dieser Hinrunde.
In alle Richtungen. Also da war ja auch mal ein 4-3 gegen Magdeburg dabei oder so.
Ja, man hat mal gedacht, okay, jetzt haben sie Kurve bekommen. Jetzt haben sie sich eingespielt, jetzt findet sich die Mannschaft. Und dann verlieren die halt sang- und klanglos in Paderborn. Und gegen weitere andere Spiele, gegen andere Mannschaften. Also insofern, es ist echt eine Wundertüte, jetzt zum Ende der Hinrunde scheint man sich ja wieder zu fangen oder gefangen zu haben. Auch wenn man natürlich noch unten drin steht. Aber wie das weitergeht, weiß ich nicht. Die 2. Liga ist natürlich eng genug beieinander, dass da auch noch ein kräftiger Run in der Rückrunde reichen würde, um sich nach oben spülen zu lassen. Ich sehe das aber momentan nicht. Zumal natürlich auch wieder Baustellen aufgemacht wurden, wie ein Scheinberg soll im Winter wieder verkauft werden. Es gibt ja immer dann diese Strömungen, wo man sich an den Kopf fasst und denkt, ey Leute, ihr habt diverse junge Spieler geholt, die sind jetzt alle in Ungnade gefallen, die sollen im Winter jetzt wieder gehen. Und das ist ja auch Quatsch. Schalke hat ja auch gar kein Geld dafür, um das so zu betreiben. Eva würde gerne schonigen. Und Yannick, also alle wollen was sein, ist ein Pausier.
Yannick war gerne als Erstes.
Ja, ich würde den Blick gerne kurz weg vom rein sportlichen Denken. Und zwar war Schalke ja zweimal bei uns zu Gast. Einmal in der Liga und einmal im Pokal. Und da gab es ja am 6. Spielag, als sie bei uns in der Liga zu Gast waren, auch zum Abfiffen Ausschreitungen aus dem Gästeblog hin zu unserer Nordkurve. Und jetzt auch am vorletzten Spieltag, als sie in Rostock zu Gast waren, haben sich da auch das Heim- und das Gastlager versucht zu begegnen. Da war zum Glück dann so ein Pufferblock zwischen –das wären auch mal meine zwei Cents –aber ich dachte, ich muss Rostock nicht noch mehr Plattformen geben, als ich es eh schon hingemacht habe. Dass es einfach unsiedlich ist von der baulichen Art, dass das da alles so nah beieinander ist. Und es würde jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu weit gehen, zu sagen, dass Schalke Rostock mittlerweile in nichts nachsteht, aber es geht in eine Richtung, die ich nicht gut heiße. Da ist ganz viel Druck auf dem Kessel sozusagen. Das haben wir am sechsten Spieltag am Millantor zu spüren bekommen. Und jetzt auch in Rostock gab es da unschöne Szenen. Das wollte ich einfach nur kurz abseits des Platzes noch ergänzen, was natürlich auch so ein bisschen vielleicht die Gesamtgemengelage, die du gerade versuchst hast, sportlich einzuordnen, auch aus Fansicht ein bisschen zwar nicht relativiert und nicht legitimiert, aber vielleicht ein bisschen erklärt.
Ich merke schon, ich bin heute zu sportlich.
Ich komme gerne sonst immer auf Sportliche zurück. Also einmal als Ergänzung zu Yannick. Es ist ja eben so, dass sehr, sehr viele Parallelen tatsächlich zwischen Schalke und Bielefeld gezogen werden. Also wird Schalke die nächste Mannschaft sein, die durchgereicht wird von Liga 1 in Liga 3. Und ich dachte zwischendurch auch echt immer wieder so, ey, wie kann man denn genau die gleichen Fehler machen, die ihn in Amina Bielefeld gemacht hat? Also vorne eins Brian Lasmer verpflichten. Bestimmt ein super netter Mensch. Aber der Kerl, es tut mir einfach leid, wenn du sowieso schon Probleme hast, Invitore zu erzielen zum Teil, ist Brian Lasmer einfach nicht der richtige Mensch, weil der macht halt eine von zehn Chancen vornherein. Ich glaube menschlich braucht man den wirklich nicht ankreiden, aber weiß ich nicht. Für mich war das Kader-Zusammenstellung auch ein bisschen wild. Dann eben dieses –und das hast du eben auch angesprochen, Kevin, zwar bei Ron Schallenberg, aber wenn man bei Udo Régu –ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn richtig ausspreche, das tut mir schrecklich leid –das war ja auch wieder dieses, also dann nimmt man einen sehr, sehr jungen Spieler und den hyped man so auf. Und das kann –also gerade in einem Kader, wo du eben nicht nur einen Einzelspieler hast, den du sagst, okay, wir sind ein Team, das ist relativ klein, das hat vielleicht nur zwei, drei gute individuelle Spieler, die müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen rausheben. Okay, aber wenn du so einen Kader hast, der ja eigentlich von individualer Klasse eher so strotzt, dann ist das einfach nicht gut. Also dann wirst du dieses menschliche Gefüge glaube ich nicht unbedingt befeuern und dann ist bei Schalke das Problem, sie kriegen ja keine Konstanz in ihre Leistung und da kann ich auch aus Erfahrung sagen, das ist einfach, das wird dir am Ende der Saison richtig was kosten können. Weil wenn du, Michi hat es auch gesagt, diese Liga, die kannst du so einfach von hinten aufholen, wenn du einfach mal zwei, drei Spiele, vier Spiele gewinnst. Da hast du schon so viel. Vor allem, weil du es eigentlich nie hast, dass drei, vier Teams gleichzeitig in der gleichen Position eine Serie aufbauen. Hast du eigentlich so gut wie nie. Deshalb ist es umso wichtiger, so eine Serie aufzubauen. Und das Problem bei Schalke ist auch, die hatten zwei Spiele, die waren so vorbewilligt gegen Schalke, gegen HSV, sie haben gegen sich selber gespielt, gegen HSV und Düsseldorf, die glaube ich beide 5 zu 3 ausgegangen sind, aber immer für den Gegner. Und wenn du immer wieder diese Spiele drin hast, wo du als außenstehender Fan oder als außenstehender Zuschauer innen draufguckst und sagst so, boah heftig, was ging mir da ab? Und dann immer sagst du, aber Schalke ist am Ende immer die Mannschaft, die den Kürzeren zieht. Ich weiß irgendwie nicht, also das wäre vielleicht noch so eine Mannschaft, wo vielleicht ein Braunschweig auch vielleicht sogar aus der Brücke draufstehen könnte. Mir fehlt auch da so ein bisschen die Fantasie zu sagen, naja, werden sie es wirklich schaffen auf lange Sicht? Also sie hatten schon mal das Zweitliga-Jahr. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie absteigen werden, aber ich glaube, dass sie richtig, richtig Probleme haben werden. Und dass vielleicht sie naiverweise am Anfang der Saison dachten, Leute, wir machen das einfach wie vor zwei Jahren, sind wir ja auch wieder aufgestiegen. Und das ist einfach, das klappt nicht in dieser Liga. Das klappt einfach nicht.
Ich glaube aber, dass sie jetzt auf einem guten Weg sind. Und vor allem haben sie eins nicht gemacht, was du vorhin gesagt hast, Eva, wieder einen der bekannten Trainer geholt. Sondern sie haben einen sehr interessanten, spannenden Menschen geholt, der auch für die Spieler völlig neu ist und eine große Unbekannte war. Und sicherlich immer noch ist nach knapp zwei Monaten Amtszeit, wo man jetzt aber doch schon langsam sieht, man spricht immer auch so komisch vom Siegergehen und so weiter. Also der hat ja auch vor dem Spiel gegen Fürth gesagt, dass er mit dem Punkt nicht zufrieden ist. Auch wenn Fürth gerade gut drauf ist und eine starke Mannschaft in der zweiten Liga ist, er würde immer gewinnen wollen. Das ist natürlich eine Phrase, die ja auch jeder Fußballspieler und natürlich auch jeder andere Mensch in einer anderen Sportart immer so sagen würde, aber –sogar inzwischen Frankfurter gegen Bayern –das ist einfach ein Typ, der als Trainer bisher immer Erfolgs-Stories geschrieben hat in seiner jungen Karriere zugegebenermaßen noch oder relativ jungen Karriere, aber der einfach unverbraucht ist, wo die Spieler auch mal –gerade auch so Spieler wie Laszme, wie Schallenberg, Uedra Ogo –ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie man das spricht.
Uedra Ogo, glaube ich.
Uedra Ogo, ja. Ja, gut, dann doch so, wie man ihn schreibt.
Das glaube ich zumindest.
Ich glaube auch, aber es ist immer komisch. Wo diese Spieler auch nochmal quasi neu starten, Reset erfahren, jemanden haben, der ihnen auch auf absolute Rücken stärkt. Ja, er spricht kein Deutsch auf Pressekonferenzen oder in Interviews, großartig. Da haben die Schalker ja mit jedem schon mal schlechtere Erfahrungen gemacht, der aber weiß Gott auch ein größerer Name war. Vorher bei Chelsea, Di Matteo, meine ich natürlich. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, dass das sehr gut klappen kann. Die haben jetzt einen guten Drive in die Winterpause mitgenommen, was glaube ich sehr wichtig war. Haben auch einen T-Rodde wieder ein bisschen bei Laune bekommen, der, glaube ich, vorher einer der Stinkstiefel dann auch war in der Mannschaft, weil er nicht mehr so zum Zuge kam und natürlich auch frustriert war usw. Traue den schon zu, dass die –deswegen sprach ich gerade auch vom Run in der Rückrunde –dass die schon in der Rückrunde noch deutlich nach oben springen werden.
Und das könnte richtig was bedeuten. Also zum einen Kare Gerrits ist natürlich der bisher namenlose Trainer, von dem wir gesprochen haben, von Union Saint-Gilles. Also wir haben ihn quasi in der Europa League letztes Jahr auch beobachten können. Aus den letzten drei Spielen hat man sieben der 20 Punkte geholt, die man jetzt geholt hat. Und hat zweimal gewonnen gegen Osnabrück, gegen Hansa Rostock und eben jetzt das 2 zu 2 gegen die Spielvereinigung. Und das mit einer Viererkette und Raute. Viel für zwei Raute hat man da gespielt. Vielleicht ist das das neue System, in dem es erfolgreicher klappt. Und wenn man diesen Run fortsetzen sollte, jetzt über die Winterpause hinweg, dann hätte das insofern einen besonderen Wert, weil man nicht nur dann Siege holt oder Unentschieden, sondern man spielt vor allem gegen direkte Konkurrenz. Es geht noch nicht gleich los. Heimspiel gegen HSV, wobei Heimspiele auf Steige immer was Besonderes. Aber dann gegen Lautern auf dem Betzenberg, dann zu Hause gegen Braunschweig, dann wird man noch mal in Kiel spielen, und dann zu Hause gegen Wien-Wiesbaden. Also sollte man tatsächlich das schaffen, da stabil in die Rückrunde zu starten, dann könnte es sein, dass wir mit einem ganz anderen Puls über Schalke 04 sprechen in der Rückrunde. Thomas Schaaf freut sich über die Raute. Ich mich auch ein bisschen. Rauten kommen jetzt wieder zurück und ich muss sagen, ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht. Also stand ich vor ein paar Jahren noch kritischer gegenüber, aber sogar Leverkusen hat manchmal so Raute-Elemente mit drin. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wobei die Raute ja auf den Flügeln am Platz gibt, dann flanken immer die Gegner. Also es ist einfach ein Jammer. Fußball-Abschaffung, Flanken-Provizen. Wann kommt endlich diese Initiative? Nun ja, bevor ich mich wieder in Rage rede, reden wir über den 1. FC Magdeburg. Denn der ist jetzt dran, liegt auf Rang 13, hat ebenfalls 20 Punkte, hat auch ein spektakuläres Spiel damals auf Schalke gemacht. Das war eines jener Spiele, die Schalke gewinnen konnte, nämlich damals noch mit 4 zu 3 zu Hause. Und Magdeburg, da können wir jetzt endlich Yannick auch mal länger zu Wort kommen lassen. Er sitzt schon auf ganz heißen Kohlen. Ihr könnt das ja nicht sehen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Was müssen wir denn zu Magdeburg wissen? Es ist ja auch bei Magdeburg immer viel los. 58 Torbeteiligungen sind es hier, 30 geschossen, 28 kassiert. Also eine positive Torbilanz. Erstes Team mit einer positiven Bilanz, über das wir sprechen.
Ja, tatsächlich. Also man muss ja erst einmal eingangs sagen, es ist jetzt das schwierige zweite Jahr nach dem Aufstieg. Man war ja zur letzten Saison fulminant als Tabellenerster der dritten Liga aufgestiegen. Ich bin auch echt zu weit weg, um mich in Magdeburg auszukennen. Einfach mal so ein bisschen in Magdeburger Kreisen umgehört. Da gibt es einen Knackpunkt, den hast du gerade quasi schon indirekt erwähnt. Das ist nämlich dieses besagte Spiel gegen Schalke. Aber ich kann ja erst mal allgemein mit dem Saisonverlauf anfangen. Es gab erst mal ein Unentschieden zum Auftakt in Wiesbaden. Dann konnte man zu Hause gegen Braunschweig gewinnen. Dann ist man darauf in der ersten Runde im DFB-Pokal weitergekommen gegen Regensburg. Dann gab es ein 4 zu 2 Auswärtssieg in Kiel. Und dann –und das könnte sich tatsächlich –also ich habe auch bei den Kollegen vom Nur der FCM Podcast liebe Grüße an Alex und Thomas reingehört. Also beide Seiten können sich bis heute nicht erklären, wie dieses Spiel am vierten Spieltag zwischen Sankt Pauli und Magdeburg 0 zu 0 aussehen konnte. Und tatsächlich stand Magdeburg danach auf Platz 2. Und Sankt Pauli war damals noch sieb, da das sollte sich dann irgendwann ein bisschen umkehren. Genau, dann gab es ein völlig wildes 6 zu 4 gegen Hertha BSC, wo man irgendwie wahlweise –ich glaube, es war immer so ein Schlagabtausch zwischen 0-1, 1-1 und immer so weiter, bis man dann irgendwann mit 6 zu 4 als Sieger vom Platz gehen konnte. Und dann hat mir Diana aus Magdeburg –auch da, liebe Grüße, wenn du das hörst –erzählt, dass dann diese 3 zu 4 Auswehrsniederlage aufschalke. Ja, so ein bisschen der Knackpunkt war, da war man zwar damals noch Tabellen dritter, aber dann gab es daraufhin nur ein 1 zu 1 zu Hause gegen Paderborn, ein 0 zu 1 in Nürnberg, ein 1 zu 1 gegen Karlsruhe, ein 1 zu 2 in Hannover, ein 1 zu 2 Heimniederlage gegen die Aufsteiger aus Elbersberg, einziger Lichtblick zu der Zeit, das Weiterkommen im DFB-Pokal in der zweiten Runde, nach Elfmeterschießen gegen Holstein Kiel. Dann war man auch in Hamburg zu Gast und hat 0 zu 2 verloren, war damals dann schon 13. Es ging dann weiter mit Heimniederlage gegen Rostock und dann konnte man endlich am 14. Spieltag mal wieder gewinnen gegen die direkte Konkurrenz zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil man war schon 14. und hat 2 zu 0 gegen den Tabellen-8-Zäten aus der Brücke gewonnen. Also man sieht schon zwischen diesem Spiel auf Schalke und dem Spiel, der darauf folgte, da ist auf jeden Fall so ein Knackpunkt passiert und man hat daraus dann nicht mehr viele Punkte holen können. Dazu passt dann auch, dass man vielleicht in der Fairness-Tabelle ist man auch nur 17. Mit nämlich 48 gesammelten gelben Garten. Und jetzt kommt das Highlight, was ich auch bei den Kollegen vom Null der FCM-Podcast gehört habe. Rund 15 davon resultieren nicht aus Fouls, sondern aus Meckern, Rangeleien, Spielverzögerungen, was auch immer. Und dann kommen noch zwei Platzverweise dazu. Also da ist man auf jeden Fall auch, was die Verteilung von bunten Kartons angeht, auch ganz weit vorne. Und ja, ähnlich wie andere Mannschaften, zu denen wir später im Verlauf unserer Aufnahme hier noch kommen, hat man auch das Problem, das ist ein ziggemäßes Zitat auch aus dem Podcast der Jungs, dass ein Spiel von Magdeburg zweimal 45 Minuten dauert, denn man spielt entweder wahlweise eine gute und eine schlechte Halbzeit. Und ja, lag in der Hinrunde neunmal in Führung, hat davon aber nur fünf Siege geholt und auch noch drei Niederlagen. Also man hätte eigentlich 27 Punkte haben können, wenn man denn jede Führung nach Hause gebracht hätte. Ja, hätte, hätte Fahrradkette und so. Genau, also das ist auf jeden Fall ein signifikantes Problem von Magdeburg, dass man Führungen nicht nach Hause tragen kann. Und ja, als kleines Drumherum hätte ich noch einzuwerfen, dass Intel plant, einen Standort in Magdeburg aufzubauen und da sich dann auch als namhafter Sponsor beim FCM angekündigt hat. Das wären so erstmal meine Two Cents zum FCM.
Kevin hat sich auch noch ein bisschen damit befasst. Ich darf ergänzen, es ist natürlich alles in Magdeburg wie immer. Also das ist Tietz-Fußball, 61, nee 62 Prozent Ballbesitz im Schnitt. Das ist mit weitem Abstand der meiste der Liga. Aber man sieht, Ballbesitz ist eben nicht alles. Sie geben eben auch immer wieder Spieler aus der Hand. Das sind die berühmten zwei Hälften. So ist man ja unter anderem auch gegen Fortuna im DFB-Pokal ausgeschieden. Das haben wir indirekt in der letzten Ligatur besprochen zur zweiten Liga. Da hatten wir ja auch Fortuna Düsseldorf als einen der Schwerpunkte. Kevin, was ist denn noch zu ergänzen zu Magdeburg?
Dass sie offenbar –und ich habe auch mit dem lieben Thomas noch korrespondiert im Vorfeld –deswegen auch von mir schöne Grüße an die beiden. In diesem Fall an Thomas, aber ich mag beide gerne. Dass sie halt auch den passenden Mittelstürmer nämlich nicht haben für diesen Ballbesitz. Er hat gesagt, da haben sie ein großes Problem, die treffen nicht oder der trifft nicht, wie auch immer. Also der Sturm ist nicht so erfolgreich. Dafür hatten sie mehr Glück mit den Joker-Toren. Da haben sie nämlich schon neun Stück diese Saison erzielt, was ein ziemlich guter Wert sein dürfte. Er hat übrigens vom Spiel gegen Hertha, vom Freak-Spiel gesprochen, weil er ist tatsächlich in Magdeburg viel mal im Rückstand gewesen und hat das dann gedreht. Das Spiel habe ich damals tatsächlich auch gesehen. Also im Nachhinein natürlich nicht vorher, weil ich mir dachte, das interessiert mich nicht unbedingt. Hertha sowieso nicht.
Du bist so gnadenlos ehrlich, das ist fantastisch.
Na ja, das ist einfach so. Der FCM ist halt einfach auch so ein Verein. Wir sind ja ein paar Jahre mit denen auch durch die dritte Liga gemeinsam gegangen als SCP. Deswegen haben wir auch sehr oft zusammen gepodcastet dann, Pardercast und nur der FCM. Und es war auch so ein bisschen Rivalität an der Tabellenspitze dann eine Zeit lang. Leider haben die immer gewonnen. Also am Ende sind die immer Herbstmeister oder Meister geworden. Und wir leider ja nie, sind ja nie Erster geworden. Auf jeden Fall ist es eigentlich ein Verein, der nämlich zumindest in meiner Kenntnis nicht diese Problematik hat, die viele andere Ostvereine haben. Er hat, glaube ich, eine sehr gesunde Fanbase. Zumindest das, was ich mitbekomme. Es ist eine hammermäßige Stimmung in diesem Stadion. Und es macht echt Spaß, wenn da die Post abgeht, da auch mal zuzuschauen. Auch als neutraler Beobachter. Wir haben da diese Saison als SC Paderborn gespielt. Das war echt ein schweres Spiel. Magdeburg hat dieses verflichste zweite Jahr. Und sie nehmen es echt mit Kampf auch an, ihn fehlt. Und sie waren auch gegen uns echt nicht schlecht. Man hat aber gemerkt, dass ihnen tatsächlich wirklich der Qualitätsstürmer fehlt. Denn dann könnten die, glaube ich, deutlich weiter oben stehen, wenn sie den oder die hätten. Das fehlt ihnen bei allem Ballbesitz. Titz hat da, glaube ich, echt ganz gut gearbeitet, seitdem er da ist. Zuerst war das ja so ein bisschen, ist das so der richtige Trainer, der richtige Trainer auch in der richtigen Stadt. Aber ich finde es schon, ich freue mich auch, ich würde auch unbedingt wollen, dass Magdeburg drin bleibt in der Liga, ich wollte die sehr bereichern. Was übrigens interessant ist, sie haben ja diese Führung teilweise verdeidelt, sie sind aber auch eine Mannschaft, die bei wieviel, das muss ich jetzt einmal spicken, aus jedem zweiten Spiel, wo sie in den Rückstand geraten sind, konnten sie noch etwas zählbares mitnehmen. Also im Umkehrschluss haben sie auch immer noch wieder Moral, die sie immer wieder noch zu Punkten bringt.
Comeback-Qualitäten.
Mentalität, verdammt. Ich bin jetzt wirklich der, der das sagen muss.
Jetzt werfen wir gleich alle etwas ins Schweinchen ein. Thomas hat übrigens noch ergänzt, Yannick, mit den gelben Karten, dass man in dieser Saison, das möchte ich jetzt gerne zitieren, wie hat er das gesagt, und auch die fehlende Körperlichkeit ist gerne ein Problem bei uns, was ich gut ausfinde, bei der Anzahl von gelben Karten.
Na ja, wenn man sich durch Meckern holt, so kann ich mir auch eine Karte holen. Das ist ja der Mario-Götze-Ansatz auf Fußballspiel. Aber Michi wollte noch etwas ergänzen.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, die ich jetzt ergänzen wollte. Natürlich das richtige Wort für Mentalität ist gewinnen wollen, hat Alexander Zorniger jetzt neu eingeführt. Also sie haben immer später v.a. brutale Schritte im Gewinnen wollen gemacht.
Und das meint er wirklich als ein Wort?
Das Gewinnen wollen, ja. Ich schreibe es immer mit, also groß und gekoppelt halt. Das Gewinnen wollen.
Das darf man ja im Deutschen machen, aber ob man es machen sollte, egal. Mach weiter.
Ja, und es ist witzig, wir reden seit 1,5 Stunden über die 2.
Liga.
Und das ist jetzt der erste Verein, bei dem es wirklich auch Spaß macht, ein Fußballspiel anzuschauen, finde ich. Also ich habe sie vor ein paar Wochen –ich meine, ich bin ein Freund des schönen Fußballs. Ein Freund des schönen Fußballs. Und wirklich, ich mag das, wenn Mannschaften auch den Mut haben, sich mal hinten rauszuspielen. Es war als No-Front gegen andere Vereine davor, aber es ist einfach schöner, den FC Magdeburg spielen zu sehen. Also ich war wirklich begeistert. Und auch wenn sie Tabellen 13 sind, und die haben sich mit einer Ruhe und Selbstverständlichkeit gegen eine Mannschaft, die davor fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen hatte, einfach von hinten jedes Mal wieder rausgespielt. Und es ist einfach auch jedes Mal fast gut gegangen. Weil sie diese Selbstverständlichkeit haben, den Christian Titz-Fußball, der ihnen das einfach einbläut. Wir machen das jetzt so. Und ich mag diese Standhaftigkeit, auch wenn die vielleicht mal dazu führt, dass man Spieler aus der Hand gibt. Oder dass man vielleicht mal auch wilde Dinge macht. Letztes Jahr haben sie auch in Fürth dann 3-0 verloren, weil sie einfach in der Abwehr komische Dinge gemacht haben. Weil halt für diesen Fußball, der so viel Beibesitzung, sozusagen als zentrales Element hat, einfach nicht vielleicht die spielerische Qualität haben. Aber ich mag es, so einen Ansatz einfach stringent verfolgt. Diese Philosophie, wie Kevin vorhin sagte, also Magdeburg hat eine Philosophie. Und ja, Lukas Tanius hat den Viertz zum Beispiel in der Mittelspiel bei Magdeburg. Der hat schon auch viele Chancen vergeben. Also ich dachte mir, bei ein, zwei Chancen, die könnten wir schon auch mal machen als 2. Liga-Stürmer. Und dann würden sie tatsächlich weiter oben stehen. Aber ich denke, sie werden auf jeden Fall drin bleiben, weil die individuelle Qualität ist zu gut. Auch diese Comeback-Qualitäten, die Yannick gerade angesprochen hat, habe ich in Fürth auch gesehen. Weil ich habe da in der 95. mit einem wunderschönen Schuss, den auch nicht viele 2. Liga-Spieler machen, Daniel Fadli in den Winkel, dann Elhan Kouri war es, Mohamed Elhan Kouri in den Winkel rein, den Ball geschlänzt. Also es macht einfach Spaß, finde ich, ihn zuzuschauen. Deswegen sind es immer noch eine Bereicherung für die 2. Liga. Deswegen wünsche ich ihm, dass sie weiter hochkommen. Und auch ganz uneigennützig, weil ich sie mal als Aufstiegskandidat getippt hatte. Vielleicht ist Platz 8 oder 7 ganz schön, dass ich nicht ganz mein Gesicht verlieren muss.
Ja, sehr gut. Aber da kann ich dir nur raten als jemand, der ja jede Saison Tipps abgibt und jede Saison erlebe ich es wieder. Man muss sich das abgewöhnen, irgendwann seinen Tipps hinterher zu jagen. Let it go. Ich habe Stuttgart als Absteiger getippt oder als Fastabsteiger. So etwas passiert einfach. Da muss man einfach dazu stehen und sagen, ich wusste es halt nicht besser. So ist es eben. Aber Magdeburg, sehr, sehr viel schon zu sehen. Sehr viel Spektakel, sehr viel interessanter Fußball und interessanter Fakt. Elfmal lag man zurück, ich meine viermal alleine im Spiel gegen Hertha BSC. Wie viele Spiele hat man gewonnen bei diesen elf Rückständen? Eines, das gegen Hertha BSC. Das war das Einzige, das man noch drehen konnte, aber immerhin drei Unentschieden. Es sind aktuell drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsrang. Wir sind mal sehr gespannt, was Christian Thijs da macht. Definitiv ist es interessant, jemanden zu sehen, der seiner Philosophie treu bleibt und die Fußball bejahend ist. Damit kann man aber dennoch Erfolg haben. Allein deshalb sind das schon mal Grundsympathien. Ich glaube, sie flanken auch nicht so oft, wenn ich das richtig abgespeichert habe.
Die einfachste Suche ist die des nach den Knipsern im Fußball. Nur linker Verteidiger ist, glaube ich, schwieriger. Ich finde das auch wirklich erfrischend. Ich bin da voll bei euch, die gehören in die Liga. Es macht einfach auch Spaß, das zu sehen, wie der Funken überspringt aufs Publikum und wie es dann da rund geht. Das habe ich in den letzten Jahren immer verfolgt. Auch damals in der dritten Liga, das ist stark, schwer beeindruckend. Und auch für die Gästemannschaften ganz, ganz schwer dort zu bestehen.
Und noch auswärts übrigens. Auch wenn die zu Gast sind irgendwo. Das ist eine der lautesten Gästekurven, die ich am Milan Tor jemals gehört habe, auf jeden Fall.
Ach Magdeburg, und das alles im Jahr, in dem sich der Europapokalsieg jährt. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema hier hinter mir. Für die, die bei YouTube sind, hier hinter mir, hängt ein Europapokalsieger Magdeburgwimpel. Den habe ich auf meiner Lesung im Magdeburg bekommen, die im Rahmen des Europapokalsieges stattfindet. Also, da hat man auch gegen Bayern gespielt im Jahr danach. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Wir waren bei Teams, die Spaß machen, zuzugucken. Und zuletzt hat es auch Spaß gemacht, dem KSC zuzugucken. Denn in den letzten fünf Spielen ist man ungeschlagen geblieben. Dreimal hat man zwei zu zwei Unentschieden gespielt und zweimal noch gewinnen können. Und das ist aber sehr, sehr wichtig. Denn diese neun Punkte bedeuten, dass der KSC bei 21 insgesamt steht. Und da wissen wir, es war zwischendurch schon mal ganz schön happig bei Karlsruhe. Man hat eine ausgeglichene Bilanz, 30 geschossene Tore, 30 kassierte Tore. Man hat unheimlich viele Themen von neben dem Platz. Wir haben ja dazu schon einen Schwerpunkt gemacht mit dem lieben Jörn Kreuzer. Seitdem sind schon wieder mehrere Staffeln passiert vom Haus auf Karlsruhe. Yannick hat sich dessen angenommen und wird uns jetzt Sportliches, nicht Sportliches. Ich weiß es nicht, du kannst alles Kulinarisches wegen mir. Was müssen wir zum KSC wissen?
Ja, es ist die Frage, wie viel Zeit haben wir noch mitgebracht, nachdem wir jetzt nach 90 Minuten erst bei Platz 12 angekommen sind. Das könnte noch ein bisschen länger gehen heute Abend, würde ich vermuten. Ja, ich habe ein buntes Potpourri aus sportlich neben dem Platz und allen möglichen mitgebracht. Bleiben wir erst mal beim rein sportlichen, was ich gerade schon gesagt habe. 21 Punkte sind jetzt auf jeden Fall auf Platz 12. Das ist ein sehr ausstrichendes Torverhältnis von 30 zu 30. Von meinem Kollegen Tim habe ich gelernt, dass man meistens in einem 4-4-2 aufläuft. Das kann dann entweder eine Raute sein. Ich habe vom Kollegen Fadi aus Nürnberg gedacht, man kann auch Drachen-Fier-Eck sagen. Das finde ich natürlich viel schöner. Man könnte vermuten, warum ich vermeide das Wort Raute auszusprechen.
Jetzt ist der Groschen auch bei mir gefallen.
Es ist spät. Auf jeden Fall ist auch schon mit der Doppel-Sechs aufgelaufen. Aber wie gesagt, entweder noch das Drachen-Fier-Eck. Jetzt im direkten Vergleich, weil wir es ja gerade hatten, ist man Platz 1 in der Fanestabelle mit nur 32 gelben Karten und noch keinem Platzverweis. Und jetzt wird es schwierig von außen einzuschätzen. Denn man hatte zwar einen guten Saisonstart. Danach hat man aber auch nur zwei Siege aus zehn Spielen geholt und war zwischendurch auf Platz 14 in der Tabelle. Ich weiß von Jörn Kreuzer, mit dem habe ich mich auch im Vorfeld aus unserer Aufnahme hier unterhalten. Er macht zum einen eine zu geringe Tiefe im Kader aus. Das sind nur 22 Feldspieler. Fun Fact, auch der FC St. Pauli hat nur 22 nominelle Feldspieler. Also Klopf auf Holz. Dass da nichts passiert. Dazu kommen wir später noch. Ich glaube, einer der Gründe, dass wir da bisher verschont blieben. Aber ich schweife ab. Du hast schon gesagt, in der Formtabelle ist man sehr gut dabei. Mit zwei Siegen und drei Unentschieden. Hat man sich da jetzt so langsam gefangen. Und ist deshalb jetzt zumindest ins relativ gesunde Mittelfeld vorgerückt. Zum Winter hin. Dann habe ich von den Kollegen von den Wildpark-Budlern gelernt, dass man sich wohl zu viele Tore in den Schlussminuten oder auch in der Nachspielzeit fängt. Da hat man wohl auch einige Punkte liegen lassen. Ich habe das jetzt nicht mehr in Zahlen elaborieren können in der Kürze der Zeit. Und ja, wie gesagt, ein sehr wechselhafter Saisonverlauf. Bisher von einem guten Start, dann diese zehn Spiele, wo man kaum Punkte holen konnte. Tim hat sie mal in der Vorschau auf ihr Spiel bei uns als Dark Horse bezeichnet. Man weiß nie genau, was man so bekommt. Das ist dann halt so die, kann gut laufen, kann auch schlecht laufen. Boris von den Wildpapugeln hat es als Achterbahnfahrt bezeichnet. Genau, das wäre es erst mal zum rein sportlichen Verlauf. Du hast ja gerade schon angekündigt, wie viel die Staffel auch immer vom Haus auf Karlsruhe. Man könnte jetzt von außen erst mal sagen, so mit gut Platz 12, einigermaßen gefestigt, könnte man jetzt von außen betrachtet sagen, hat jetzt die Leistung des Teams nur so bedingt beeinflusst. So, jetzt müssen wir vielleicht einmal kurz –also wie ging es denn überhaupt los? Wir erinnern uns, es gab zwei Fronten in der Vorstandsetage sozusagen, seit der Entlassung von dem nicht verwandt und nicht verschwägerten –oh, Vorname entfallen, Kreuzer. Oliver Kreuzer, danke. Genau, nicht verwandt und nicht verschwägert mit jedem Jörn Kreuzer.
Ach so, ja, nicht mit Jörn. Genau, ich habe gerade überlegt, mit wem soll der verwandt gewesen sein. Und es gab zwei Fronten, das eine war die Volksfront von Karlsruhe und das andere war die Karlsruhe Volksfront. Aber das ist nur für Insider.
Gut, genau, also seitdem hat sich quasi dieser Kindergarten oder diese Vorabendserie oder Netflix-Serie, wie auch immer man sie einordnen möchte, hat sich da entsponnen. Und jetzt ist die aktuellste Episode quasi jetzt Anfang des Monats gewesen mit der Mitgliederversammlung, wo es zunächst im Vorfeld Abwahlanträge gegen insgesamt vier Personen aus der Vorstandsetage gab, unter anderem gegen den Präsidenten Holger Sigmund Schulze und Vizepräsident Martin Müller. Die wurden dann aber auf der MV selber durch einen Antrag gestrichen. Fun Fact dazu, also er sollte mal mit so bunten Kärtchen abstimmen. Das war aber dann irgendwie im Saal nicht gut zu erkennen und nicht eindeutig. Und deshalb musste ein sogenannter Hammelsprung her. Für alle, die nicht wissen, was das ist, alle mussten einmal den Saal verlassen und dann, je nachdem, wie ihre Stimme ausfallen, sollte durch eine bestimmte Tür wieder hereinkommen. Also gut, wer schon mal auf Mittel der Versammlung von Fußballvereinen war, weiß, es kann nicht schaden, zwischendurch auch ein bisschen aufzustehen und sich die Beine zu vertreten. Von daher, genau, sind diese Anträge dann gestrichen worden. Mit der Begründung, dass man eben dann, ja, sollten die dann, also, während sie durchgegangen wäre, der KSC ja quasi führungslos gewesen. Und das wollte man vermeiden. Zumal ja wohl in den letzten Wochen zumindest, ja, Gespräche der Annäherung stattgefunden haben. Was aber auch stattgefunden hat, ist eine Nichtentlastung des gerade schon erwähnten Vizepräsidenten Martin Müller. Und im Nachgang der MV dann auch, ja, das Anraten des Aufsichtsrates an eben jeden Martin Müller doch bitte zurückzutreten. Das ist bis heute der Aufnahme nicht passiert. Er erwägt es aber zumindest, was man so der Presse entnehmen kann. Die Fernszene sieht das ganz eindeutig, was er tun sollte. Hat dann nämlich dann auch mit zu einem Transparent reagiert, dass da lautete, Warnschuss ignoriert, Fehler nicht reflektiert, nur Unruhe produziert. Müller, ist das dein Schulterschluss? Und es gibt sehr schöne Sticker, die einen Wortspiel mit einem gewissen Firmennamen nennen, sich dann Ausgem Müllert. Also die Fernszene ist sich da ganz eindeutig einig, dass Müller nicht mehr erwünscht ist. Und wie gesagt, er überlegt da noch und möchte da das Gespräch mit dem Verein suchen, wie man das denn –ja, wie das alles zugunsten des Vereins, weil um nichts anderes ging es natürlich die ganze Zeit. Vielleicht muss man dann noch ergänzen, dass sich das Ganze vor allem daran aufgehangen hat, dass er wohl bei den ganzen Querelen, die es gab und wo ja auch vieles in der Presse gelandet ist, dann auch eben diesen Kontakt zur Presse gesucht hat. Das ist vor allem das, was vielen Teilen der Fans und auch des Umfelds sauer aufgestoßen ist. Und er hat wohl –will ich jetzt wieder Jörn Kreuzer sinngemäß zitieren –auf der MV gesagt, ja, ihm hat er Angst um den KSC und deshalb ist er an die Presse gegangen. Das wird er heute nicht mehr machen. Das wäre ja auch alles viel zu stressig. Also so Einsicht gleich Null, muss man mal sagen. Und von daher warten wir gespannt auf die nächste Folge oder Episode oder Staffel vom Haus auf Karlsruhe.
Ja und ich kann dazu nur sagen, wenn Sie da draußen das jetzt gerade hören und auch Angst um Ihren Verein haben und der in den ersten –ich sag mal drei deutschen Ligenspielt melden Sie sich gerne beim Rasenfunk. Hier bekommen Sie ein offenes Ohr.
Am besten nicht bei Feng Shui Meistern. Das kann ich nämlich nicht empfehlen, wenn der Verein Stress hat.
Genau. Nicht irgendwelche komischen überteuerten Dinge aufheben fürs Schi, sondern melden Sie sich doch für schlechte Wortspiele direkt bei mir. Aber das ist etwas anderes. Ja, der KSC. Es ist immer was los. Jetzt geht das Gerücht um, dass der Hauptsponsor noch pleite ist. Das war eine der jüngsten Entwicklungen noch. Und das, obwohl eigentlich so viele Grundfaktoren gerade gut sind. Das neue Stadion mit Christian Eichnen, interessanten Trainer, der war jetzt am Montag bei RONDO TV. Ich habe es nicht gesehen, deswegen weiß ich leider nicht genau, was er da gesagt hat. Ich werde es aber mal verlinken. Ich denke, für alle KSC-Fans ist es zumindest interessant, sich anzusehen. Was auf jeden Fall noch besser werden muss, ist Führung über die Zeit bringen. Ich habe KSC-Fans in meiner näheren Umgebung. Und es ist wirklich egal, wie hoch der KSC führt. Sie gehen immer davon aus, dass es noch ein Unentschieden-Minimum wird. Und was soll ich sagen? Inzwischen gehe ich auch davon aus, weil ich habe jetzt auf die Hardtour gelernt. Ja, stimmt, so ist das wirklich. 12 Mal lag man schon in Führung in dieser Saison. Immerhin 5 Mal davon konnte man noch gewinnen. 3 Mal hat man noch verloren. 4 Mal ein Remis. Aber das ist im Liga-Durchschnitt dann schon nicht ganz so gut. Also man rangiert da –also die Teams, die quasi zweistellige Führung hatten, aber 5 Siege oder weniger hatten, das sind Lautern und Karlsruhe. Und alle anderen haben es mindestens 6, 7 oder mehrmals noch geschafft zu gewinnen. Ganz oben natürlich Heustern, Kiel und der FC St. Pauli. Aber zu denen kommen wir später. Jetzt wollen wir über wen Wiesbaden sprechen. Mit denen hat sich Eva auseinandergesetzt. Einer der drei Aufsteiger und allein an der Lücke, die wir jetzt haben, zeitlich gesehen und auch in der Tabelle zu Osnabrück sehen wir für die anderen beiden, wen Wiesbaden und Elbersberg läuft es viel, viel besser. Das bedeutet in Punkten 22, 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. 19 Tore erzielt, 22 kassiert. Also so ein bisschen das Anti-Scheike in dem Sinne. Bei Scheike passiert immer viel, bei wen Wiesbaden wenig. Aber es bleiben mehr Punkte dabei hängen. Aktuell zumindest zwei Punkte mehr als Scheike 04. Eva, was ist zu wen Wiesbaden zu wissen?
Ja, ich habe ja mit Wiesbaden auch so ein bisschen meine persönliche Beziehung tatsächlich. Aber ja, also generell muss man glaube ich durchaus Respekt zahlen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe es nicht erwartet, dass sie doch so stabil in die Saison reinrutschen. Weil ja, also unter anderem weil sie einen Leistungsträger Wiener, Benedikt Hollerbach, unter anderem verloren haben. Aber man könnte schon sagen, okay, Offensiv habe es auf jeden Fall noch. Also man hat mit 19 Treffern eben, ja, ich sage mal, die schlechteste Offensive außerhalb dieser Abstiegsränge quasi. Also da ist definitiv noch zu wenig. Aber muss auch sagen, eine sehr, sehr stabile Defensive. Also gerade der Torhüter-Stritzel, der sticht echt raus, ist da eher in den Top-Torhütern zu finden, sage ich mal, mit seinen 4 zu 0-Spielen. Ich finde das für einen Aussteiger nach 17 Spielen schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Aber wenn wir wirklich nochmal auf die eigenen geschossenen Tore zurückkommen.
Ich hatte ganz kurz noch zum Torhüter, das habe ich mir nämlich vorher rausgesucht, wem Wiesbaden hat die höchste Differenz zwischen dem Post-Shocked Expected-Ghost-Vet und den Gegentoren, die man gefangen hat. Also woran man ja immer die Qualität von Torhüter ganz gut ablesen kann. Und zwar mit weitem Abstand, plus 5,0. Dahinter kommt Hannover 96 auf Platz 2 mit 1,7. Also es ist statistisch gesehen der beste Torhüter der 2. Liga. Es kommen natürlich noch andere Komponenten dazu, aber ich wollte das unterstreichen. Und jetzt darfst du das weiter machen.
Also es ist halt wirklich eigentlich ein perfekter Showcase, sage ich mal, was man immer als MVP bezeichnet. Also als Most Valuable Player ein Spieler, ohne den dieser Verein definitiv nicht dastehen würde, wo er steht. Und das kann man immer wieder sagen, glaube ich, als Aussteiger ist das ein richtig, richtig großes Faustpfand, wenn du eine gute Defensive hast. Weil wir sehen gerade eben, wir haben jetzt ganz, ganz viel über Defensiven gesprochen, auch von Vereinen, die eben unten drin stehen, weil die Defensive nicht gut ist und eben nicht nur die Offensive nicht ausreichend. Also das ist super wichtig. Wenn wir dann eben jetzt kurz auf die geschossenen Tore kommen. Ich habe noch mal in die Ligatour Anfang der Saison reingehört, als du mit Sonja Riegel darüber gesprochen hast. Da ging es auch schon um die Wangel der Abschlussqualität, möchte ich mal sagen. Man hat in nur vier Spielen mehr als ein Tor geschossen. Ich glaube, zweimal zwei, zweimal drei waren es am Ende. Dafür hat man aber eben auch Unentschieden gegen Hamburg und St. Pauli geholt. Ich glaube, dann nimmt man das gerne in Kauf, wenn dann nur ein Tor geschossen wurde. Aber es ist eben so zweitwenigste Abschlüsse der Liga mit 202. St. Pauli ist da Spitzenreiter und hat dann, glaube ich, 100 mehr, glaube ich. Aber generell kann man, glaube ich, sagen, was jetzt an Mäckerei kommt, sage ich mal, kommt auf hohem Niveau, weil man eben der Zweitbeste, der Aussteiger ist. Dass wir über Elversberg noch nicht gesprochen haben, hat natürlich auch seinen Grund. Aber man kann schon mal sagen, Wiesbadens Saison jetzt verläuft um einiges besser als die letzte zweitigere Saison. Ich glaube, deshalb habe ich sie nicht erwartet, weil sie natürlich auch als letzter Aussteiger erst feststanden. Aber zuletzt lief es nicht so optimal. Die letzten vier Spiele waren sieglos. Aber man hat St. Pauli die Herbstmeisterschaft versaut. Also nicht nur ein bisschen, sondern man hat es versaut, weil man da sehr effizient war. Also ein Schuss aufs Tor und ein Tor. Das ist natürlich für Wiesbaden der maximale Ertrag. Für St. Pauli natürlich super bitter gewesen. Aber ich sage mal so, für das, was Wiesbaden erreichen will, nämlich den Klassenerhalt, ganz ehrlich, ist dann schon sehr gut. Und du hast es ja mit dem Torhüter schon angesprochen. Das ist dann natürlich auch praktisch. Worauf sie sehr kommen, sind Standards. Also das ist etwas, wo man als Gegner immer wieder aufpassen muss. In Wiesbaden kommt sehr viel über Standards. Was man natürlich sagen muss, ist eine Qualität, die man mitbringen kann. Wenn man sagt, vielleicht kommen wir nicht komplett überspielerische. Davon abgesehen, dass Kowalczynski ja durchaus ein Trainer ist, den man in der 2. Liga auch kennt. Aber kann man ja trotzdem sagen, wenn wir darüber kommen, also ich glaube, 8 der 19 Tore haben sie aus Standards erzählt und dann noch 2 über 11 Meter, ist eine gute Bilanz. Weil im Unterschied zu vielleicht anderen Dingen, die man gut unterbinden kann, sind Standards was, was du halt nie immer komplett aus einem Spiel rausnehmen kannst, ob es Freistöße sind oder eben, ob es einfach Ecken sind. Und ich glaube, das ist etwas, wo du natürlich immer wieder weißt, okay, da haben sie, da bringen sie ihre Qualität mit. Da ist vor allem Robin Huyse auch nicht ganz unwichtig. Der hat eben neben dem Tor der Strieze die meisten Spiele gemacht, alle 17 und ist so mit für die Standards zuständig. Was ich tatsächlich ganz interessant fand, was ich so erstmal nicht glauben konnte, der Wiesbaden hat den höchsten Gesamtmarktwerk von allen Aussteigern. 15,75 Millionen laut Transfermarkt, natürlich immer ein bisschen Vorsicht behandeln. Und direkt da drüber ist tatsächlich der Karlsruher SC mit 16,25. Aber sie stehen damit immer noch relativ weit unten in der Tabelle, aber haben tatsächlich von allen Aussteigern den höchsten Gesamtmarktwert. Fand ich tatsächlich sehr interessant, weil ich es auch so nicht erwartet hatte. Aber ja, auch da ist so ein bisschen das Thema nach Rückständen und nach Führung. Also sie sind zehnmal in Führung gegangen, haben zumindest noch sechsmal gewonnen. Ist eine okaye Balance, würde ich sagen, aber haben eben auch erst nach Rückstand gewinnen können. Und das war tatsächlich gegen Kaiserslautern am 13. Spieltag. Also generell Wiesbaden ist tatsächlich eine Mannschaft, die ich sonst immer sehr schwierig einzuschätzen finde. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe Kauzinski, er ist halt ein Trainer, der sich durchaus auch einen gewissen Ruf erarbeitet hat. Ich muss sagen, dass ich hier unfassbar schwierig gerade in der Liga 2 finde. Also für mich ist er tatsächlich, das klingt immer super abwertend, aber er ist eher der tatsächliche Drittliga-Trainer, weil ich ihn da immer eher verordnet habe. Ich finde, in der 2. Liga hat er mich nicht immer komplett überzeugt, wo er dann tätig war. Aber ich lasse mich auch gerne vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Und wie gesagt, Herr Yannick, ich wusste es.
Genau, und das auch nur digital. Kauzinski hatte ja auch eine Vergangenheit bei uns. Ich war damals, als er da war, nicht so überzeugt. Er stand immer so mit beiden Händen in der Hosentasche an der Seitenlinie und wirkte nach außen eher wie der Busfahrer, der darauf war, dass er die Mannschaft wieder zurück vom Gelände fahren kann. Ich halte nicht so viel von ihm. Aber ich meine, Wiesbaden, wir sprechen jetzt erst nach knapp zwei Stunden über See. Das spricht ja eigentlich für seine Arbeit dort. Das soll ihm dann auch gegönnt sein. Du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, das war jetzt das letzte Spiel vor der Winterpause, als Wiesbaden bei uns zu Gast war. Und es fühlte sich halt aus St. Pauli-Sicht wie in der Niederlage an. Weil, wie du schon gesagt hast, man hätte auch da wieder mindestens 3-4-0 führen können, aber es hat versäumt, mindestens noch einen Schuh mehr zu machen. Ja, das war dann leider zu wenig.
Aber diese Ruhe von Markus Korczinski hilft, glaube ich, so einem Standort wie Wiesbaden auch sehr, weil er halt immer die Ruhe bewahrt. Auch als ich ihn in Fürth dann erlebt habe, hat er einfach schon viel gesehen in dieser 2. Liga, auch vielleicht mit Händen in den Hosentaschen, okay. Aber es hilft ja als Trainer, der schon mal –das wird ja immer oft betont –der die 2. Liga kennt und Markus Korczinski kennt die 2. Liga. Und ich glaube, er weiß auch, wie man den Verein ganz gut durch so eine Liga durchmanövriert. Ich fand das doch schon beeindruckend, dass er dann einfach mit großer Ruhe mit einer Mannschaft, wo wirklich viele Spieler gegangen sind. Als es ja auch immer dann gleich auf den 1. FC Nürnberg kommt. Amit Gürley war Verteidiger dort, Hollerbach hat er angesprochen. Also da sind ja einige Spieler einfach gegangen. Aber man muss auch sagen, dass wir in diesem Mal ein gutes Scouting haben. Ich habe es mir wieder gedacht, als ich Ivan Britein gesehen habe. Ich habe irgendwann mal so ein bisschen uneigennützig Drittligastürmer gescoutet, der vielleicht nach Fürth kommen könnte. Da ist mir Ivan Britein schon in der 3. Liga aufgefallen. Und er ist auch in der 2. Liga immer noch ein guter Stürmer. Er ist auch einer der Gründe, er hat den zweithöchsten Marktwert in dem Kader. Er heißt eigentlich der Wiener, der Wiesbadener. Der Weher wahrscheinlich heißt er. Einfach ein gutes Scouting, muss man einfach sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob bei Matthiessen ausgesprochen wird. Auch der Verteidiger, ein guter Spieler. Das muss man einfach auch mal loben. Wir haben nicht die großen Mittel, aber wir machen aus diesen wenigen einfach viel. Es gibt ja andere Vereine, die deutlich mehr Mittel haben, aber damit einfach nicht so gute Arbeit machen. Deswegen stehen sie da auch zurecht da. Ich finde auch Junioli, der habe ich von dem Bayern ausgeliehen gewesen, fand ich extrem guter Fußballer, auch für einen Aufsteiger, der dem Spiel wirklich gut getan hat. Später habe ich ihn mal live gesehen. Da bin ich auch zuversichtlich, dass das was wird auch weiterhin. Klar, so eine Aufsteiger hat auch mal ein bisschen Anfangsäuphorie, das wird da wieder weniger, aber auch insgesamt eine gute Mannschaft. Ich glaube, dass sie da auch für ein drittes Zweite-Liga-Jahr und ein zweites ins Folge planen können. Vielleicht schon gegen Ende Mitte der Rückrunde.
Ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen gespannt, weil sie auch zu den Teams gehören, die zwar nicht wegen des Afrika Cups, aber wegen der Asienmeisterschaft vom 12.1. bis 10.2. müssen ein Spieler abgeben müssen mit John Ironsdale, der für Australien nominiert wurde.
Der ist auch mal Paderborn-Spieler gewesen.
Und Schürze, als sie bei uns zu Gast waren.
Also vielleicht jetzt –sie kommen ja auch so ein bisschen aus dem Kollektiv. Da bin ich tatsächlich gespannt, wie sie den dann doch auch ersetzen können. Also wenn du trotzdem dann kardertiefer an der einen oder anderen Stelle fehlt, bleibt natürlich trotzdem die Frage. Weil es sind trotzdem diese vier Spiele sieglos. Und wir haben jetzt genug über Serien gesprochen. Das kann eben auch in die andere Richtung gehen. Also auch so vier, fünf Niederlagen oder vier, fünf sieglose Spiele am Stück. Aber ich meine, sie sind natürlich in einer sehr komfortablen Zone gerade in der Tabelle. Ich glaube, das ist dann schon ganz okay. Ich fand es trotzdem noch mal interessant, auf die Drittliga-Saison zu gucken. Weil da waren sie das zweitstärkste Offensivteam mit 71 Toren. Aber eben auch defensiv unter den Top 5, also unter diesen Top 5 der Aufsteigerriege, das war ja sowieso ein bisschen wild, der schlechtesten mit 51 Gegentoren. Also schon interessanter irgendwie drauf zu gucken. Aber ich glaube schon, dass sie auch ganz gut wissen, was sie dort tun. Aber ich muss gerade so dran denken, weil man, als du gesagt hast, Yannick, so Hand in der Hose, ich muss immer daran denken, dass man Zettel Ewald gesagt hat, vielleicht ist dann Hand in der Hose Markus oder so, auch wenn man dann direkt Joachim Löw für den Kopf hatte.
Ja, genau, also bitte, Rudy Giuliani, nein, nein, einfach nein, Eva. Und ich mit?
Komisch, dass bei Wiesbaden offenbar dieses –also wir hatten Gunnar vom Stehblock bei uns in Palarkas zu Gast. Und die Folge bei uns hieß untenrum in bester Gesellschaft. Also komisch.
Dafür bin ich jetzt nicht verantwortlich, zumindest ganz klar.
Wollt ihr wissen, wie die Zwillinge sich gemerkt haben, dass Wiesbaden die Hauptstadt von Hessen ist? Mit der Esensbrücke Hessen-Hassens-Duschen-Wiesbaden.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt auch nicht gesagt.
Hat geklappt, die HSU-Note war gut. Das war sehr gut sogar. Das war große Freude. Und zu Hände in den Hosentaschen –Context Matters. Also Franz Beckenbauch hatte nach dem WM-Titel 1990 auch die Hände in den Hosentaschen. Mit was für einer schlechten Körpersprache, der damals über den Rasen da gelaufen ist. Eigentlich ein Wahnsinn, dass man ihm das durchgehen lassen hat. Vielleicht wird ja Markus Korczynski genauso dann den Klassenerhalt feiern. Nicht in Rom, aber in dem, was in Deutschland, Rom am Nächsten kommt.
Ich möchte noch kurz zwei Sachen ergänzen. Zum einen hatten wir beide vom Niemals-Este-Liga-Podcast, Gunnar und Michael, zu Gast bei uns in den VDSN-Gesprächen. Da hatte ich im Vorfeld die super Idee, als wir auf die bisherige Show zurückblickten, dass wir das in so Viererblöcken machen. Das waren dann 16 Spiele, jeder acht Spiele. Michael hatte leider die unglückliche Aufgabe, dass die Viererblöcke immer ihm zu fehlen, wo man gerade nicht so performt hat. Es waren immer vier Spiele gut, vier Spiele nicht so gut. Das war ein stetiges Auf und Ab. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, wer sich noch an meine paar Sätze vom Vorhanden, zwei Stunden erinnert. Ich habe die Spiele gegen Osnabrück und Wiesbaden durcheinander geschmissen. Es war das Spiel gegen Wiesbaden, wo man kurz nach der Entführung in Ostenburg ging. Da hat man bereits noch sechs Minuten geführt und sich dann sehr spät den Ausgleich gefangen. Das habe ich durcheinander geschmissen, weil es halt vom Spielverlauf oder vom Endergebnis sehr ähnlich war und man in beiden Fällen vermisst hat, das Tor zu schießen.
Gut, das wäre so. Es sei dir mehr als zu erziehen, Yannick. Ich möchte nur ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, für mich ist alles cool, aber wir sind gerade im Mittelfeld der Tabelle. Wir haben da vorhin drüber gesprochen. Ihr bestimmt, wie lange das heute geht. Ich wasche meine Hände in Unschuld und übergebe mit diesen einleitenden Worten dankbarerweise jetzt dann an Michi, der uns zum ersten FC Nürnberg etwas sagen möchte. Ich weiß gar nicht. Warum du dich für diesen Verein gemeldet hast und warum du dich da auskennst. Nürnberg hat 24 Punkte, 7 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Wir sehen schon, dass ist relativ ausgeglichen. Nicht so ganz bei der Tordifferenz. 24 Tore nur erzielt, 33 kassiert und der Messi der 2. Liga spielt dort. Das wissen alle, die die entsprechende Ligatur gehört haben. Michi, was ist darüber hinaus wichtig zu wissen beim Club?
Ich könnte jetzt ja auch nochmal so zwei Stunden einfach über den Club reden, nur aus den Erfahrungen und Erlebnissen, die ich jeden Tag in irgendwelchen Calls bei uns in der Redaktion höre von den Kollegen, die den 1. Wir haben auch mehr Clubreporter bei uns. Der 1. FC Nürnberg ist schon immer noch der große Verein hier. Auch wenn eine Tabelle gerade hinter der Spielvereinigung steht. Diese 24 Punkte, die du gerade schon angesprochen hast, sind ja für den Club erst einmal, wenn man die letzten Jahre sieht, sehr, sehr gut. Das vergisst man dann immer, weil der Club ja eigentlich auch in die 1. Liga gehört. Und es gibt auch beim Club, wie bei Schalke, wie bei vielen dieser großen Traditionsvereine mit vielen Meisterschaften, immer Menschen, die sagen, der Club müsste doch eigentlich schon nächstes Jahr in der Bundesliga wieder spielen. Aber eigentlich ist er halt gerade ein Zweitligist, der sportlich schon ziemlich am Struggeln ist die letzten Jahre. Also, ich weiß noch, vergangene Saison, 34 Jahre später kam sie in Paderborn, glaube ich, müsste Kevin dann erlebt haben, in Paderborn gewonnen. Und dann haben sie dann den Klassenerhalt noch geschafft. Aber trotzdem war es bis zuletzt einfach spannend, dass sie überhaupt in dieser Liga bleiben. Sie haben vor einigen Jahren dieses in Ingolstadt mit Fabian Schleusener, der in der 90. plus sechs, plus sieben, plus acht, was auch immer, also in der Nachspielzeit sehr tief den Klub gerade noch in der Liga gehalten. Also dann würden wir wahrscheinlich heute nicht über den Klub sprechen. Deswegen sind 24 Punkte einfach schon sehr, sehr gut für den Klub. Und man muss ja sagen, dass es zwischenzeitlich sogar noch mal besser aussah, dass es zuletzt dann so eine schlechte Phase noch mal gab. Aber das vielleicht auch ganz normale ist in der Mannschaft, wo einfach der Messi in Nürnbergs spielt, nämlich Can Usun, geht es mittlerweile laut, weil gerade der marktwerten Thema war. Acht Millionen haben die Transfermarkt-Userinnen und –User ihn, glaube ich, hochgerankt. Er ist der wertvollste Spieler der zweiten Liga mittlerweile. Can Usun wird gerade 18 Jahren jetzt geworden. Es gibt schon wieder neue Gerüchte, dass irgendwelche türkischen Großklubs schon wieder dran sind. Der Klub angeblich, laut diverser Quellen, als ich liebe dieses Transferkarussell da im Winter immer, angeblich zehn Millionen aufruft. Das ist das Glück des 1. FC Nürnbergs, dem es auch finanziell nicht wirklich gut geht, dass er gerade junge Spieler rausbringt aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs, die man verkaufen kann. Einer wird ja schon gehen, also Nathaniel Brown, ziemlich sicher zur Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga. Einer der Stützen dieser Saison. Can Usun wird wahrscheinlich mal im Sommer auch gehen, dann für eine hohe, einstellige Million, so wird er wahrscheinlich mindestens mal. Er wird dem Klub nochmal gutes Geld bringen. Man muss ja auch sagen, dass diese Jugend spielt, dem Klub auch einfach fußballerisch guttun, und dass auch Christian Fjell dem Klub guttut. Also man hat in den letzten Jahren auch da Grüße an den Kollegen Fadike Blavit, der immer geschimpft hat mit Markus Weinziel. Der Fußball war wirklich nicht schön anzuschauen beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Und Christian Fjell hat ja auch einen Fußball-Beyanen. Aber Dieter Hecking hat anscheinend mittlerweile eingestanden, dass es sein Fehler war, Markus Weinziel zu holen. Der Klub hatte ja vor einigen Wochen seine Mitgliederversammlung und da wurde wohl offenbar auch ein bisschen nachgetreten gegen Markus Weinziel, was vielleicht auch nicht dafür spricht. Aber andererseits kann man es vielleicht auch machen. Jetzt, wenn es einfach so gut läuft. Aber man hat eben mit Christian Titz einen Trainer –na, Christian Titz sag ich schon, Christian Fjell, Entschuldigung –einen auch fußballbejahenden Trainer. Das haben die beiden Christian, auch wenn einer da ohne Haar geschrieben wird. Aber haben diese beiden Trainer einfach gemeinsam, dass sie gerne Fußball spielen wollen. Und der 1. Nürnberg spielt auch schön in Fußball mittlerweile und hat dafür auch mittlerweile gute Spieler wie Can Usun zum Beispiel und auch viele andere. Es ist halt noch ein bisschen wackelig teilweise, was auch das erklärt, dass es immer wieder so Einbrüche gibt, weil man zum Beispiel mit Christian Martini einen Torhüter hat, der jetzt nicht der beste fußballerische Torhüter der 2. Liga ist, also das ein anderer Verein vielleicht verwöhnt hat. Aber trotzdem macht der Klub eine gute Entwicklung durch und er hat einfach schon auch wirklich gute Ergebnisse gehabt und aber zuletzt auch wieder Schwächephasen mit –was haben Sie hier gerade noch mal vor Augen? Moment. Also sie haben wirklich schon Spiele verloren, wo man dachte, was ist da los 5-0 gegen Bielefeld? Sorry, Eva, ich mache mich ganz nervös –gegen Düsseldorf zu Hause, wo man wirklich sich dann denkt, was ist denn da wieder los? Aber vielleicht gehört das einfach zu einer Genese, zu einer jungen Mannschaft, die gerade dabei ist, sich zu einer stabilen Zweite-Liga-Mannschaft einfach zu entwickeln. Und ja, man holt der Zwischenzeit trotzdem wieder Siege. Also man hat dann in Elversberg, die auch lange Zeit ein sehr guter Zweite-Liga war –wir haben noch immer noch über sie geredet –einfach auch gewonnen in einem wirklich nicht guten Spiel. Das hätte auch Elversberg gewinnen können, aber man gewinnt halt an dieses Spiel. Und auch einer der Gründe, warum der 1. FC Nürnberg vielleicht nicht weiter oben in der Tabelle steht, ist auch wie bei Magdeburg. Vielleicht man hat keinen so wirklichen Mittelstürmer. Also man hat Christoph Daferner immer noch im Aufgebot, ein Spieler, für den man auch eine Million, glaube ich, gezahlt hat, da knapp über eine Million, der ist aber selten im Spieltags-Kader noch. Und man spielt jetzt dann auch immer so eher mit Can Usun, der aber körperlich auch kein wirklicher Neuner ist, oder mit Daichi Hayashi, also ein Japaner, der auch erst so flinke, weil er der falsche Neun ist und deswegen oftmals ist da halt einfach keiner in der Mitte. Dann ist er der Nachteil dieser falschen Neun. Man kann da halt einfach dann nicht mal rein flanken. Max freut sich schon über Flanken. Aber ja, ich glaube, der FC Nürnberg diskutiert da grad intern auch so ein bisschen, ob man dann vielleicht nochmal jemanden noch dazu nimmt, der dann einfach mal in der Mitte auch mal Tore schießen könnte. Aber bislang läuft es ja ganz gut. Und der Klub ist ja, wie gesagt, nochmal voll im Zoll. Deswegen alles gut beim 1. FC Nürnberg, auch wenn nicht jeder schon wieder im Umfeld vielleicht von mehr trömt, auch Fadi hat schon wieder geschwärmt. Ich bin nicht immer kadept, den Podcast der Kollegen dann höre. Kommt oftmals die Frage, steigt der Klub jetzt auf? Das ist ja eine beliebte Frage. Ich würde sagen, in dieser Saison schon mal nicht.
Also was ja mit Blick auf die Tabelle auf jeden Fall auffällt, dass man sieben Siege, sieben Niederlagen und nur drei Unentschieden. Also es gibt einen, entweder läuft es super und man holt die drei Punkte oder man, ja, ich meine, wir hatten sie ja auch schon bei uns zu Gast und sie sind bei uns mit eins zu fünf aus eigener Sicht nach Hause geschickt worden. Also das passt ja zu dem, was du gesagt hast, dass es entweder, ja, hat man gute Spiele dabei oder halt auch wirklich welche, die komplett in die Grütze gehen. Und was ich ja, ich bin ja heute der hier der Mann für die Fairness-Tabelle, man führt sie mit Abstand. Jetzt habe ich gerade den Reiter verloren, wo ist der denn jetzt hingekommen? Jetzt suche ich sie gerade, auf jeden Fall ist man mit Abstand.
Sie sind an dem Ende, an dem man nicht sein möchte.
Genau, es sind glaube ich 49 gelbe Karten und vier Platzverweise, wenn ich es gerade richtig, ich suche das mal. Genau, danke, dass du das bestätigst, genau, das ist ja, das wollte ich nur nochmal dazu ergänzen, dass man sich ja durchaus auf dem Platz auch in anderer Form präsent zeigt als durch Tore und Siege.
Aber einer dieser Spieler, das selbe Problem, Jens Kastrup ist er einfach, der habe ich noch gar nicht genannt, einfach ein wichtiger Spieler im Mittelfeld beim Club, einfach auch mit seiner Aggressivität und Präsenz und der hat zuletzt dann auch gesperrt gefehlt, deswegen das war einer der Gründe, auch warum es damals sportlich zwischenzeitlich wieder nicht lief, aber die Sperren laufen glücklicherweise auch wieder aus und deswegen kann er dem Club auch bald wieder helfen.
Also wird mir hier bei Husqord mit acht Spielen angezeigt und acht Gelben und einer roten Karte. Wenn diese Zahlen stimmen, dann ziehe ich meinen Hut. Das ist…
Fußballsprache hat den Begriff Aggressiv-Leader wahrscheinlich dafür erfunden.
Ja, Körpersprache bestimmt mega geil. Also super, super Spieler eigentlich. Passt genau zu dem, was man in Deutschland im Fußball sehen will. Und noch zwei Anmerkungen dazu. Zum einen, vorne haben wir, vorhin haben wir bei Wien Wiesbaden die Post Shot Expected Goals habe ich thematisiert. Der Club ist genau am anderen Ende dieser Tabelle. Also Wien Wiesbaden hat 5 Gegentreffer weniger kassiert, als man statistisch gesehen hätte kassieren sollen. Natürlich mit aller Vorsicht zu genießen. Beim Club sind es 8 Gegentreffer mehr. Und wenn das so deutlich ist, finde ich, dann kann man diese Statistik dann doch mal nennen. Und du hast es ja angedeutet. Michi, das ist ein Thema.
Es gibt ja auch Club-Fans, die dann auch schon über Christian Martegna natürlich immer so ein bisschen in diversen oder auf den diversen Plattformen, Least Ingen auch so, ja, sagen wir mal, nicht mehr allzu super finden. Es hat zuletzt ja Karl Klaus gespielt, was sich Martegna verletzt hatte, der fußballerisch deutlich besser ist, der auch auf der Linie ein gutes Spiel gemacht hat. Ich bin gespannt, wie Christian Friertes moderiert, weil er trotzdem, das ist ja auch ein Spieler mit einer gewissen Erfahrung und Reputation innerhalb des Mannschaftsgefüges auch, ob man den dann so einfach auf die Bank setzt und dann den seit Jahren braven Ersatzmann dann ins Tor stellt, kann ich mir schwerlich vorstellen. Aber auch das ist natürlich die Frage, man sieht es in Fürth, wenn man Fußball spielen will oder mehr Fußball spielen will, es ist extrem wichtig, einen guten Torhüter zu haben. Auch Magdeburg hat einen Torhüter, der einfach viel Fußball spielt, viel aufbaut. Da tut es sich immer noch schwer, wenn der Trainer sagt, du sollst den Ball nicht langschlagen. Und er denkt sich jedes zweite Mal, ich würde ihn jetzt aber gerne langschlagen, weil ich mich unsicher fühle. Das strahlt natürlich auch auf eine Mannschaft aus. Deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, was sich dann am Tor noch tut.
Ja, und wir können vielleicht festhalten, weil wir auch die Stürmerproblematik angesprochen haben, die ja beim Klub inzwischen gute Tradition hat, muss man sagen. Das war das Thema der letzten zwei, drei Jahre, wenn wir über Nürnberg gesprochen haben. Was wäre mit den gut spielenden Teams dieser zweiten Liga los, wenn es mehr gute Mittelstürmer in Deutschland gäbe? Meine Güte! Das könnte ja hier ganz, ganz andere Sphären sein. Vielleicht sogar ja Sphären, in denen der SV Elbersberg, die SV Elbersberg gerade sich befindet. So ist es natürlich korrekt, denn die sind zwar punktgleich mit Nürnberg, aber als Aufsteiger ist das natürlich ein hervorragendes Ergebnis. Und Elbersberg hat ja für den ein oder anderen Aufreger auch schon durch sehr, sehr überraschende Ergebnisse gesorgt. Das hat eigentlich so fast jeder mal zu spüren bekommen in dieser Liga. Fast jeder hat das zu spüren bekommen. Kevin möchte sich schon gar nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das vielleicht dieses 1 zu 4 war oder woher das jetzt genau kam. Übergeben wir das Wort doch einfach an Michi, denn Michi hat sich bereit erklärt, uns auch zur SVE ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Mir ging es ähnlich, als ich mit Nils-Ole Bog, dem Sportdirektor aus Elbersberg telefoniert habe, da musste ich mich auch manchmal berichtigen, wenn ich ihm wieder der sagte. Ich habe es mir immer wieder aufgeschrieben, es ist die Sportvereinigung aus Elbersberg. Aber ich habe mir auch damals versucht, erklären zu lassen, woher kommt dieses Erfolgsrezept. Am Ende ist es wahrscheinlich eine einfache Formel, ein innovativer junger Sportdirektor, er ist 37 Jahre alt und vor allem sehr viel Ruhe. Da hat er gesagt, sie haben ihre Standortvorteile früh identifiziert, dass es in Elbersberg Ruhe ist, habe ich dann auch festgestellt, als ich hingefahren bin zum Auswärtsspiel. Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel keinen Bahnhof in Elbersberg. Aber auch da hat sich der Elbersberger Sportchef ein bisschen näher verärgert gezeigt, dass er zum Beispiel Freunde eine Story über Elbersberg gemacht hat. Und es ging immer nur darum, dass es dieses kleine, lustige Dorf ist, mit der Tankstelle neben dem Stadion, wo die Menschen dann zum Stadion laufen, von der Tankstelle und die Tankstelle und kein Bahnhof und bla, bla, bla. Und sie haben sich dann ganz ernst genommen gefühlt, aber ich glaube, sie haben relativ früh an dieser zweiten Liga bewiesen, dass man sie schon auch sportlich ernst nehmen sollte. Also, ich habe die Yannick vorhin auch mal zu den Spielplanen noch mal ein bisschen durchgeschaut und sie haben ja an den ersten Spieltagen eigentlich in Hannover gleich 2-0 geführt, haben dann noch 2-2 gespielt, haben am zweiten Spieltag zu Hause gegen Rostock 1-0 geführt und haben in der 90. plus 10. und 90. plus 13. die Gegentheorie kassiert, also auch wild, haben da auch verloren, haben dann in Lautern zwar geführt zwischenzeitlich, aber auch verloren, dann zu Hause 0-5 gegen Düsseldorf verloren und da hätte man ja schon damals denken können, dass es so ein Verlauf ist für einen Aufsteiger, der eine Mannschaft auch brechen kann. Aber diese Mannschaft ist gefestigt, die ist ja in Teilen so von der Viertel- in die Zweite Liga jetzt durchmarschiert, diese blöde Militärsprache, man kriegt sie halt immer raus. Sie haben diesen Run von der Viertel- in die Zweite Liga durchgezogen und danach wurde es ja viel besser. Also danach haben sie sieben Spiele ungeschlagen, haben davon fünfmal gewonnen, unter anderem gegen den HSV, haben auf Schalke gewonnen, auch wenn das natürlich jetzt besser klingt, also es ist kein Qualitätsmerkmal, es haben auch andere Vereine auf Schalke gewonnen, aber für die kleine SV Elversberg ist natürlich ein Riesenerfolg gewesen, beim FC Schalke zu gewinnen. Jetzt am Ende haben sie wieder dreimal verloren und gab ja auch einen vornen Beitrag dann zur SV Elversberg, in dem es noch alles sehr viel ausführlich, was ich jetzt erklären kann, dargestellt ist. Aber natürlich ist das einfach auch Lehrgeld für so einen Verein, der einfach wechselhafte Phasen durchleben muss und auch mit Spielern, die man halt einfach größtenteils nicht kennt. Also das ist ja immer so ein Zeichen auch, da kommen junge unverbrauchte Spieler einfach in die Liga, aber die machen das einfach wirklich richtig gut. Haus Steffen ist einfach ein sehr guter Trainer, der diesen offensiven Stil einfach weiter durchgezogen hat. Sie haben einfach einen schönen, guten Fußball gespielt und in der 2. Liga gibt es Mannschaften, die nicht so gern Fußball spielen. Deswegen bin ich auch ein Freund. Auch das ist ja ein Fußball-bejahender Ansatz und deswegen gefällt mir die SV Elversberg auch. Und sie hat 24 Punkte als Aufsteiger. Der beste aller Aufsteiger. Das ist, glaube ich, so eine perfekte Saison bislang für sie, auch wenn es natürlich Spiele gab, die sie sich –vielleicht in der Winterpause denken, hätten wir da vielleicht ein paar Punkte mehr geholt, dann wäre vielleicht sogar noch mehr möglich. Aber am Ende ist ein Mittelfeldplatz etwas, womit man in Elversberg sehr, sehr zufrieden sein kann. Und da passiert ja auch immer noch sehr, sehr viel. Also ich habe letztes Mal das Spiel angeschaut gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg, wo sie zu Hause dann verloren hatten. Die Tribüne, auf der ich noch im September, glaube ich, war, September, Oktober saß, auch die Presse-Tribüne damals, ist einfach weg. Also das Stadion wird ja auch umgebaut. Es werden immer bessere Bedingungen. Sie bauen, glaube ich, oder sind gerade dabei zu planen, auch ein neues Trainingszentrum. Also dieser Verein entwickelt sich auch neben dem Platz. Man muss da immer sagen, dass es, ja, passiert nicht einfach so, sondern da ist auch Geld dahinter von der Hülo, heißt Hülo, Hüla, Hülo. Also die Familie Holzer ist ja dieser, Ursa Farm heißt der Konzern. Das heißt, die sind ja auch bei den Bayern Sponsor. Also man sieht das Logo dieser Augentropfen, sind es, glaube ich, bei den Bayern auf den Sponsoren wenden ja auch. Also da ist schon auch ein bisschen Geld dahinter, aber es wird einfach auch gute Arbeit gemacht. Da wird ja nicht mit Millionen um sich geschmissen, wie an anderen Standorten, wo reiche Geldgeber dahinter sind, sondern dieses Geld wird auch dafür genutzt, eben einfach den Verein insgesamt weiter zu bringen infrastruktuell, wie sportlich. Und deswegen macht es auch Spaß, ihnen zuzuschauen in der 2.
Liga.
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, noch mal als Ergänzung dazu, es liegt ja jetzt so ein bisschen von der Wahrnehmung von außen nahe da gewisse Parallelen zu einer TSG aus Hoffenheim zu ziehen, einfach, weil da so viel Finanz hinter ist und man jetzt sehr schnell sehr groß geworden ist. Das ist ja auch einfach der Grund, weshalb du ich… Was war das deine Story, Michi, die du irgendwie mal gepostet hattest, irgendwo, wo du durchs Fenster in den Pressebereich musstest?
Ja, das war in Elbersberg.
Weil im Gang irgendwie noch die Spieler lagen und so. Also dieser Verein ist einfach sehr schnell sehr groß geworden, aber…
Max Gesicht müssen jetzt alle…
Du musst ihn kurz aufklären, sonst man konnte die Fragezeichen um deinen Kopf schwirren sehen.
Man merkt, dass Max nicht mehr auf Twitter ist, auf X. Ich habe damals auch eine Kolumne darüber geschrieben, es war sehr witzig, kam in Elversberg an und das Pressezentrum war in einem Containerdorf auf einem ehemaligen alten Kunststraßenplatz hinter der Heimtribüne und dann fragte ich die Ordnerin, ob ich denn irgendwo auf Toilette gehen könne und dann sagt sie, geht gerade nicht, da liegen gerade Spieler noch rum. Also dieser Presseraum ist auch gleichzeitig Containerkabinen-Dorf und anscheinend haben sich auch immer Spieler auf faszinierende Rollen gerade aufgewärmt im Gang, deswegen konnte ich nicht aus Klo gehen. Und dann hatte ich weiterhin so, wo gibt es eine Toilette? Dann sagt sie gegenüber, da war keine Tür im Klo. Dann habe ich die Ordnerin gefragt, ob bei ihnen ein Klo wäre. Dann sagten sie, ja, aber da ist noch mal geputzt worden seit dem letzten Heimspiel. Also es war alles noch sehr urig, ein bisschen wie bei einem Pokalspiel. Und dann sagte ich, wie komme ich denn jetzt in den Presseraum rein? Ich würde gerne rein zum Arbeiten. Dann sagt sie, da müsstest du durchs Fenster reingehen. Dann stand tatsächlich in dem Container auf Brusthöhe das Fenster und es stand ein Stuhl davor und dann konnte man in diesen Presseraum halt dann reinklettern durchs Fenster. Also ich hätte es gerne gesehen, was passiert wäre.
Aber Moment mal, hat da auch eine Pressekonferenz stattgefunden und sind Pressesprecher und Trainer dann auch über dieses Fenster reingekommen?
Bitte sag ja. Nein, nach dem Spiel war alles wieder offen. Das Witzige war aber auch, man kennt ja diese Mixed-Zones, wenn man mal journalistisch gearbeitet hat, wo teilweise hermetisch abgeregelt ist und dann werden die Spieler vor diese Videowende oder vor diese Sponsorenwende gebracht. In Elvesberg bin ich in die Mixed Zone gelaufen und stand plötzlich neben der Mannschaftskabine der Spielfeindlichen ohne irgendeine Absperrung. Da hat der Trainer auch ein bisschen komisch geschaut, dass der Journalist plötzlich fast in der Kabine steht. Also es war alles sehr behelfsmäßig, aber es war schön. Es war ein Ausflug, der hat Spaß gemacht, hätte man auch gewinnen können aus viertersicht, aber trotzdem eine Story, die man nicht vergisst.
Ja und man muss eben schon sagen, also auch wenn da investiert wird, ist es schon nochmal deutlich was anderes. Also ich habe einfach nur mal versucht, rauszufinden, wann hat man das letzte Mal Geld in die Hand genommen für Transfers. Das war im Jahr 2005, 2006 in der Saison. Das sollen 35.000 Euro gewesen sein, laut einschlägigen Seiten. Ich vermute mal, darüber hast du dann mit Nies-Ulle Bogue auch gesprochen. Wie recruited man denn für die SV Elbersberg?
Ja, ich dachte ja, ich mache da so eine fancy Story über den Verein, der mit Datenscouting in die 2. Bundesliga kommt, weil ich das ja auch sehr spannend finde. Die haben ja auch eine Kooperation mit Create Football, mit dieser Daten-Konsultancy. Er hat es ein bisschen abgetan, es ist gar nicht so schlimm, aber zumindest arbeiten sie mit Daten auch schon mal. Das ist ja schon mal ein sehr gutes Zeichen. Grüße auch an Flo Zenger, der jahrelang gepredigt hat. Die Vereine mögen ein bisschen mehr mit Daten arbeiten. In Elbersberg sieht man, dass es funktioniert. Er hat doch gemeint, das ist dann nur ein Teil. Klar will niemand gerne über seinen Scouting reden. Man hat es auch mal erwähnt, zu Tribünengesprächen mit einem Scout, wie Fußballscouting funktioniert. Es ist extrem schwierig, aber zumindest ist in Elbersberg ein 37-jähriger Sportdirektor anders als ein 60-jähriger Sportdirektor, der schon immer so gescoutet hat, dass er seine zehn Scouts in die ersten vier Ligen geschickt hat, um möglichst jemanden zu finden. Vor allem muss man in Elbersberg anders scouten. Manche Transfers waren schon naheliegend, zum Beispiel Paul Wander vom FC Bayern ausgeliehen. Er hätte auch andere Vereine ausleihen können, der macht eine gute Figur. Wahid Faki haben sie vom VfB ausgeliehen, war dann zwar jetzt verletzt, aber auch das ist ja ein Spieler, man kann ja auch von Bundesligisten Spieler ausleihen. Das war eben einer der Vorteile, den Nils Ohneburg erwähnt hat, dass eben diese Ruhe ist. Das wird in Fürsten auch erwähnt. Ich glaube, in Elbersberg hat man nochmal mehr Ruhe, um zu arbeiten. Die Pressekonferenz war sehr kurz und da waren noch sehr wenige Kolleginnen da.
Ganz kurz einmal, weil es gerade um dieses Datenscouting, da kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen, die Aminia-Podcast-Folge mit Michael Mutzel, also unserem Geschäftsführer, weil der relativ lange darüber redet, wie man eben auch als Position von Aminia Biedefeld, die gerade in die dritte Liga abgestiegen ist, und einfach noch einen komplett neuen Kader braucht, wie man da scoutet, und der tatsächlich, wie ich finde, sehr untypisch, sehr lang und breit über auch datenbasierte Scouting spricht. Also kann ich sehr empfehlen an der Stelle.
Werde ich verlinken. Aber hey, wenn wir über die Schiene Aminia hier mit reinbekommen, dann ist doch alles gut gelaufen. So soll das doch sein. Also die SVE steht ganz fantastisch da. Punktgleich steht Hannover 96 da. Aber die Frage ist, ob man es ähnlich fantastisch einordnen würde, denn natürlich hat Hannover andere Ansprüche. Auch wenn man sehr bemüht darum war, nicht immer den direkten Aufstieg als Ziel auszugeben, sondern es wird jetzt immer in drei Jahreszyklen kommuniziert von Hannover 96, kann man sich sicher sein, wenn es irgendwie gut läuft oder es darum geht, dass man sich über einen EV-Beschluss hinwegsetzt bei einer Investorenentscheidung, dann kommt Martin Kindt daher und sagt, jetzt müssen wir aber hochgehen. Oder, geheime Abstimmung, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr erinnern, wie ich abgestimmt habe, das eine davon ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen weniger relevant als das andere, aber beides führt dazu. Yannick bei Hannover 96, kommt man ohne den Namen Martin Kindt nie durch eine Saisonbesprechung und man kann sich auch nicht davon lösen, dass man das Gefühl hat, irgendwie hat es eben doch einen Einfluss, dass selbst wenn alle anderen Verantwortlichen es geschafft haben, ein bisschen die Erwartungen zu lenken, ein gutes Erwartungsmanagement zu betreiben, irgendwann geht es dann wieder durch die Decke und dann zieht aber auch die Mannschaft nach mit komischen Ergebnissen.
Okay, da war jetzt schon ganz viel drin in deiner Einleitung. Der Name Martin Kindt fällt tatsächlich erst relativ spät in dem, was ich so zu erzählen habe. Wir fangen mal im Sommer an, da sind mir eigentlich nur zwei nennenswerte oder erwähnenswerte Transfers auf. Mal natürlich vor allem voran Marcel Halstenberg, mit dem wir ja auch eine gemeinsame Vergangenheit haben, bevor er dann beschlossen hat, zu einem Brauseprodukt in Leipzig zu gehen. Er war eigentlich auch unser Trainer in der Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel, als sie bei uns zu Gast waren. Dazu komme ich gleich auch noch. Er hat gesagt, dass er eigentlich ein Unterschiedsspieler ist und eigentlich zu gut für die zweite Liga. Da merkt man ihm seine Erstliga-Vergangenheit auf jeden Fall an. Er ist ja nach Hannover zurückgegangen, weil er ursprünglich aus der Region kommt. Und wie er näher an der Familie sein möchte, hat er sicherlich auch einige Assansummen, was das Gehalt angeht, darauf verzichtet. Und um da jetzt in einer alten Wirkungsstätte oder in einer alten Heimat zu spielen. Dann habe ich lange überlegt, ob ich es anspreche. Ich würde zumindest einmal kurz erwähnen, dass Brooklyn Ezee –wir hatten es ja gerade von Wiesbaden –der ist aus Wiesbaden nach Hannover gekommen und ist jetzt zuletzt aufgefallen, weil er anscheinend mit psychischen Problemen kämpft und einen Ausraster –Schrägstrich –Zusammenbruch in einem ICE hat, nachdem er sich von seiner Partnerin getrennt hat. Er erwähne ich deshalb, weil er zwar freigestellt ist 96, sich aber hinter ihm gestellt hat und ihn da in dieser schwierigen psychischen Phase nicht fallen lässt, sondern hinter ihm steht zumindest, dem Vernehmen nach wollte ich einfach nur einmal kurz erwähnen. Gut, dann erstmal zum Sportlichen. Man spielt grundsätzlich in einer 3-4-3-Grunden-Formation, schreibt ein hohes Pressing an, hat einen klaren Mittelstürmer und vielleicht ein Unterschied zu zum Beispiel dem FC St. Pauli, keine offensiven Außenmannspieler, da kommen erst die Schienenspieler quasi weiter hinten positioniert, mit Köhn und dem zumeist. Man hat dann quasi einen Mittelstürmer und zwei Halbstürmer vorne. Die ersten zehn Spiele liefen eigentlich insgesamt ganz gut, mit fünf Siegen, drei unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Man war ja zwischendurch in dieser norddeutsch dominierten 2. Liga mit dabei, mit den beiden Hamburger Vereinen und Holstein Kiel noch mit dabei. Unter diesen ersten zehn Spielen fällt auch so ein Freak-Ergebnis wie ein 7 zu 0 gegen Osnabrück. Würde man heute auch nicht mehr, wenn man so zurückdenkt, könnte man sich das auch nicht mehr vorstellen, wenn man nämlich so guckt, dass in den letzten fünf Spielen kein einziger Sieg dabei war, nämlich nur drei Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen. Man ist jetzt 16. in der Formtabelle und der letzte Sieg datiert aus dem Derby gegen Eintracht Braunschreck von Anfang November. Also in letzter Zeit alles andere als gut bei Hannover. Ich habe dann auch Kontakt mit Tobi vom Vorwärts nach weit Podcast aufgenommen, liebe Grüße auch hier. Ich habe ihn gefragt, ob ich mir den Saisonverlauf nicht so ganz erklären kann, was da passiert ist. Und er sagt, ja, ich auch nicht. Er hat mir dann noch ein bisschen was aus dem Nähkästchen erzählt. Man hat ein sehr hohes Übergewicht im zentralen Mittelfeld, dafür Defizite in der Offensive. Und sagt dann zum Trainer Leitel, der würde wohl in den letzten Wochen seltsame Entscheidungen treffen. Als Beispiel hat er da die Nominierung von Burner in der Startelf gegen Kiel genannt, wo man ohne Torch hat, der mit acht Toren der Top-Torschütze ist, gespielt hat. Da wäre man halt vorne zu harmlos. Leitel wird wohl auch immer kritischer gesehen, weil man, wie ich ja gerade schon an der Spielergebnisse skizziert habe, auf der Stelle trifft und seit dem Derby sieglos ist. Er überlegt also ein bisschen, ob die Mannschaft in so einer Zufriedenheit, Comfort-Zone sich so ein bisschen bewegt und einfach, ja, reicht doch nach dem Motto und reicht halt nicht. Er befürchtet also einen Absturz, wie in der Vergangenesaison wäre verheerend und sieht halt, dass die Entscheidung über den Verbleib von Leitel so in den ersten Wochen nach der Winterpause fallen wird. Da sind die Gegner erstmal die gerade schon angesprochene SV Elbersberg, dann der FC Nürnberg, Hansa Rostock, der HSV und Kräuter viert. Das sind dann schon so wegweisende Wochen, sagt er. Und wenn bei vier Punkten aus diesen ersten fünf Spielen Leitel weg wäre, ist seine These, dann werden wir nach dem Winter sehen, wie sich das entwickelt. Und wenn da die Ergebnisse weiterhin ausbleiben und man weiterhin in dieser Teil-Bellen-Region, die man sich sicherlich bei aller Aufstiegseuphorie oder angepeiltem Aufstieg oder zumindest etablieren unter den Top-Plätzen der 2. Liga, diesen Platz hat man sich sicherlich vorher nicht vorgestellt. Genau, das wäre es zum Sportlichen. Dann, ja, St. Pauli-Bezug. Wir erinnern uns an das Auswärtsspiel von Hannover am Millantor, wo es einen absolut unverhältnismäßigen Polizeieinsatz im Gästeblock gab. Mutmaßlich soll es da –der Grund soll mutmaßlich gewesen sein, dass es interne Auseinandersetzungen im Gästeblock gab. Und dann hat die Polizei das als legitimen Anlass gesehen, um in den Block zu gehen, massiv mit Pfefferspray zu agieren. Man kann da gerne noch mal nach googeln und sich die Zahlen der Verletzten und so weiter nochmal angucken. Da sind auch einige Uniformierte dabei, die wahrscheinlich, würde ich jetzt mutmaßen, auch einfach ihren eigenen Einsatz zum Teil zum Offen gefallen sind. Natürlich hat man sich auch im Gästeblock massiv gegen diesen Einsatz gewährt. Da ist einfach vieles, vieles schiefgelaufen und reiht sich ein in die, wir könnten jetzt zahlreiche Ereignisse aus den letzten Wochen auch aus der ersten Bundesliga aufzählen, wo einfach Polizeieinsätze massiv schiefgelaufen sind, wenn man es vorsichtig formulieren möchte. Und genau, da kann ich aber gerne das NDS aus unserem Format aus dem Milan schon empfehlen, was Luca geführt hat. Da hat er sich auch Augenzeugenberichte aus dem Gästeblog damals eingeholt. Und das kann man vielleicht auch jetzt nochmal nachhören. Das ist leider auch, muss man auch traurigerweise sagen, eine der meistgehörten Folgen, die wir jemals hatten. Das ist halt dann auch immer so ein bisschen sensations-heischend. Spiele, in denen viel passiert abseits des Platzes, sind halt dann nochmal für die Allgemeinheit irgendwie interessanter, oder da möchte man eher nochmal hören, was da los war, genau, das an dieser Stelle nochmal empfohlen, weil halt relativ zeitlos da auch über diesen Vorfall erzählt wird. Dann kommen wir zum von dir schon erwähnten Martin Kind. Und ja, es gab ja jetzt nun die Abstimmung innerhalb der DFL, wo bis heute nicht klar ist und er sich ja auch nicht dazu äußert, wie er abgestimmt hat im Namen von Hannover 96, versteckt sich da so ein bisschen dahinter, dass die Abstimmung ja geheim abgehalten wurde. Und ja, das schützt ihn jetzt quasi davor, sich eigentlich auch nicht äußern zu müssen. Tobi sagt dann, also nicht zuletzt dadurch wird ein Bruch mit den Fans wieder spürbarer, langsam. Ja, und halt auch im Verhältnis mit dem EV ist es halt wirklich dann schwierig. Da steht auch noch eine Revision vom Bundesgerichtshof aus wegen der Abberufung damals, wo es erst ein Urteil vom Oberlandesgericht Zelle gab, dass das nicht wirksam sei. Und genau, also auch viele, viele Nebenschauplätze. Und solange Kind sich da nicht äußert, kann man ihnen da wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel machen, weil die Abstimmung eben geheim war und er nicht verpflichtet ist, dieses Abstimmung oder sein Abstimmungsergebnis öffentlich zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist nochmal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Gerade hinsichtlich auch der von der DFL immer gerne beschwornen Transparenz, sichtlich des Investoreneinstiegs. Das ist natürlich ein blanker Hohn, wenn man eben dann geheim abstimmt. Ja, genau aus solchen Gründen macht man das. Ja, da haben wir auch ein Tribüngespräch zu aufgenommen, das werde ich auch nochmal verlinken. Genauso wie eure NDS-Folge, also für nach dem Spiel steht NDS, falls sich das jemand gefragt hat, dann habt ihr nicht genügend Millantum gehört. Ihr sprecht immer vor dem Spiel und nach dem Spiel mit Gästen des jeweiligen Gegners. Das werde ich auch nochmal verlinken. Und nur einmal noch kurz der sportliche Kontext dieses Spiels. Zum Rest hast du schon gesagt, es war halt insofern auch, hatte es nochmal eben einen besonderen Kontext, dass das damals auch ein absolutes Topspiel war. Hannover auf Rang 3, St. Pauli als Tabellenführer auf St. Pauli dann und ab diesem Einsatz war dieses Spiel irgendwie, das war ja so 10 Minuten vor Ende, es war eine ganz seltsame Stimmung. Im Grunde haben die Spieler dieses Spiel dann so ein bisschen runter gespielt und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass daher jetzt auch der Knick kommt, aber es ist zumindest auffällig. Also danach konnte Hannover nicht mehr gewinnen, das hat jetzt damit nichts, da gibt es keine Kausalität. Aber das macht es nochmal so ganz besonders absurd. Also dieses Spiel hatte eben sportlich alles, um ganz, ganz toll zu sein und im Grunde hat danach dann zu Recht niemand über das Sportliche gesprochen, weil das andere Thema eben dann einfach wichtig war.
Und wie ist jetzt ausgelangen?
Martin Kindert übrigens auch, wenn ich es richtig sehe, in der neuen Presse am 22. an dem Tag, an dem wir aufnehmen, den Aufstieg quasi abgehakt. Also auch da hat er sich wieder zu Wort gemeldet.
Dann spielen sie gut, sobald dann wieder vom Aufstieg gesprochen wird, dann spielt Hannover 96 schlecht. Und auswärts ist man meistens nicht so gut. Zumindest war das oft so.
Ich finde, Martin Kind ist so ein bisschen Ebeneezer Scrooge von einer Weihnachtsgeschichte. Außer, dass ich nicht glaube, dass irgendwelche Geister ihn irgendwie noch zur Besinnung führen können. Weil das sehe ich nicht mehr.
Ja, das lassen wir einfach so stehen. Volle Zustimmung. Lasst uns über Hertha BSC sprechen, die kommen nämlich jetzt ran. Wir sind jetzt auf dem siebten Tabellenplatz angelangt. 25 Punkte hat die Hertha damit. 6 Punkte Rückstand auf Rang 3. Wobei zu dieser Hertha-Saison gehört, dass man lange gar nicht so sehr nach oben, sondern erst mal nach unten gucken musste. Aber anders als zum Beispiel Schalke 04, Yannick, hat man es geschafft, den Trend umzukehren. Wie hat man das geschafft? Was ist das für eine Saison? Und in welche Richtung, glaubst du, kann sich Hertha jetzt dann in der Rückrunde orientieren?
Ja, du hast schon gesagt, fangen wir erst mal vorne an. In den ersten drei Spielen gab es ein Torverhältnis von 0 zu 5. Damals stand man dann auf Platz 18. Immerhin ist man da im Pokal weitergekommen und ist ja auch nach wie vor im Pokal vertreten. Das sind vielleicht aus sportlicher Sicht positive Nachrichten erst mal. Nach diesen ersten Spielen gab es aber ein 5 zu 0 gegen Fürst. Da kann Michi gleich kurz erklären, wie das überhaupt passieren konnte. Dann hatten wir eben schon dieses 4 zu 6 aus eigener Sicht in Magdeburg, wo wir eben aus Magdeburger Sicht darüber gesprochen haben. Nach fünf Spielen war es dann immer noch Platz 17. Danach –ich habe auch mit einer Herr Tarnensohn gesprochen, so genau weiß sie auch nicht, was dann passiert ist. Sie spricht zum Beispiel von einer zunehmenden Einheit. Zum einen auf dem Platz, aber auch in allen Ebenen drum herum. Also auch zwischen Mannschaft und Fans zum Beispiel. Das war ja auch schon mal anders. Wenn man sich zurückerinnert, gab es auch mal Zeiten, wo Spieler aufgefordert wurden, ihre Tikros abzugeben. Das ist jetzt wohl nicht mehr so. Man hat danach nur noch gegen einen gewissen FC St. Pauli und einen gewissen FC Nürnberg verloren. Und ist seitdem wettbewerbsübergreifend umgeschlagen. Man möge es mir als St. Paulianer verzeihen, dass ich jetzt besonders noch mal auf das achte Finale gegen den HSV hinweise, wo es 5 zu 3 nach Elfmeterschießen für die Hertha endete und man aber nur dahin kam, weil man zum einen in der neunzigsten und in der 120. jeweils den Ausgleich geschossen hat, der dann zum Weitergang dieser Partie führte. Dann gucken wir noch mal so ein bisschen. Man hat ja im Sommer oder auch schon vorher von diesem Berliner Weg gesprochen, zu dem man ja jetzt ein bisschen gezwungen wurde, weil man eben auch einfach Gehälter einsparen musste, sowohl bei Spielern als auch im ganzen Angestelltenverhältnis, wo sicherlich viel, viel eingespart wurde. Und so ist dieser Berliner Weg sicherlich zum einen bewusst, aber auch ein bisschen gezwungenermaßen eingeschlagen worden. 32 Spieler umfasst der erweiterte Zweitliga-Kader, ich zitiere jetzt vom RBB, und 13 dieser Akteure haben große Teile, wenn nicht ihre gesamte Fußballjugend in Hertha's Akademie verbracht. Als Beispiele werden natürlich jetzt hier die drei Dadai-Brüder, Palko, Martin und Benz genannt und Martin Winkler, der auch erst 18 Jahre jung ist. Die haben Hertha's Zweitliga-Song bisher maßgeblich mitgeprägt. Laut RBB gehen sie wohl diesen Berliner Weg voran, während die anderen Eingewächse ihnen mal mit mehr, mal weniger Abstand folgen. So viel zum Berliner Weg. Wie gesagt, hatte ich noch mit Rebecca, die kennt man aus unserer Saisonvorschau, Milan Thunmiets von diesem Sommer. Sie hatte Hertha vorher auf Platz 6 getippt. Aus ihrer Sicht ist man da voll auf Kurs. Sie sieht weiterhin das Potenzial und dann kommt man aus ihrer Sicht an einem Namen auf jeden Fall nicht vorbei. Das ist Fabian Reese, letzte Saison noch bei Holstein Kiel. Er hatte dann den Transfer schon eingetütet, dass man noch gar nicht wusste, dass Hertha nächstes Jahr, also diese Saison, auch Zweite Liga spielen würde. Der hat sich aber dort fantastisch entwickelt. Vor seinen sportlichen Leistungen fiel er in den Medien vor allem damit auf, dass er gerne mal mit lackierten Fingernägeln über die Berliner Flohmärkte spazieren würde. Aber jetzt ist da anscheinend auch sportlich der Knoten geplatzt. Sie sagt aber auch einschränkend, dass man einfach viel zu abhängig von seiner Leistung sei. Also wenn der sich mal verlässt, wer weiß, wo das dann landen könnte. Dann gibt es ja noch eine Person mit Toni Leistner. Der hat ja auch eine Unioner-Vergangenheit. Habe ich zumindest von außen wahrgenommen, den einfachsten Start bei der Hertha aufgrund seiner Vergangenheit. Man stellt sich nur mal vor, als Haua käme zum FC St. Pauli oder umgekehrt. Der ist aber mittlerweile Kapitän und geht da wohl voran. Das Miteinander in der Mannschaft habe ich schon angesprochen und auch die Einheit zwischen Rasen und Rängen nenne ich es mal. Sie hat aber natürlich auch Kritik bei aller sportlich guten Entwicklung in den letzten Tagen und Wochen. Man hat halt gefühlt kein Mittelfeld. Es fehlt die Entlastung für Reze. Es gibt schwangende Leistungen. Sie sagt, wenn man eine Tabelle aus Halbzeit 1 bauen würde, wäre man im Aufstiegskampf dabei. Wenn man eine Tabelle aus Halbzeit 2 bauen würde, wäre man im Aufstiegskampf. Das testiert sich auch so ein bisschen durch unsere Aufnahme heute Abend. Dass Mannschaften da die Konstanz fehlt und dass man es entweder nicht zu Ende bringt oder dann noch Punkte liegen lässt.
Also ich kann das nur noch mal kurz unterstreichen. Die Tabelle zur Halbzeit Harte auf Platz 1, 34 Punkte auf Platz 2, der KSC 30 Punkte. Da habe ich vorhin angesprochen, egal wie die führen, hinten raus versauen sie es noch. Aber ja, man kann das wirklich so sagen zur Halbzeit. Sieht es immer sehr gut aus für Harte WSC. Aber Eva, du wolltest noch was ergänzen.
Ja, gerade bei Fabian Reza, es ist ja nicht nur eine Eventualität. Man hat es im Spiel gegen Osnabrück gesehen. Da fehlte Fabian Reza nämlich. Das Spiel ist 0-0 ausgegangen. Ich würde einfach mal sagen, wie beide Teams dann in letzter Zeit drauf waren, war das auf jeden Fall ein kleiner Rückschritt. Auch liebe Grüße an meinen Podcast-Kollegen Louis Richter, der war überhaupt nicht begeistert nach dem Spiel. Er hat gesagt, es war richtig hart, Kost anzugucken. Das kam wahrscheinlich auch die Länderspielpause zur genau richtigen Zeit. Darauf muss ja gar nicht immer unbedingt neue Transfers sein, sondern dass man einfach eine Mannschaft taktisch noch mal anders drauf anstellt. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass auch eine Pall Dadai das ganz gut schafft, dass gar nicht mal sein Ziel ist, zu sagen, naja, dann holen wir uns noch einen neuen Spieler rein. Und was ist, wenn der verletzt wird, sondern dass ich von Anfang an, das kann man hinterher sehr gut bei Kiel drüber reden, dass man einfach Spieler vielleicht flexibel darauf einstellt, dass ein Fabian Reza ersetzt werden kann. Ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen, kann durchaus gelingen. Gleichzeitig ist es eben schon. Ich muss auch sagen, Fabian Reza, als ich Gehörter, wer wechselt zu Hertha, als Hertha noch Bundesligist war, habe ich gesagt, boah, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt so was wird. Ich habe mich da auch etwas verbal mit Marc Switzki drüber gestritten. Er ist ja auch bekannter Gast dieses Formats, weil er meinte, doch, doch, das passt, John. Gut, wir werden nie wissen, wer von uns beiden recht behält, weil die Hertha ist ja nun mal abgestiegen. Aber ja, ich glaube dennoch, die Anlaufzeit bei der Hertha hat ja schon gezeigt, dass es definitiv ein bisschen gebraucht hat, bis er seinen Weg darin gefunden hat, weil, glaube ich, auch einfach der Sprung von Holstein Kiel zu Hertha BSC in allen Belangen ziemlich groß war. Aber ja, es macht durchaus Spaß, ihm beim Fußball zu spielen, zuzukommen.
Ja, neben allem anderen, was da noch neben dem Platz stattfindet, würdest du mir denn, Yannick, zustimmen, wenn ich sage, also Hertha hat sich stabilisiert in der zweiten Liga, das ist ja unbestritten, aber ich habe auch den Eindruck allein den Ergebnissen nach und ich habe zu Teile manche Spiele gesehen, dass eine besondere Qualität von Hertha BSC ist, sie verlieren nicht mehr. Also sie sind sehr, sehr schwer zu schlagen. Du kannst, plakativ gesprochen, im Defi-Pokal-Achtelfinale bis zur neunzigsten und so 120. Minute gegen sie führen. Sie schießen dann noch den Ausgleich. Es sind jetzt neun Pflichtspiele in Folge, die man zum Ende der Hinserie hin nicht verloren hat. Und das könnte ja dann auch die Zutat sein, mit der man es tatsächlich schafft, sich dann vielleicht sogar nochmal richtig oben ran zu saugen.
Also ich glaube schon, ich habe eben bei Schalke 04 gesagt, dass der Zug da eher abgefahren ist, oben nochmal anzugreifen. Ich glaube schon, dass wenn Hertha jetzt auch diese gewonnene Stabilität oder auch diese Einheit, die Rebecca ja auch angesprochen hat, sowohl auf dem Platz als auch im Schulterschluss mit den Fans, wenn man das über den Winter tragen kann und auch in der Rückrunde beibereiten kann, dass auch dann die Ergebnisse stimmen, dann kann man da sicherlich –also ich glaube zum Aufstiegskampf wird es nicht mehr reichen. Dazu sind glaube ich dann einfach auch eine Abhängigkeit vom Fabian Reese zu groß. Das habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt. Haris Tabakovic ist immerhin Zweiter der Torschützenliste mit neun Toren. Also da hat man einfach zwei Spieler, wo man die Daumen drücken muss, dass die fit sind und spielen. Eva hat es ja gerade gesagt, wenn Fabian Reese fehlt, merkt man das sofort auf dem Platz. Das wird sicherlich auch bei den Top-Torjägern der Fall sein. Also wenn man diese Stabilität und ja verbunden mit Einzelspielern, die sicherlich dann nochmal einen Unterschied machen, da sind ja auch die Dadai-Brüder sicherlich auch zu erwähnen, die aber nun halt zum Teil auch noch sehr jung sind. Und bei jungen Spielern ist es einfach so, dass du da auch Schwankungen in den Leistungen hast. Von daher sind noch viele Variablen drin. Aber wenn man das allgemein vielleicht so beibehalten kann, wie man es jetzt in der Formtabelle ablesen kann, und in der Weile ungeschlagen ist, dann sollte Top 6, Top 7, sicherlich am Ende der Saison drin sein. Das wäre jetzt meine Einschätzung von außen.
Und ist für das Jahr nach dem Abstieg mit einer sehr, sehr jungen Mannschaft ja auch dann ein gutes Resultat. Also da können andere Bundesliga-Absteiger davon ein so kleines Liedchen singen. Die Hertha war tatsächlich –ich habe mich jetzt nicht nur Eva gemeint, ich habe letztes Jahr auch eine sehr schwierige Saison erlebt mit einem anderen Bundesliga-Absteiger. Aber die Hertha war teilweise ja wirklich mit diesen vielen Eingewächsen, die Yannick schon angesprochen hat. Wenn die alle mal auf dem Platz waren, dann war das einfach eine sehr, sehr junge Mannschaft. Ich habe nicht die genauen Zahlen da, aber so 24, x war teilweise schon mal der Schnitt. Und das ist dann schon in der zweiten Liga, wo es Mannschaften gibt, die mal einen Schnitt von 28 haben. Dann ist das halt vier Jahre Fußballerfahrung, machen vieles aus und sorgen halt eben dafür, dass man nach einer guten Halbzeit auch eine schlechte Folgen lässt und dann halt einfach einbricht.
Und man hatte eben zu dieser Saison hin 24 Zugänge und 27 Abgänge. Also wir haben das ja schon mal thematisiert. Die entsprechende Ligaturfolge heißt ein Dardai für alle Fälle, glaube ich. Und da haben wir das schon mal so aufgearbeitet. Der Umbruch war auch so groß, dass es sehr gut erklärbar war, warum der Start von HTA BST vielleicht nicht so nach Plan verlief. Und jetzt hat man sich aber eben stabilisiert.
Ich würde noch zwei Namen nennen, die vielleicht auch sinnbildlich dafür stehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle noch präsent haben, was mit einem gewissen Marius Gersbeck im Trainingslager diesen Sommer los war. Der war ja unter großer Freude der Herr Taner zurückgekommen aus Karlsruhe. Er fand es eine gute Idee, sich aus dem Besagten zu schleichen und in einer Kneipe um die Ecke eine Schlägerei anzufangen, die ihm von dem nach einem sechsstelligen Betrag gekostet hat an das Opfer, mit dem er sich inzwischen wohl ausgesprochen hat. Auch eine Zahlung an die österreichische Staatskasse damals. Das finde ich deshalb zum einen erwähnenswert, weil es natürlich lange auf der Kippe stand und Hertha den Ausgang des Verfahrens abgewartet hat. Man hat ihn dann quasi begnadigt, nenne ich es mal. Er ist jetzt die nominelle Nummer zwei. Wer aber von dieser ganzen Geschichte profitiert hat, möchte ich mal sagen, ist ein gewisser Thiag Ernst, auch erst 20 Jahre jung. Da haben wir es wieder mit einem sehr jungen Team, der seitdem die unangefochtene Nummer eins im Tor ist. Das wollte ich einfach nochmal erwähnt haben. Und zur Person Marius Gersberg vielleicht noch, dass er sich auch auf der Mitgliedersaussammlung, die auch Hertha jetzt hatte, vor kurzem hingestellt hat und die Fehler eingeräumt hat. Er sagte, es wäre der größte Fehler seines Lebens gewesen. Hätte sicherlich auch ganz anders ausgehen können, wenn man so an den Fortgang seiner Karriere denkt. Und es sind wohl rund 50 Hertha-Ner-Innen nach dieser Sache, nachdem man gesagt hat, man gibt ihm noch eine zweite Chance oder begnadigt ihn, erstmal aus dem Verein ausgedreht. Und er hat jetzt angefangen, mit jedem einzelnen von denen Kontakt aufzunehmen, Telefonate geführt und sich aber auch bereit erklärt, ansprechbar weiterhin zu sein, um sich da zu erklären und die Leute zurück zum Verein zu holen. Fand ich noch eine ganz bemerkenswerte Geschichte.
Siehst du, das hatte ich nämlich, diese letzte Worte hatte ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Danke dafür. Das fand ich jetzt nochmal sehr interessant. Jetzt aber müssen wir, bevor uns hier Kevin vor heißen Kohlen im Stehen irgendwie jetzt gleich die Fragen beantworten muss, jetzt müssen wir zum SCP kommen. Und jetzt ist es natürlich so, Kevin, wir haben erst vor zwei Wochen über Paderborn gesprochen. Na ja, es war am 8. Dezember. Genau, vor zwei Wochen war es. Dann folgte danach noch ein 2 zu 1 beim HSV und dann ein 3 zu 0 gegen Hansa Rostock. Und auch das hat dazu geführt, dass man jetzt auf Rang 6 liegt, 27 Punkte hat, 4 Punkte Rückstand sind es aktuell auf den Aufstiegsplatz. Was hat sich denn noch zusätzlich ergeben zur letzten Ligatur? Oder gab es noch Aspekte, die wir da nicht richtig beleuchtet haben? Was würdest du denn jetzt so abschließend für ein Fazit zu dieser Hinrunde ziehen?
Ja, erstmal, dass es die zweitbeste Hinrunde aller Zeiten des SCP in der 2. Liga ist. Was man nach dem Hinrundenverlauf jetzt eher nicht hätte schätzen wollen oder können. Wo es ja stimmungstechnisch eine Berg- und Talfahrt war. Auch ergebnistechnisch immer wieder hoch und runter ging. Ja, das ist schon sehr beachtlich. Auch mit dem Vorausgesetzt, wenn die zu der heutigen Sendung gehört haben vom 8. Dezember, was ich da erzählt habe, ist es wirklich beachtlich. Und da nötigt man auch Respekt ab, dass diese Mannschaft das hinbekommen hat. Und dass man tatsächlich jetzt, auch wenn das erstmal primär nicht relevant ist, aber tatsächlich nur vier Punkte hinter den Aufstiegsringen steht, plötzlich wieder. Wo man ja vor dem Spiel gegen Nürnberg auch schon mal den Abstand hergestellt hatte, dann, wie das immer gegen Mannschaften aus der Region ist, verlor. Und dann in Elversberg sich richtig gut in die Krise geschossen hatte, in die vermeintliche. Der damalige Kaderumbruch, damaliges, wie vor zwei Jahren, also vor Wochenfrist getätigte, damals nach Elversberg getätigte Kaderumbruch, wo die Kapitäne aus der Mannschaft rausgetan wurden, zumindest aus der Startelf. Und Yannick Huth, der bis dahin Kapitän war, oder es ja formell auch noch ist, aber auch seitdem nicht mehr ins Tor zurückgekehrt ist, haben sich als gut herausgestellt, als die richtige Option offenbar. Denn seitdem, wie du gesagt hast, hat man wieder Punkte geholt und ist sehr persönlich durch die Hinrunde dann doch durchgekommen, mit allen Widrigkeiten, die es da gab.
Und das ist ja interessant, weil das hatten wir ja da thematisiert. Da haben wir ja noch gesagt, da hat man dann danach gar nicht mehr so viele Möglichkeiten. Es war ja so ein bisschen, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, ja auch ein Bejahen der Jugend und ein bisschen Erfahrung raus. Und jetzt eher wieder mit jungen Spielern und die jetzt die Verantwortung nehmen, ihnen das Vertrauen schenken und damit dann gleich mal beim HSV zu gewinnen. In einem sehr, sehr wilden Spiel mit zwei roten Karten, was man dann aber über die Zeit bringt, hinten raus. Also scheint so zu sein, als ob das auch das ist, was zu Lukas Kwasniok als Trainer passt?
Ja, absolut. Also zum Beispiel Anza ist ja bis jetzt Startspieler geblieben, der aus der U21 hochgezogen worden ist. War vorher schon mal Anfangs der Saison, aber da hat niemand damit gerechnet, dass er Stammspieler wird. Und der ist jetzt auch geblieben und hat sich dann ja sogar belohnt gegen Rostock und gegen den HSV mit sehr guten Leistungen. Man konnte in Hamburg gewinnen mit so einem Team, was auch nicht selbstverständlich ist, nachdem man vorher diese zwei Ergebnisse hatte. Wobei wir gegen den HSV traditionell ganz gut aussehen in den letzten Jahren. War das schon ein Achtungserfolg. Auch der Sieg gegen Hannover war eigentlich zu erwarten, weil Hannover noch nie gegen uns gewonnen hat. Aber tatsächlich sind wir, habe ich ja da gesagt, Angstgegner einer Mannschaft zumindest. Das ist Hannover 96. Da ist das schon sehr beachtlich. Und gegen Rostock war das eine sehr, sehr souveräne Leistung. Eine Mannschaft, die auch bei solchen langen Unterbrechungen immer wieder aus der Kabine gekommen ist und quasi so gespielt hat, als wäre nichts passiert. Da muss man auch den Hut vorziehen, die sich dann sogar noch steigern konnte. Und ja, Lukas Krasniok, wie gesagt, der hat sich auch so ein bisschen oder sich und die Mannschaft als das wandelnde Chamäleon bezeichnet, die sich den Widrigkeiten anpassen musste. Die Mannschaft ist durch sehr, sehr schwierige Phasen gegangen mit vielen Verletzungen. Der ganze Sturm war Anfangs der Saison verletzt. Und wie gesagt, man hat absolute Leistungsträger verloren. Schallenberg habe ich ja vorhin schon genannt. Julian Justwahn, der jetzt eventuell im Winter zum FC St. Pauli verliehen werden soll von Hoffenheim, weil er dort halt gar nicht stattfindet, aber bei uns halt einer der Keyplayer war. Und jetzt im Winter wird uns ja aller Voraussicht nach auch unserem Momentaner, Top-Spieler Muslia, verlassen können zumindest. Wobei jetzt unser sportlicher Geschäftsführer gesagt hat, dass kein exorbitantes, unwiderstehliches Angebot vorliegen würde. Das machen die natürlich immer wieder gerne, um den Preis noch mal ein bisschen anzuschrauben. Aber er hat auch gesagt –und das fand ich eine krasse Aussage, auch wenn es nicht sehr ehrlich ist –man würde gerne mit Muslia bis zum Sommer gehen. Bisher war immer die Rede, man hat ihm einen neuen Vertrag angeboten, aber das will er wohl nicht. Man würde also gerne bis zum Sommer mit ihm gehen und gemeinsam noch Geld verdienen. Und die Erklärung dahinter ist, dass natürlich ein Platz 4 in der 2. Liga mehr Geld bringt als ein Platz 9. Und wenn man Muslia im Winter verlieren würde, würde man sehr viel Qualität verlieren. Das hat man gesehen in den Spielen, wo er gefiltert hat. Das waren nämlich die besagten Niederlagen. Da war er nicht dabei. Wobei ich auch glaube, dass die Mannschaft, das über die Hinrunde gesehen, auch wieder kombinieren könnte. Das letzte Mal, als wir das hatten, war, als wenn Michael dann im Winter in die Bundesliga gewechselt ist zur Union Berlin. Da war er hier auch landunter. Der absolute Publikumsliebling ging weg. Keiner allahm vermutet, jetzt kommt der tiefe Pfeil. Aber ich bin da ein bisschen bei dem guten Herrn Weber. So heißt unser Geschlecht. Ich vergesse heute immer, die Namen zu nennen. Benjamin Weber, eines Zeichens Assistent von Thomas Tuchel damals in Paris, Dortmund und London. Er zieht bei uns inzwischen die sportlichen Fäden im Winter. Es ist eine ehrliche Aussage, eine unromantische Aussage. Aber er hat ja recht, indem er sagt, lasst uns zusammen noch Geld verdienen. Und im Sommer kannst du dann gehen. Das hat man jetzt im Winter genauso mit Ron Schallenberg gemacht. Der sollte ja auch im Winter schon heiß umworben sein von Schalke und Werder Bremen. Und ist dann erst im Sommer nach Gelsenkirchen gewechselt.
Und dann konnte man da endlich Content mit Ron Schallenberg produzieren. Wie viele Minuten müssen wir jetzt noch Logue auf Max Kruse abhalten, der seine Karriere beendet hat als Paderborner Legende, nehme ich an?
Ja, also das wird ja immer wieder aufgegriffen, auch auf dem Fernsehsender, der viel Fußballbundesliga und Zweite Liga zeigt. Eigentlich bei jedem Spiel wird das immer noch einmal erwähnt. Ich finde es immer müßig. Ich kann es natürlich verstehen, weil natürlich viele Fußballfans den Namen halt kennen. Und es war von Anfang an einfach ein Experiment. Er hat nichts gekostet. Es hätte gut gehen können, indem er irgendwie einschlägt. Also was weiß ich, acht Tore vorbereitet, vier schießt oder so. Dann hat er sich früh verletzt, hat aber auch einfach merken müssen, dass bei Lukas Kwasniok –das war bei Steffen Baumgart vorher auch schon so –Namen keine Rolle spielen, solange die im Training nicht performen. Und im Spiel sowieso nicht, sind die ganz schnell raus. Das ist einfach so. Steffen Baumgart hat es ja bei den anderen arrivierten Spielern, die er nach Elversberg aussortiert hat, auch gesagt, wer sich nicht 100 Prozent mit dem SCP, aber auch mit der 2. Liga arrangiert, also über 100 Prozent motiviert ist, sondern sagt, für mich ist die 2. Liga eine Selbstverständlichkeit geworden, der ist bei mir raus. Der hat in meiner Mannschaft gesagt, das ist ja legitim, aber der hat bei mir in der Mannschaft halt keinen Platz. Und ich glaube, dass für Max Kruse die 2. Liga jetzt keine Opportunity war, also sich zu zeigen oder so. Das war einfach für ihn nochmal ein Gag. Hey, ich kann mich nochmal versuchen, nochmal fit zu werden, mein kleines Bäuchlein nochmal abzutrainieren, meine Frau vielleicht nochmal ins Schaufenster mit reinzuzielen oder andersrum, weiß ich nicht, die inne ist jetzt eigentlich bei Big Brother eher beschäftigt. Und also, das ist ähnlich, viele hier vergleichen es halt mit der Top-Verpflichtung damals von Stefan Effenberg. In Paderborn muss man jetzt auch endlich mal verstehen, das versucht man offenbar im 5-Jahres- oder 8-Jahres- oder 10-Jahres-Rhythmus einmal, jemanden, der mal auf einer großen Bühne war, hier nach Paderborn zu machen. Das passt einfach nicht zu uns. Wir sind ein Verein, der junge Talente pusht, der viele große Trainer rausgebracht hat, große Trainer anfangs nicht, aber die halt dann in der Bundesliga oder Champions League sogar als Trainer gegangen sind. Michroga Schmidt zum Beispiel, Józlo Ukei, Andre Breitenreiter und so weiter. Baumgart, André Schubert. Also viele dabei gewesen, die aus Paderborn kommen.
Das war jetzt wie so ein Studentenfutter. Da kann man auch manchmal eine Rosine erwischen.
Nein, aber –oder halt auch Spieler, die es woanders nicht geschafft haben. Aber Max Kruse hatte es ja woanders geschafft. Das ist viel aus dem Raster. Wir verpflichten eigentlich keine Spieler, die über 30 sind. Das war mit Grimaldi vor den Sohls schon krass, dass wir den mit 32 noch aus der dritten Liga geholt haben. Wo ich sehr skeptisch war, dass er sich aber im Nachhinein als absoluter Glücksgriff erwiesen hat, der inzwischen auch einer der Publikumslieblinge ist hier. Wird schon Euro-Luigi genannt und so was, weil er diesen Schnäuzer hat und ein bisschen an Luigi von Mario Brothers erinnert? Also, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit dieser Vorrunde im Großen und Ganzen. Ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, was wäre möglich gewesen, wenn diese Mannschaft ohne Verletzung durch die Vorrunde gegangen wäre und ohne diesen Adalast, dass quasi die Mittelachse komplett –also wenn man Peeringer dazu nimmt als Stürmer, der ja nur Ausgliener von Schalke, aber trotzdem eine große Rolle gespielt hat, wenn die halt noch dabei wären.
Aber ich muss jetzt tatsächlich noch einmal einhaken, weil für mich bleibt die große Frage, warum man diesem Max Kruse das Experiment überhaupt gewagt hat. Weil ehrlich gesagt, Kevin, du hast angesprochen mit dem ganzen Schallenbergding, so wie man ihn auf Schalke ruft hat, so mit den Egos, die da eine Rolle spielen. Und ich finde ehrlich gesagt, das war ein Experiment, was von Anfang an auch richtig hätte schiefgehen können. Also im Sinne von, dass es auch die kommen. Man könnte ja im Zweifel sagen, es hat ja in gewisser Weise auch vielleicht ein Mannschaftsgefüge an der einen oder anderen Stelle gestört. Weil wenn du als Paderborn, und ich kann das auch aus einem Bielefeld-Standort-Standpunkt wie auch immer, neidlos anerkennen, da wird richtig gut Scouting betrieben. Da hat man gute Transfers gemacht. Und dann kam im Sommer der Max-Kruse-Transfer. Und da stand ich wirklich so, aber warum denn? Weil man für mich, ehrlich gesagt, fast das eingerissen hätte, was man sich jahrelang aufgebaut hat. Dass man auch einen gewissen Ruf auf dem Transfermarkt hat. Und das ist für mich ehrlich gesagt das Beste, was Paderborn jetzt hätte passieren können, dass Kruse und Paderborn sich auf dieses Ende geeinigt haben. Das geht irgendwie klar. Du hast gesagt, er hat nichts gekostet. Ja, vielleicht als Ablöse nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Max Kruse als Gehalt so ein super günstiger Spieler war. Ich glaube schon, dass er gewisse Gehaltsvorstellungen hatte. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie man da eingegangen ist. Aber ich meine, das war ja anders als vielleicht bei einem Halzenberg und Kurve, wo man dann gesagt hat, okay, Gehaltserbußungen, weil der Verein bedeutet mir so viel. Und ich meine, da hat Max Kruse ja selber auch schon deutlich gemacht, dass das vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt der springende Punkt war. Und also, das finde ich schon ein Risiko, was man eingegangen ist, was man ja fast sagen könnte, was einem vielleicht zwischendurch auch auf die Füße gefallen ist, obwohl man noch rechtzeitig die Kurve gekriegt hat, aber was ja richtig böse hätte enden können für die komplette Teamdynamik.
Ja, plus du hattest ja den Vorfall mit dem Trainer noch im Sommer. Also das war schon doppelt mutig halt. Die Trikotverkäufe haben sich allerdings rentiert. So wie ich das aus zuverlässigen Quellen erfahren habe, hat sich das alleine deswegen amortisiert mindestens, dass man die geholt hat.
Echt, wie viele Trikots verkaufen wir denn da?
Ich weiß nicht, wir hatten glaube ich Rekordtrikotverkäufe diesen Sommer. Ja, man verdient so 40 Euro an so einem …Es ist halt ein Event, wenn in Paderborn so jemand aufläuft.
Das ist halt so …Ja, ich meine klar, das war euer Bonucci. Das war so, wie Union sich Bonucci geholt hat im Sommer und der jetzt offenbar auch weg ist. So hat halt Paderborn auch …oder so wie Sadio Manet. Das sind halt so ein Poker-Chip, der einem irgendwie –passt ja auch bei Max Kruse –der fällt einem in den Schoß und dann denkt man sich, okay, probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ja, die Skepsis war halt …ich kann die verstehen, vor allem mit dem Blick von draußen. Und wenn halt die großen Persönlichkeiten aus der Kabine verschwinden gleichzeitig, die also hier das Sagen hatten, ist das natürlich eine Mixtur, die gefährlich ist. Aber ich habe von Anfang an quasi nur das zugetraut, weil der halt vom Typ her ziemlich straight ist, was sowas angeht. Und er hat jetzt auch immer wieder betont, wobei das, glaube ich, auch Goodwill ist, um einen persönlichen Abschied zu finden, dass er das Max-Goal-Sicht von Anfang bis Ende immer tadellos benommen hat, keine Allüren hatte, für die Kabine sogar wertvoll war, für die jungen Spieler –das mag ja auch alles sein. Nur …ja, das Risiko ist tatsächlich da. Also wir haben uns im Sommer auch alle gewundert. Wie gesagt, man hat zwei, drei Spieler über 30 geholt. Hat aber gleichzeitig –und das ist die wertvolle Erkenntnis –und das ist auch mit das Wichtigste, was in der letzten Saison passiert ist, dass unsere U21 in der Regionalliga aufgestiegen ist. Und wird deswegen auch da, glaube ich, gefühlt –ich weiß gar nicht –einen ganzen Kader neu verpflichtet haben fast für die zweite Mannschaft, wovon inzwischen zwei bis vier Spieler regelmäßig bei den Ligaspielen in der zweiten Liga dabei sind. Anser und Hansen als 19. Jäger von Schalke 04 geholt. Offenbar hat es nicht gereicht dort für die erste Mannschaft. Bei uns ist er direkt Stammspieler geworden. Er hatte jetzt am Ende einen kleinen Leistungsweg. Da hat Kvassniok ihn dann auch in der ersten Halbzeit schon einmal rausgenommen. Aber er war halt auch da –und das ist ganz cool bei ihm als Trainer –nicht, um ihn abzustrafen oder sowas, sondern er hat ihn dann auch quasi geherzt. Er hat ihn vor seiner –ja, mit 19 Jahren halt auch schützen wollen. Der Leistungsdell in dem Spiel war einfach eine Katastrophe. Das ist aber nicht schlimm. Der ist jetzt trotzdem ein guter Riesentalent. Und der wird über kurz oder lang mindestens in der 2. Liga auf der 6 oder 8 spielen.
Erster Profisaison, Stammspieler direkt. Da hat man ja getauscht.
Ja, genau. Und ob das so zugunsten von Schalke 04 war, aber jetzt wollen wir nicht da Runden aufreißen. Wie es für Paterborn weitergehen wird, auch hinsichtlich der Frage, schafft man es vielleicht noch, sich oben ranzusaugen. Darüber wird unter anderem das erste Spiel der Rückrunde entscheiden.
Furchtbar. Ich wusste vor der Saison, dass das unsere ganze Saison vermiesen kann, dass wir in Fürth starten mussten. Sorry, aber es ist unfassbar. Ich hasse dieses Spiel. Das ist nämlich genau –Wir haben noch nie gegen Fürth gewonnen. Ich glaube, wir haben schon gefühlt 40 Spiele gegeneinander gehabt. Nein, es waren, glaube ich, 27 oder so.
Das letzte Heimspiel habt ihr gewonnen gegen Fürth.
Ja, aber in Fürth haben wir noch nie gewonnen. Deswegen wusste ich, dass zum Saisonstart kriegen wir dann auch gleich, glaube ich, die dritte Minute, oder was war es, die rote Karte von unserem neuen Hoffnungsträger in der Innenverteidigung, der dann gleich mal für drei Spiele gesperrt war. Es war grandios. Also bei uns ist es nur einfach der Frankenflug. Eigentlich ist auch immer der Sendungstitel vor diesem Spiel. Wenn ein paar Tage war es der Frankenflug und dann 4.0 oder sowas. Das ist unfassbar. Auch gegen Nürnberg, gegen Regensburg, also irgendwie, wir spielen gegen die ganzen Mannschaften aus dem Süden unfassbar schlecht.
Tja, was soll man dazu sagen? Also 24 Spiele habt ihr bisher gegen die Spielvereinigung gemacht. Viermal gewonnen, achtmal Remit, zwölf Niederlagen. Und sollte da jetzt natürlich noch eine dazukommen zum Rückrundenauftakt, dann würde das …Das spielt in die Stadt.
Für das muss passen und es wird 2.0 für uns gewertet.
Das kann natürlich passieren, das ist natürlich das wahrscheinlichste Szenario. Aber für den unwahrscheinlichen Fall, dass beide Teams gegeneinander antreten, da könnte das wiederum für Viert bedeuten, dass man richtig mit Rückenwind die oberen Plätze attackieren kann. Und das, obwohl der Rückenwind so in der jüngeren Vergangenheit jetzt so ganz leicht nachgelassen hat. Aber man ist dran. Michi, 29 Punkte, 27 zu 20 Tore, acht Siege, fünf Unentschieden, vier Niederlagen. Und 29 Punkte bedeutet, zwei Punkte sind es auf Rang drei, vier Punkte sind es auf Rang zwei und sechs Punkte sind es auf Rang eins. Warum wird die Spielvereinigung Fürth in dieser Saison aussteigen?
Schwierige Frage. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es tun wird. Ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass sie länger oben dabei bleibt, weil sie etwas tut, was untypisch ist eigentlich für eine Mannschaft, wo man im Sommer dachte, Ovei Ovei Defensive ist ein großes Problem. Man hat nämlich in den Vorbereitungsspielen eigentlich immer viele Tore kassiert. Vier gegen Gornik Sapche, gegen die SC Paderborn locker 4-0 gewonnen hat. Auch andere Vereine haben immer zu Null gewonnen. Das war so in Österreich. Dann haben alle Vereine immer gegen Gornik Sapche gespielt. Die Viertel haben die meisten Tore kassiert. Es gab auch Fans, die sagten, mit dieser Mannschaft, mit dieser Abwehr, das kann gar nichts werden. Jetzt hat man die zweitbeste Abwehr der 2. Bundesliga, hat achtmal schon zu Null gespielt. Jonas Urbeck hat acht von 16 Spielen zu Null gespielt als Torhüter. Damit 50 Prozent, also schon krasse Quoten. Das ist natürlich für Mannschaften, die aufsteigen wollen, denke an Heidenheim zum Beispiel. Defensive Stabilität ist da ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Ding, was in Fürth nicht immer so war. Zorniger steht da eigentlich auch eher für diesen Spektakelfußball. Er hat damals auch was im Amtsantritt gesagt, dass er lieber mal 4 zu 3 als 1 zu 0 gewinnt. Das hat er auch letztes Mal wiederholt, weil er ja im Entertainment-Businessfußball tätig ist. Aber Fürth macht das Defensive extrem gut, er hält die Gegner weit vom Tor weg. Auch die Expected-Goals pro Schuss sind sehr gering, also 0,1, 1, 0,12 ist der Schnitt, also knapp unter diesem Schnitt auch. Man lässt wenige Großchance noch einfach, das Gegner ist insgesamt zu. Man steht defensiv gut, aber was auch gesagt, 27 geschossene Tore sind auch die wenigsten all dieser Mannschaften, die da oben eben um den Aufstieg gerade spielen. Das heißt, man hat da, also Defensive steht gut, aber die Offensive funktioniert jetzt auch nicht so gut, was damit zusammenhängt, weil da kann man wieder den Vergleich zum SC Paderborn ziehen. Man hat Dennis Sabeni im Sommer geholt vom SCP. Der gegen den SCP, nach einer, Zornig hat es jetzt noch mal gesagt, der hat eine bärnstarken Vorbereitung gespielt und dann stand er in der Startelf gegen den SCP und Visa Muslihu hat ihm mal heftigst gegen das Sprunggelenk getreten. Also es war eine vertretbare Rote Karte, würde ich mal sagen. Und Dennis Sabeni kam als 12 oder 14-Tore-Stürmer. Den hat nämlich Zornig am Sommer gefordert, um Brani Maragota zu entlasten als Stürmer, der immer die meisten Tore schießen muss. 12 oder 14-Tore-Stürmer, Sabeni hat genau 0 Tore bislang geschossen in der ganzen Saison und auch 0 Vorlagen. Das heißt, er steht bei einer ganz großen Null als vermeintliche neue Sturmhoffnung, was einer der Gründer ist für diese offensive Flaute. Gota ist immer noch mit 6 Toren der beste Torschütze. Dahinter dann Trullian Green, 4 Tore. Also es ist nicht so, dass Fird da jedes Mal bombastisch spielt, aber wenn man oft zu Null spielt, reichen ja auch 1-0-Siege. Und das hat Fird eben gemacht, nämlich was wir vorhin hatten, mit diesem Run. Fird hat fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen. Ich weiß noch ganz genau, ich habe mit Alexander Zornäger einen Podcast aufgenommen, nach seinem Einjährigen. Da hat Fird gegen Osnabrück gespielt, er war auf Tabellenplatz 14. Und dann hat man fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen, jetzt zuletzt zwei Mal Unentschieden gespielt, jetzt ist man neben Tabellen fünfter zur Winterpause. Das geht sehr, sehr schnell, wenn man in diesen Flow kommt. Und Zornäger hat das auch, er ist ja bekannt für solche Aussagen. Dann auch mal gesagt, das Wichtigste ist einfach, Gleichmäßigkeit in seine Leistungen zu bringen und einfach mal eine gewisse Konstanz zu spielen. Man braucht ja gar nicht diese ständigen Ausreißer-Highlight-Spiele, dass man mal ein Spiel 7 zu 0 gewinnt, wie es Hannover macht, sondern es reicht ja, wenn man einfach jede Woche konstant performt, auch mit der schönen Fußballsprache und einfach die Siege holt. Und das hat Viertel eben in großer Regelmäßigkeit gemacht, kurz unterbrochen von einem Pokal aus beim vierteligsten Hamburg, was jetzt auch nicht so schön war. Aber man ist auch auswärts besser geworden. Also man war ja letztes Jahr in der Auswärtstabelle, dabei ein letzter mit nur zehn Punkten in 17 Spielen, ist deutlich besser geworden. Ich glaube, da hat man schon neun, müsste es sein. Neun Punkte. Und zu Hause ist man eh schon in der Spitzenmannschaft. Man ist nach dem HSV die beste Heimmannschaft. Es läuft vieles gut in Fürth, muss man sagen. Und es kommt jetzt auch nicht ganz von ungefähr, diese Erklärung, also diese Entwicklung. Weil, also Fürth hat, klar, war letztes Jahr, Eva weiß es noch gut, Fürth und Bielefeld haben lang gestruggelt. Fürth hat dann vielleicht den besseren Trainer geholt bei den Trainerwechseln, hat dann einen Zäuniger geholt und hat in dieser Zäuniger-Tabelle, die wird oft zitiert in Fürth, ich freue mich, ich habe sie eigentlich eingeführt, deswegen wird sie jetzt selbst von Rashida Souzi zitiert, hat man in diesen 21 Spielen nämlich 31 Punkte geholt unter Alexander Zäuniger schon in der vergangenen Saison. Das reichte für Platz 6 in dieser Zäuniger-Tabelle. Davor war eigentlich nur Heidenheim, St. Pauli, der HSV, Darmstadt und Düsseldorf, alles Mannschaften, die auch in der Tabelle einfach dann oben waren. Das heißt, man hat da schon gesehen, dass es eine gewisse Entwicklung gab. Dann gab es einen sehr guten Saisonauftakt, 15-0 gegen SCP, sorry Kevin. Wo man wirklich auch gezeigt hat, was diese Mannschaft zu leisten im Stande ist, offensiv. Also da dachte man, okay, das wird eine wahnsinnig gute Saison. Die wurde es dann aber nicht. Unter anderem, Yannick hat es vorhin mal angesprochen, ich habe es leider nicht ausführen können, 0-5 bei der Hertha, die davor eben kein einziges Tor geschossen hatte. Da hat man eben auch wieder gemerkt, dass auch Fütter eine junge Mannschaft hat, die sich immer noch, was mittlerweile auch öffentlich zugegeben wird, schwer tut, diesen großen Arenen zu spielen, weil man eben oft auswärts, wenn mehr Zuschauer da waren und es laut wurde im Stadion und diese Widerstände von außen, auch wieder Zorniger, groß wurden, die Mannschaft irgendwie sich nicht zu ihrer Stabilität gefunden hat. Und das war dann eben dieses Spiel bei der Hertha. Man hat auch beim HSV 2-0 verloren und auch da gab es aber eine Entwicklung, weil man jetzt, letztes Spiel vor der Winterpause, beim FC Schalke zweimal zu hinten lag, am Ende aber halt dann eben 2-2 gespielt hat und Zorniger wieder sein, was ich vorhin sagte, den Brutalen frotten und gewinnen wollen. Man hat zwar nicht gewonnen, hat aber zumindest mal das nicht verlieren wollen, hat man auch gestärkt. Also man merkt einfach, dass da eine gewisse Entwicklung in dieser Mannschaft da ist. Also individuell ist die Mannschaft schon mal sehr, sehr gut besetzt. Also Brandi Miragota, Julian Green, einfach sehr, sehr gute Spieler. Jonas Urbeck angesprochen, also wir haben vorhin Thiago Ernst noch mal gehabt, das sind halt einfach die nächsten deutschen Torwart-Hoffnungen. Alle 20 Jahre alt, Jonas Urbeck, ich finde das faszinierend, dieser Junge, wie er Fußball spielt, das sieht wirklich aus, als wäre er 15, wenn er vor allem steht und er spielt mit einer so großen Sicherheit, Fußball im Passspiel sicher, er hat gegen Magdeburg krasse Paraden gezeigt, also einfach ein sehr, sehr guter Torhüter, also der 1. FC Köln kann sich freuen mit seiner Transfersperre, wenn Jonas Urbeck zurückkehrt, egal, in welcher Liga man spielt. Man hat einen der besten deutschen Torhüter auf jeden Fall schon mal bei sich. Tim Lempeler ist ja auch ausgeliehen vom 1. FC Köln, der darf sich auch gerade noch in der 2. Liga weiterentwickeln, bevor er zum FC zurückkehrt, also die werden ihn auch zurückholen, nehme ich an. Das ist so eines der Probleme, er entführt ein bisschen, man hat nämlich drei Leitspieler, mit Robert Wagner auch noch einen, der auf der Sechs spielt, also drei Spieler, die wahrscheinlich am Ende der Saison wieder gehen werden, auf wichtigen Positionen, nämlich im Sturm, im Tor und auf der Sechs. Das ist so ein bisschen wackeliges Gebilde und lässt bei mir ein bisschen Angst aufkommen, dass man halt dann, wenn man in die Bundesliga aufsteigt, wie es letztes Mal auch war, da hat man auch fünf Stammspieler verloren und dann ging es ja so gründlich schief. Also ich möchte es nicht nochmal erleben, dass man so eine Saison spielt, wo man am 15. Spieltag zum ersten Mal ein Spiel gewinnt. Deswegen, der Viertel an sich ist ja gerne ein bisschen pessimistischer. Vielleicht ist es ja auch ganz schön in der zweiten Liga. Anders als muss man natürlich einfach auch sagen, für einen Verein wie Viertel, auch ein Bundesliga-Jahr, so bitter es ist und so öfter man sich zum Gespürt gemacht hat, so oft irgendwie von Tasmanier, Viertel, an die Rede war, und ich konnte es irgendwann nicht mehr hören in der Sportschau, noch auf Sky. Aber es ist halt einfach finanziell extrem gut. Also Viertel hat da einen Rekordumsatz damals gehabt in der Bundesliga, hat jetzt auch, zuletzt wurden die Zahlen verkündet, 35,5 Millionen Euro Umsatz gemacht. Für Viertel war immer die 30-Millionen-Marke so die Grenze, die hat man jetzt locker mal überschritten, weil man eben in der Fernsehgeld-Tabelle so weit oben steht, weil es diese 5-Jahres-Wertung auch gibt. Insofern wäre ein weiteres Bundesliga-Jahr für Viertel Gold wert. Man hat jetzt dann auch in die Infrastruktur wieder investieren können, hat einen neuen Rasenplatz mit Rasenheizung gebaut, wobei man noch nicht ins Trainingslager fliegt, was mir in Klammern erspart, vielleicht über Trainingslager in der Türkei bei Erdogan schreiben zu müssen. Also das ist auch schön, dass das erspart bleibt. Man bleibt einfach in Viertel. Also natürlich wäre ein weiteres Bundesliga-Jahr sehr, sehr gut. Andererseits muss man auch sagen, die Mannschaften oben sind schon auch sehr, sehr stabil. Gut, der St. Pauli sieht zuletzt auch nicht mal ganz zu. Aber mir fehlt so ein bisschen der Glaube, dass man das einfach so durchziehen kann, weil auch die Offensive sich noch sehr, sehr schwer tut. Und man hat es dann auch gemerkt, also in Braunschweig, das hatte ich vorhin mal erwähnt, hat man 1-0 gewonnen. Es hätte aber halt einfach auch schon nach 20 Minuten Zweihandel für Braunschweig stehen können. Es hätte der Ausgleich in der Nachspielzeit fallen können. Man hat das oft dann einfach gut verteidigt, aber es waren schon auch Klappespieler dabei. Und da müssten schon mal einige Spieler noch mal einen Schritt machen. Das ist natürlich bei einer jungen Mannschaft immer möglich. Ich habe jetzt auch mal gefragt, ob er das für möglich gehalten hat. Er hat ja so eine Entwicklung nach diesem Pokal aus. Das war einfach an Halloween, also am 31. Oktober. Da war gefühlt Krise. Ich habe auch einen Kommentar geschrieben mit sehr vielen kritischen Fragen. Und danach hat die Mannschaft einfach viermal gewonnen, was mir nicht so gut öffentlich zu Gute kam.
Da haben Sie einen Kommentar ausgedruckt und in die Kabine gehängt. Das musst du dann immer sagen, wenn sich jemand beschwert, musst du sagen, seht ihr denn nicht alle, dass ich dafür verantwortlich war?
Das Witzige war, ich dachte auch, dass ich dafür verantwortlich war, dass wir in Kaislautern gewonnen haben. Und Bani Margota lief an mir vorbei in der Mixed Zone und hat gesagt, wenn wir gewonnen haben, willst du wieder nicht mit mir sprechen? Da habe ich gesagt, ach so, ich dachte schon, du würdest wegen des Kommentars nicht mit mir sprechen. Er hat dann nur geschrieben, was hast du wieder für eine Scheiße geschrieben? Also er hat es nicht gelesen, glücklicherweise. Ich glaube auch, dass die wenigsten Spieler Kommentare in Zeitungen lesen.
Solange sie Podcasts hören, ist das für mich okay.
Ja, gibt es einen Spieler, der mich auf ein Podcast angesprochen hat, ich werde den Namen hier nicht erwähnen. Er kam im Podcast nicht so gut weg und hat sich ungerecht behandelt gefühlt. Nein, Nils Seufert ist ja leider nicht mehr da. Das spielt er bei der SV Josco Fensterried mit der Leberkäse-Cimmel auf dem Arm. Und das war auch nicht schon mehr ein Kunstbuch, Eva, für dich als Bielefelder. Aber jetzt hör mal auf, sonst wird es irgendwann identifizieren.
Genau, irgendwann kann man nach dem Ausflussverfahren, so wie bei Martin Kintz, Stimme, oder irgendjemand sonst.
Ihr habt doch im Trainerteam oder als Assistenten einen Medienprofi mit Jurek Rohrbeck. Der muss doch da vermitteln können. Also Jurek hat deine Seite quasi auch kennengelernt und weiß ganz genau, wie das funktioniert.
Ich glaube, Alexander Zornig, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht wissen, hat mit Jurek Rohrbeck einen Assistenten, was er sich auch bei Roger Schmidt, auch David, eine Parallelde, abgeschaut hat, der ja auch ein Ex-NDR-Journalisten als persönlichen Assistenten bei sich hatte, der unter anderem natürlich mit Sicherheit auch Medien-Schulungen in ihm gibt. Also Screening. Zornig hat mir mal erzählt, dass er wirklich jeden Text von mir auch liest, und man das mit Sicherheit auch in Essenz von Jurek Rohrbeck herausgefiltert. Aber er hat eben jetzt auch einen Assistenten, was für Viert dann schon bedeutet, dass man ein großes Trainerteam mittlerweile hat. Also in dieser Bundesligasaison, das ist noch nicht so lang her, hatte man eben einen Cheftrainer mit Stefan Leitl, der jetzt in Hannover ist, einen Co-Trainer und einen Co-Trainer, der gleichzeitig aber noch Videoanalyst war. Und jetzt hat man halt eben mittlerweile einen Cheftrainer, einen Cheftrainer-Assistenten, zwei Co-Trainer, zwei Athletiktrainer, einen Videoanalysten, einen Datenanalysten. Also auch das ist ja was, was man in Viert geschafft hat, weil man eben ein Jahr in der Bundesliga war und sich auch einfach infrastrukturell weiterentwickelt hat. Was wir gar noch nicht hatten, glaube ich, Zornig hat sein Vertrag ja in Viert auch verlängert. Also das ist natürlich auch nochmal ein wichtiges Zeichen gewesen. Ich glaube, das war in der letzten Ligatour noch nicht soweit. Weil der hat in Viert noch viel vor und er kann sich verwirklichen. Er hat auch ganz klar gesagt, er ist nicht mehr ein Trainer, der jetzt noch drei, vier Erstligisten oder Zweitligisten in seiner Vita stehen braucht, sondern will er beim Verein gestalten können und will Fußstapfen oder Fußspuren hinterlassen. Das macht er in Viert bislang sehr, sehr gut. Die Fans lieben ihn. Mittlerweile steht er sogar bei diesem gemeinsamen Feierritual mit Arme nach oben vor der Kurve. Ich finde, Zornig tut diesem ganzen Verein extrem gut. Er hat im Kicker-Interview zuletzt gesagt, er ist auch froh, dass er in Viert ist, weil er allen auf die Nerven gehen kann. Viert ist schon so ein Standort, wo ein bisschen verschlafen teilweise ist. Wenn man den PKs anschaut, bin ich oft alleine zum Beispiel. Da tut so ein Trainer einfach, der auf und abseits des Rasens sehr, sehr viel richtig macht und auch den Verein insgesamt weiterbringen will, der ihn gut repräsentiert. Er hat ja auch als Schuhling Green in Halle der Rassistisch beleidigt wurde, eine viel beachtete Ansage gemacht. Da kam von der berühmten, von vielen komischen Usern auf Twitter, gab es dann die Beschimpfungen, wie das sein kann, dass man eine vermeintlich demokratisch legitimierte Partei da beschimpft. Aber er hat ja auch gesagt, das braunige Socks im Bundestag und so. Also auch in solchen Dingen ist Sonneke stabil. Also in der Zusammenarbeit ist es super. Da hat die Mannschaft von einem Abstiegskandidaten zu einem Aufstiegskandidaten entwickelt innerhalb eines Jahres. Knapp, also von dem her. Läuft sehr, sehr viel, ist sehr, sehr gut in Fürth. Aber ich glaube am Ende nicht, dass das für ganz oben reicht. Aber ich lasse mich gerne eines Besseren belehren und gehe dann wieder jede Woche in acht Bundesliga-Podcasts.
Also die ersten fünf Spiele der Rückrunde, ich sage, ich will es nur gesagt haben, die nur gegen Teams, die auf Rang 8 oder besser stehen, also um die direkten Konkurrenten. Paderborn aktuell sechster, Heustern Kiel aktuell erster, St. Pauli aktuell zweiter, Hertha BSC aktuell siebter, Hannover 96 Achtung, wenn man dann denkt, jetzt haben wir es ja rumgebracht, ach ja, dann kommt ja noch das Derby gegen den Club, vielleicht auch nicht ganz so unwichtig in Fürth. Also ich sage mal so, nach dem 23. Spieltag, schauen wir einfach noch mal drauf, Michi, und dann gibt es eine Neubewertung eventuell.
Ich würde mal sagen, entweder ist man dann halt einfach Zweiter wahrscheinlich oder man ist Achtter. Und dann kann man auch sagen, man kann für ein weiteres Jahr Zweite Liga planen, was ja auch etwas Gutes hätte, weil ich habe nur einen Wunsch vor der Saison geäußert, dass es nicht wieder bis zum 33. Spieltag auf dem Weg nach Hamburg spannend ist und man in der Konferenz damit anschauen muss, dass man doch nicht absteigen wird. Weil das war fürs Arbeiten auch nicht angenehm. Aber ich glaube, dieser Wunsch eines Nicht-Abstiegs wird sich erfüllen mit schon 29 Punkten jetzt, wenn wir vorhin auch über die Performance der Mannschaften unten im Keller gesprochen haben.
Aber wirklich. Also mit Abstieg haben wir jetzt gar nichts mehr am Hut. Dafür geht es jetzt ums Aufstiegsrennen. Zeit wird es ja auch dafür. Wir wollen auf Fortuna Düsseldorf blicken. Tabellenplatz 4, 30 Punkte, 9 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 5 Niederlagen, 37 erzielte Tore. Das heißt, wir sprechen hier über die beste Offensive der Liga bei 21 kassierten Toren, was jetzt auch kein so schlechter Wert bei den Gegentoren ist für die Fortuna. Wir haben in der letzten Ligatour schon über Fortuna gesprochen. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht ganz tief ins Detail gehen. Aber Eva, was würdest du denn so für ein Zwischenfazit ziehen für die Saison von Düsseldorf bisher?
Ja, ich ziehe da anscheinend ganz, ganz anderes Zwischenfazit als ein lieber User im Rasenfunk-Forum. Ich muss sagen, ich war ein bisschen erschrocken. Also das war –also in Ost-Westfalen würde man sagen, Hut ab für den Optimismus oder den mangelnden Optimismus. Ich würde per se erstmal sagen, okay, das ist ein sehr hartes Fazit. Also weil generell muss man einfach sagen, Düsseldorf ist das drittbeste Team im Jahr 2023. In der 2. Liga nach St. Pauli und dem HSV. Man hat die meisten Tore geschossen, 74 in einem Jahr. Das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Und eben halt mit 62 Punkten und 18 Siegen aus diesem Jahr rauszugehen, ist glaube ich schon ganz okay, wie man dann hier auch sagen würde. Ich glaube, was jetzt –um auf die Kritik zurückzukommen, jetzt so ein bisschen auf Fortuna zu gucken als neutrale Zuschauerin, macht viel Spaß, sehr unterhaltsame Spiele dabei. Kann man glaube ich immer wieder ein bisschen was mitnehmen. Zuletzt natürlich die beiden Spiele gegen den FCM im Pokal. Darüber habt ihr in der Ligatour auch geredet. Ich wusste natürlich vorher schon, dass das Spiel 3 zu 2 für Fortuna Düsseldorf ausgeht. Ich habe es nämlich getippt. Ich glaube, es war eine einzige Vier-Punkte-Partie in dieser kompletten Hinrunde. Ich fand schon klar, welche Parallelen es da gab zu den Pokalspielen. Wir haben über die Halbzeiten des FCM gesprochen. Wir können auch gerne über die Halbzeiten von Fortuna Düsseldorf reden. Das waren in der ersten Halbzeit genauso wenig wie auch im Pokalspiel, nämlich geradezu nichts.
In der Tabelle der ersten Hälfte auf Rang 12 Düsseldorf.
Obwohl ich es ganz interessant fand, ich dachte nämlich, das sieht man dann auch sehr deutlich bei den geschossenen Toren. Und die Bilanz ist, ich würde fast noch sagen, relativ ausgeglichen. Man hat 15 Tore in der ersten Halbzeit geschossen und 22 in der zweiten, was dann die 37 ergibt. Klar, sieben Tore Unterschied ist immer noch eine Menge, aber ich dachte, dass man es tatsächlich doch noch deutlicher sieht. Aber ja, ich fand schon wirklich bemerkenswert, welche Parallelen man da gefunden hat. Also ich kann dann auch immer diskutieren, ob das mit Magdeburgs Fehlern in der zweiten Halbzeit zu tun hatte oder mit Fortuna de Sedors umdenken. Also ich habe da auch beim Gebrammel Rot-Weiß mal reingehört. Liebe Grüße an der Stelle zu dem Spiel. Die Halbzeitansprache muss gut gewesen sein. Wäre halt mal die Frage, ob man die Halbzeitansprache mal vor das Spiel verlegen könnte, damit es von Anfang an eine gute Partie wird. Generell war ja vor der Saison, glaube ich, auch das hier wurde schon diskutiert, ein bisschen wie ersetzt man Krofnatski. Wie gesagt, beste Offensive der Liga, könnte man jetzt sagen, ist ganz gut geglückt. Wie gesagt, ich erinnere gerne an das Fortuna für alle Spiele, war sehr wild, auch das Spiel gegen Schalke. Also es sind glaube ich verhältnismäßig ein bisschen zu viele Niederlagen dabei mit fünf. Also es ist natürlich immer noch nicht viel, aber wenn man einfach mal so ein bisschen guckt, klar St. Pauli führt das an mit keiner einzigen Niederlage in der Hunde runter, aber trotzdem sind verhältnismäßig relativ viele Niederlagen, wenn man da oben mithalten will, aber man spielt halt einfach nicht so wahnsinnig oft unentschieden, sondern holt glaube ich noch relativ viele Siege raus. Aber ja, die große Frage ist eben offensiv, wer kommt hinter Verme? Das wurde eben auch im Forum gesprochen und das ist so ein bisschen dünn generell. Die Offensive von der Fortuna finde ich mit einem Verme, mit Ginczek unter anderem, schon ein bisschen älter, könnte man vorsichtig formulieren. Aber ja, sie haben definitiv sehr interessante Spieler auch dabei. Also Schinterapel kam ja sowieso immer, aber Tanaka wird ja auch ein bisschen diskutiert, ob der eventuell zum VfB wechselt. Alles, was in der 2. Liga ein bisschen besser spielt, wird gefragt, ob es zum VfB Stuttgart wechselt. Habe ich so das Gefühl, auch wild. Aber ja, generell, ich finde Düsseldorf, wenn es da mal gut läuft, hat man so das Gefühl, die Fans glauben, sie beraten nicht. Und dann sehen sie, Leute, läuft gar nicht so gut. Und dann denkt man so, ja, wir sind immer noch Platz 4, 30 Punkte. Gut, man muss natürlich ehrlich gesagt sagen, hätte man das Spiel gegen Magdeburg verloren, dann wäre es die zweite Niederlage in Folge gewesen. Und so, wie sich die Liga dann auch an diesen letzten beiden Spieltagen entwickelt hat, hätte das nochmal eindeutig was anderes heißen können, als es jetzt am Ende eben mit diesem Sieg heißt. Ja, also ich glaube, mein größtes Thema wäre gar nicht unbedingt, was passiert in der FMA, sondern was ist mit der Rechtsverteidiger-Position. Da wurde eben auch gewechselt gegen Magdeburg, glaube ich, zur Pause, weil da eben nicht so die Leistungen erbracht worden sind, sage ich mal so. Ich glaube, das könnte dann tatsächlich noch so ein Thema werden, was passiert da, auch gerade weil Tim Overdorf irgendwie gefühlt alles in der Innenverteidigung oder auf dem Feld spielen muss, aber vor allem in der Verteidigung, außer Torhüter, so wird es auch in den Fogen geschrieben. Also das ist, glaube ich, ja, flexibel Spieler gut, wie gesagt, ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, da ist, glaube ich, Holstein Kiel wirklich so die absolute Masterclass, wenn es darum geht. Aber die Frage ist, muss denn, also muss ein Spieler wirklich acht defensive Rollen einnehmen können oder ist das was, wo man im Winter nachlegen kann? Aber generell kann man, glaube ich, sagen, Düsseldorf ist immer so das Paradebeispiel für Ausgeglichenheit, Heim- und Auswärtsbilanz ist relativ ausgeglichen, wie gesagt, per se auch Tore in der ersten und zweiten Halbzeit, obwohl man da ja definitiv, also es geht, es muss darum gehen, diese erste Halbzeit so ein bisschen zu forcieren, wie man so schön sagt, also da einfach ein bisschen wacher zu sein von Anfang an. Und ich glaube gerade, ja, Kiel und Magdeburg haben schon durchaus aufgezeigt, wo es da Lücken gibt. Kiel ist einfach eine Mannschaft, wo es extrem schwierig ist, zurückzukommen. Magdeburg macht da vielleicht defensiv ein paar mehr Fehler. Das hat mich in ihr auch betont, dass es ja vielleicht so ein bisschen die Downside ist von dem Fußball, den Magdeburg spielt. Aber generell, ja, ist glaube ich das Problem bei Fortuna Düsseldorf, dass schon viele wissen, ja, wenn nicht dieses Jahr, wann dann? Also da hatte man jetzt so zweimal hintereinander die Saison, so das Gefühl, ja, jetzt muss aber, und ich glaube, das ist das, was eben wichtig sein wird. Also kann man es diesmal vielleicht schaffen, da ein bisschen vorbeizudrängen. Letztes Jahr gab es mit Darmstadt einen Verein, den man da irgendwie nicht so ganz vermutet hatte. Vielleicht auch Heidenheim, die da so ein bisschen Dark Horse waren und wo man es dann als Fortuna Düsseldorf eben verpasst hat. Und jetzt ist es eben Holstein Kiel, die man da vielleicht so nicht erwartet hat. Bei St. Pauli und HSV würde ich schon sagen, dass man die da so aufgrund der, einfach St. Pauli aufgrund der Rückrunde, HSV sowieso verorten konnte. Aber ich glaube, das ist eben so ein bisschen bei der Erwartungshaltung das Problem. Also dass man eben sagt, ja, nee, wir müssen es eigentlich schon dieses Jahr schaffen, weil gut, wir wissen natürlich noch nicht, wer dieses Jahr als Absteiger aus der Bundesliga runterkommt. Aber man will halt nicht immer sagen, so ja, wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann, wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann, sondern irgendwann muss natürlich dann da auch die Leistung stehen.
In den letzten vier Jahren war man einmal fünfter und zweimal vierter. Das ist quasi dieser, wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann.
Genau, und hält am Trainer fest.
Man hält an Daniel Thun fest. Das tun nicht alle in der zweiten Liga. Und man freut sich vor allem auf Ende Januar. Denn auch für Düsseldorf ist der Start in die Rückrunde sehr interessant. Es geht los mit dem Auswärtsspiel bei Hertha BSC. Und dann hat man den Doubleheader, auf den sich Yannick schon ganz besonders freut. Nämlich erst zu Hause, also aus Sicht jetzt der Fortuna gegen St. Pauli. Und dann im DFB-Pokal-Viertelfinale, drei Tage später im Entscheidungsspiel, wer ins Halbfinale kommt. Das könnte sehr, sehr interessant werden. Und ich bin auch gespannt. Ich weiß nicht, Yannick, ob du dazu eine Meinung hast. Aber wir haben ja sehr viele Zweitligisten jetzt auch noch im DFB-Pokal. Und manchmal hat man das schon erlebt, dass diese so DFB-Pokal-Runs, wo man dann weit kommt bis ins Halbfinale oder vielleicht sogar noch weiter, dass es auch die Saison beeinflusst. Und zwar in beide Richtungen. Manchmal gibt das Mannschaften Pust, manchmal hat man das Gefühl, so rund um diese DFB-Pokalspiele im Frühjahr, wo es ja dann wirklich um Finale und so weiter geht, gerät man ein bisschen ins Wanken. Hat ja auch St. Pauli schon seine eigenen Erfahrungen mitgemacht. Bin gespannt, ob das einen Einfluss haben wird auf diese Zweitligasaison, so wie der DFB-Pokal gerade läuft.
Also vor allem bin ich gespannt, wenn wir dann erst mal bei Düsseldorf in der Liga zu Gast sind, wird das ja auch eins von den ausgewählten Testläufen von Fortuna für alle sein. Bin mal gespannt, wie das so ist und wie das läuft. Ich kann mir dann jetzt irgendwann Ende des Monats ein Gratisticket als Auswärtsdauerkarteninhaber klicken und fahre quasi gratis oder gehe gratis ins Stadion. Und ja, Pokal –also ich bin in das Viertelfinale reingegangen. Ich wollte auf jeden Fall ein Heimspiel haben, weil es unter der Woche ist. Und das ist einfach manchmal nicht zu managen, sonst wo hinzufahren. Ich musste schon auf Hamburg verzichten, weil das ja auch unter der Woche war. Und ja, dann muss man sehen, ob das dann –also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, habe ich, glaube ich, irgendwann vor kurzem auch schon mal entweder im eigenen Format oder irgendwo zu Gast gesagt, wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, würde ich den Aufstieg nehmen. Aber ja, so ein Halbfinale oder Pokalfinale. Und je nachdem, wie dann die Konstellation ist –Das ist auch Europa, ne? Ich wollte gerade sagen, je nachdem, wie die Konstellation sonst so in der ersten Liga sich gestaltet oder wer dann da im Finale auf uns warten sollte, kann das ja noch ganz andere Sphären annehmen. Aber ja, also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, würde ich die Liga nehmen, aber alles andere ist gern genommener Bonus.
Das sind Luxussituationen.
Auf jeden Fall muss Düsseldorf bis Februar viele Punkte geholt haben. Das letzte Mal 2.000 gewonnen in der Regionalliga West-Südwest.
Entschuldige, dass ich diese Statistik normalerweise… Wir haben zwei Dienstmannschaften in der Liga.
Sanofa 619 und Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Warum hast du das denn nicht gemerkt, Max? Das habe ich mir selbst von der letzten Ligatour gemerkt. Schämlich, dass du bei allen Formaten sowas einfach nicht merken kannst.
Yannick hat auch gerade gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das irgendwo bei mir gesagt habe oder in einem anderen Format. Vielleicht habe ich es einem Taxifahrer erzählt. Das ist das Problem von uns Menschen, die sehr viel reden. Das ist einfach, was weiß denn ich und ich höre auch sehr viel zu.
Mein Geschwätz von vorgestern.
Ja, vor allem dein Geschwätz von vorgestern. Was weiß ich ja nicht, was du dann gesagt hast. Mich interessiert ausschließlich, was du uns jetzt zum HSV erzählst. Denn Kevin, ich muss sagen, du bist ein Held. Den HSV zu besprechen, es ist nicht einfach.
Ja, das ist doch jetzt total einfach. Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich nur noch ein Thema. Walter bleibt Trainer. Also reicht doch als Zusammenfassung den Runde, oder nicht?
Nein, nein.
So kann ich dich leider nicht davon kürzen.
Also erst machen wir erst den kurzen Statistikblock. Der HSV ist zur Überraschung aller Dritter aktuell in der Tabelle. 31 Punkte, 9 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 4 Niederlagen, 33 Tore geschossen, 22 Tore kassiert. Und in seiner ganzen HSVigkeit hat man wieder eine Achterbahn durchlebt, die allerdings immer auf den oberen Etagen fährt. Also der HSV ist ja nicht kein Schalke 04, das irgendwie tief abstürzt oder so, sondern der HSV ist halt der HSV und ist aber in eine solche sportliche Krise reingeraten, dass eben diese Frage jetzt im Raum stand, würde Tim Walther jetzt bleiben können. Also im DFB-Pokal ausgeschieden, gegen Paderborn verloren. Wir haben es vorhin schon thematisiert. Aber immerhin das letzte Spiel in Nürnberg jetzt gewonnen. Wobei, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, so ganz souverän war das wohl nicht. Unter anderem deshalb gab es jetzt ja die Diskussion rund um Tim Walther. Aber Tim Walther bleibt. Wie blickst du auf diese Entscheidung?
Also grundsätzlich befürworte ich sowas sehr, weil ich –Eva hat es ja vorhin auch kritisiert gehabt –dass man immer dieses Rondell in der 2. Liga sehr schnell rotieren lässt. Und dann kommt wieder irgendwer, der mit Verlaub –gut, in der Winterpause könnte es vielleicht noch gelingen –sich mit einer Mannschaft dann zu warm zu werden und mit der in der Rückrunde ein besseres Ergebnis zu erzielen als nur 31 Punkte. Was ja eine Katastrophe ist beim HSV. Womit wir, glaube ich, auch bei dem sportlichen Thema sind, ist halt einfach diese Erwartungshaltung, die immer noch da ist. Die große Sehnsucht nach der Bundesliga, die man mit auch ein bisschen mitschwingt und meiner Ansicht nach einen sehr enormen Druck auf dieses Team auch immer ausübt. Ich fand es beachtlich zum Beispiel, dass ich jetzt dann der Kapitän, also Bastian Schonlau, auch hingestellt hatte und quasi Werbung für den Trainer gemacht hatte. Also was ja auch ein großer Pluspunkt gewesen sein wohl, dass die Kabine intakt ist, wie man so schön sagt. Früher hätte man gesagt, die Mannschaft steht hinter dem Trainer oder folgt ihm.
Er hat die Kabine nicht verloren, er hat sie gewonnen.
Und das, obwohl alle, die nicht HSV-Fan sind, diesen Trainer glaube ich nicht so gerne mögen von seinem Auftreten, von seiner Art her. Ich stehe ja auf solche Typen, deswegen mochte ich auch Steffen Baumgart. Ein schräger Vergleich, nein.
Ich verkratze gerade Tim Walther und Steffen Baumgart in einen Topf geschmissen. Natürlich nicht.
Aber es sind halt beides Typen, die ihre Meinung sagen. Das würde ich damit sagen, die halt Typen sind. Ob man sie jetzt mag, ob man sie für arrogant hält oder vielleicht auch abfällig gegenüber Journalisten, was ja auch durchaus bei ihm mal durchklingen könnte, wenn man so seine Antworten sieht, kann man auch wieder einfach werten, dass er nicht um den heißen Brei redet, sondern dass er straight ist. Und sich auch mit so manch einer komischen Frage eher nicht länger beschäftigen möchte. Aber ja, ich kann da durchaus auch verstehen, dass man ihn als jemanden sieht, der arrogant wirkt, der aber bei der Mannschaft offen mal ganz gut ankommt. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Formschwankungen daran liegen, dass –deswegen wurde es ja auch gesagt, dass die Mannschaft hinter dem Trainer steht –dass er irgendeine komische Art hätte. Sondern im Gegenteil, ich glaube, das schätzen Spiele auch, wenn sie jemanden haben, der ganz klar auch deutlich macht, wer quasi Chef im Ring ist und wer die Mannschaft aufstellt. Dem sind dann aber Folgen, wenn er halt auch inhaltlich gut mit der Mannschaft interagiert. Deswegen muss er nicht mit uns inhaltlich gut sprechen oder mit fragenden Journalisten, sondern das muss er mit der Mannschaft im Endeffekt tun. Was mich halt immer wieder wundert ist, wieso man jetzt noch –wie viele Jahre ist der Hass vor jetzt in der zweiten Liga? Sieben? Ist das die siebte Saison? Sechs. Siehst du, ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, so lange sind die schon da. Sie kratzen ja immer lange Zeit dran und dann kommt immer so eine vermeintliche Delle, die ich immer gar nicht als eine solche empfinde, die aber im Umfeld dann immer so unfassbar aufgebaut wird, dass auf einmal Krisenstimmung da ist. Ich meine, Yannick würde es am besten live vor Ort miterleben, quasi, beim Stadtrivalen. Da kannst du vielleicht auch besser noch was zu sagen zum Umfeld, zu der Stimmung, die auch durch Mopo und Kodern sehr gern befeuert werden. Ich sehe sportlich, habe ich eigentlich eine Mannschaft inzwischen da gesehen, die jung aufgestellt ist, wo natürlich auch ein paar Spieler dabei sind, die schon ein bisschen länger dabei sind, die dann auch die –wie nennt man die –Leader sind, die in der Kabine wichtig sind. Und auch als ein Verein, der inzwischen gelernt hat, nicht mehr Schleudersitze zu verteilen, sondern –also man könnte ja auch zum Beispiel den Herrn Boldt schon mal entlassen haben, nachdem das dann jetzt nicht funktioniert hat die letzten Jahre. Jetzt wird ja auch geschrieben, indem er sich mit oder für Walter oder zu ihm bekennt, dass das dann auch sein letzter Zug ist, der da jetzt abfährt gerade. Diese Kommentierung finde ich immer schwierig und finde ich auch sehr schade, weil ich finde eigentlich ist das ein beachtliches Zeichen, weil irgendwo muss ja die Kritik an Tim Walter herkommen in der höheren Vereinsetage, dass das überhaupt diskutiert wird. Und dann auch noch in die Öffentlichkeit drängt. Die haben 31 Punkte geholt, haben jetzt das letzte Spiel in Nürnberg gewonnen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie –klar, Sie haben davor gegen Paderborn in der Liga verloren. Das hätten sie aber auch genauso gut gewinnen können. Das Spiel, das war offenes Visier, wo wir einfach kalt-schneuzeiger waren, wo der HSV reihenweise Chancen vergeben hat. Deswegen weiß ich nicht. Ich sehe da nicht die große Krise immer. Ich verstehe nicht, wieso das dann doch wieder öffentlich gemacht wird. Und dann wird sich doch für ihn entschieden, für den Trainer. Das finde ich immer ein bisschen schwierig. Aber das ist halt so dieses in Anführungsstrichen typische HSV-Ding. Von außen oft belächelt wird. Irgendwann stellen sie sich selber das Beinchen und steigen halt deswegen dann nicht auf.
Wenn ich aber kurz ergänzen darf. Generell bin ich auch eher ein Fan von am Trainer festzuhalten. Also wir hatten das ja gefühlt in dieser Saison so oft wie noch nie, dass darüber nochmal so eine moralische Lanze drüber gebrochen wurde. Also wenn man jetzt über uns Fischer gesprochen hat, über Steffen Baumgart oder eben auch über Tim Walther, dass immer mehr dieses, ja nee, dann geht er von alleine, weil es ist voll schwierig, ihn irgendwie rauszuschmeißen, weil er ein gewisses Standing hat. Ich glaube, das Problem ist eben, der Erfolg bleibt ja eben aus. Weil man muss ja sagen, der HSV ist ja eben nicht, weiß ich nicht, Heidenheim oder Kiel und Co., wo gesagt wird, naja, dann spielen sie mal eben oben mit. Sondern man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, der HSV tätigt ja auch die Transfers, um da oben mitzuspielen. Und dann muss man einfach sagen, ganz ehrlich würden wir darüber sprechen, dass der HSV in den letzten vier Jahren mal Platz 7, mal Platz 8, dann mal vielleicht Platz 4 und 3 gehabt hätte. Dass wir dann sagen, okay, dann ist man unglücklich gescheitert. Aber man muss ja ganz ehrlich sagen, sie sind ja immer knapp dran gewesen. Sie haben zweimal Relegation gespielt. Und sie sind, also ja klar, ich kann das auch aus HSV-Sicht wirklich gut verstehen, wenn man irgendwann die Schnauze voll hat von diesen Witzen. Und es ist ja schon wieder Frühling und was auch immer. Aber man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn sich ein Tim Walther da letztes Jahr hinstellt und sagt, ja alle, die jetzt über uns spaßen und lachen, die wissen nicht, dass wir nächstes Jahr Bundesliga spielen. Das ist halt eine Aussage, an der muss man gemessen werden. Und ich persönlich gehöre zu den Leuten, die Tim Walther weniger abgewinnen können, das gebe ich auch gerne zu. Aber ich finde, das große Problem ist, dass inzwischen ich das Gefühl habe, es wird immer mehr als trotz Reaktion auf etwas reagiert, als das wirklich auf sich selber geguckt wird. Und ich habe Jonas Boldt hier persönlich beim Pokalspiel gegen Bielefeld erlebt, dass sie mit sehr, sehr viel Glück gewonnen haben. Und der erste Kommentar, den Jonas Boldt von sich gegeben hat, war, ja, also man hätte ja mindestens zwei Klassenunterschied hier gesehen. Der HSV wäre so viel besser gewesen, was ich sehr mutig finde, wenn man sich mit 1-1 ins Elfmeterschießen gerettet hat. Und der gegnerische Verein sehr, sehr lange ein Zurich geführt hat. Also das ist für mich halt, ja, klar kann man von außen sagen, ja, warum gibt es denn immer diese Kritik? Und man hält auch fest, und das ist doch ein gutes Zeichen. Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, es sind halt nicht immer nur die anderen Schuld, sondern man bringt sich mit eigenen Aussagen ja immer wieder dahin. Und das ist für mich dieses, ja, da muss man halt am Ende kritisieren, weil ganz ehrlich, wir machen ja die Witze ja, am Ende reicht es wieder nur für Platz drei und vier, weil man in den letzten Jahren einfach sagt, ganz ehrlich, wäre es jetzt noch so eine Sensation, wenn sie aufsteigen, weil ehrlich gesagt…
Eigentlich wird die Sensation ja größer. Das ist ja das Interessante. Eigentlich mit jedem Jahr, der Kader wird ja von Jahr zu Jahr schlechter. Und das, was du gesagt hast, mit den Transfers, die man getätigt hat, deswegen müsse man ja eigentlich fast aufsteigen. Ich würde die These in den Raum stellen, in dieser Saison stimmt das zum ersten Mal nicht, weil man hat nicht groß investiert. Man hat natürlich interessante Spieler geholt, aber man ist eben nicht mehr in das große Minus dafür gegangen. Das heißt, eigentlich ist ein dritter Platz jetzt höher zu bewerten als ein dritter Platz oder ein vierter Platz in den Vorsaisons. Sie sind jetzt im sechsten Zweitliga, ja. Aber es ist halt schwierig, diese Anpassung hinzubekommen im Umfeld, auch im eigenen Blick auf den HSV. Und vielleicht auch fällt es den Verantwortlichen selber manchmal schwer, das zu transportieren.
Genau das sehe ich halt auch so. Eva hat aber Recht, was diese Aussagen dann angeht. Die fallen einem natürlich auf die Füße, wenn es dann nicht folgt. Das ist natürlich bei Tim Walther letztlich auch manchmal im Jetzorn, wenn ich es jetzt mal zu Dingen hinreißen, die er vielleicht einen Tag später so nicht mehr sagen wird. Das weiß ich nicht. Die Aussage war ziemlich dämlich. Das weiß er glaube ich auch inzwischen selber, dass man nächste Saison –dem ging das glaube ich einfach auf die Nerven, genau diese Helme, die da immer über den HSV hereinbricht. Sportlich gesehen bin ich da bei dir, Max. Vom Etat, vom Budget her wird es immer schmaler, muss es ja auch logischerweise. Wir haben vorhin von dieser 5-Jahres-Wertung gehört, die kann ja jetzt nun nicht mehr so gewinnbringend sein, wie sie halt vorher war oder gewesen wäre. Und dann hat man, finde ich, in den letzten Jahren auch immer wieder, das haben andere Mannschaften sicherlich auch, auch zentrale Schlüsselspieler, die dann lange verletzt ausgefallen sind, in dieser Saison zum Beispiel ein Kapitän schon, der glaube ich vier Spiele auf dem Papier gerade hat. Und davon glaube ich auch nicht alle über die volle Zeit. Ich weiß nicht genau, der sich jetzt schon wieder verletzt hat und wieder an der Wade hinten. Und weswegen man jetzt überlegt, personell da nochmal nachzulegen, über den der Trainer quasi gesagt hat, das muss ich jetzt einmal ablesen, ein knappes halbes Jahr ohne den Mann, der unser Spiel ausmacht. Das war nicht so einfach, denn gerade im Spiel mit dem Ball sind wir mit ihm der HSV, der wir sein wollen. Sein Positions- und Aufbauspiel ist das, was wir brauchen. Das heißt, es wird ja ganz klar, auch wenn das ein Innenverteidiger ist, dass das der Schlüsselspieler ist, der da dem HSV wegbricht. Und ich meine mich, ohne es jetzt wirklich beweisen zu können oder zu belegen zu können, hätte ich mir vielleicht mehr Mühe geben müssen in der Vorbereitung, dass das in den letzten Saison auch immer wieder so war beim HSV, dass immer wieder Schlüsselspieler lange ausgefallen sind. Yannick meldet sich schon und kann das jetzt bestätigen oder nicht.
Nein, mach erst mal weiter. Das ist noch zu dem, was du eben gesagt hast.
In den Schlüsselspielen fehlen dir solche Spiele oder sie können fehlen.
Ganz kurz dazu, der HSV hat ja die gleichen Verletzungs-Säulen diese Saison auch wieder. Und hat, wie ich finde, da tatsächlich transfertechnisch schon Fehler gemacht. Weil die defensive Valet-Saison immer wieder ein Problem. Wo man durch den eher, ich sage in dem Fall, unfreiwilligen Wegfall, auch von Vuskovic und Schonlau, ein ganz großes Problem hatte mit der zweiten Reihe defensiv. Und dann fand ich halt, hat man dieses Jahr gesagt, okay, wir müssen da nachrüsten, gute Idee. Was ich halt finde, klar gucke ich jetzt wieder auch mit der Bielefeld-Brille drauf, aber da hat man unter anderem Guy Ramosch verpflichtet, der bestimmt seine guten Momente hat. Aber, und das hat er auch beim HSV gezeigt, eben immer wieder defensiver Aussetzer hat. Und der dann, der Verwurf von Anfang an, auch so wie Tim Walters formuliert hat, klar ist, der ist eher so die Nummer 3, 4, 5. Und das ist halt, wenn man mit Schonlau immer wieder Verletzungsprobleme hatte. Und das ist ein supergutes Spieler, das ist superwichtig für den HSV. Aber dann muss ich halt ehrlich gesagt in die Reihe jemanden verpflichten, den das dann auch gut ersetzen kann. Und das, ja klar, vielleicht hat man nicht mehr das Geld, aber ob das dann so der richtige Weg ist, jemanden zu verpflichten, der eben diesen Weg, also diese Position, laut Trainer selber zum Teil überhaupt nicht gut erfüllt, das finde ich merkwürdig.
Ja, klar. Also die zweite Reihe ist offenbar, wobei sie in anderen Vereinen nicht stündend besetzt wäre. Also ich weiß nicht, Muayyam hat glaube ich 15 Spiele gemacht. Und glaube ich auch nicht so schlecht. Zumindest im Kicker die zweitbesten Notenschnitt außer der Defensive. Ambrosius haben sie glaube ich noch. Also sie haben ja schon ein paar Leute, aber ich bin bei dir. Es sind so die Spitzen, die dann da fehlen wahrscheinlich, die den Game-Changer oder den Unterschied machen. Und eben auch durch dieses wechselnde Personal. Du hast einen Jatta seit Jahren. Ich darf bei dem keine Altersdiskussion anfangen. Hast du dabei? Es fehlen schon so ein bisschen die Game-Changer irgendwo. Aber das halt auch immer auf allerhöchstem Niveau. Mit dem Ziel, dass man aufsteigen will und sich als Erstligist wieder sieht.
Mein Hottag wäre ja, dass dem HSV tatsächlich mal eine Saison als Achter guttun würde. Also einfach mal wirklich als Achter.
Ist das nicht die Zweitliga-Version von ein Abstieg würde ihm mal ganz guttun?
Naja, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube alleine, mir tun die Fans tatsächlich auch wirklich leid. Weil ich weiß, wie es ist, dass man nie eine Saison mal in Ruhe sagen kann. Okay, komm, wir wissen jetzt am 30. Spieltag, es geht einfach um nichts mehr. Wir können jetzt wirklich einfach mal genau sagen, in acht Wochen gehen wir in der und der Liga an den Start oder zwölf oder was auch immer. Und ich glaube tatsächlich mal, dass es einmal, wenn es dieses Jahr nicht klappen sollte, dass man einmal tatsächlich eine Saison braucht, wo man sagt, okay, und jetzt läuft es einfach mal auf gut Deutsch gesagt, richtig mittelmäßig scheiße.
Ich glaube, es kommt halt auch dazu, dass es in der zweiten Liga unfassbar schwer ist. Und das klingt jetzt so nach einem Phrasendrescher-Ding, aber unheimlich schwer ist, konstant über eine ganze Saison da oben Attacke zu gehen. Mal gucken, ich bin gespannt beim FC St. Pauli. Das ist ja nicht die erste Halbserie, die die so stark spielen. Letzte Saison war es ja die Rückserie, die ja überragend war. Also das ist halt wirklich –das haben wir vorhin bei anderen Teams auch schon gehabt –es ist halt einfach schwer, diese Konstanz. Ich glaube, Michi Duart hat das gesagt. Man muss in der zweiten Liga keine Ausreißer von den Ergebnissen her haben, aber man muss halt konstant irgendwie auch schmutzige Spiele gewinnen. Und ja, da ist natürlich ein HSV ausgelegt, auch ein bisschen Spektakel, gerade vor dem Heimpublikum, die wollen was sehen. Ist immer so ein Zwiespalt, so ein Spagat, der schwierig ist. Aber wie gesagt, sowieso auf hohem Niveau beim HSV.
Aber zu Hause gelingt es im HSV natürlich auch. Das sind auch gar nicht immer Spektakel-Spiele, aber sie sind erst in der Heimtabelle. Bitte?
Außer gegen Paderborn.
Aber sie sind trotzdem noch erste in der Heimtabelle. Das Problem sind dann eher die Auswärtsspiele beim HSV. Das sind dann eben diese tristen Zweitligaspiele, dass man dann einfach auswärts auch mal gewinnen muss, wo man sich eigentlich als Verein gar nicht sieht. Und das hat man trotzdem nicht geschafft.
Nein, tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass man gegen sämtliche Aufsteiger nicht gewinnen konnte. Ganz im Gegenteil. Man hat ja teilweise auch sogar verloren. Ich hätte noch ein paar Two Cents aus –Sie nennen uns ja, oder Tanja vom HSV Podcast nennen uns ja immer liebevoll den Stadtteilverein. Ich wollte noch einmal zu dem, was ihr gesagt habt, naja, oder du Max hast gesagt, die Mannschaft ist immer schlechter geworden. Man hat aber trotzdem laut einer einstiegenden Seite immer noch den höchsten Gesamtmarktwert. Noch vorher der BSC, dann kommt lange, lange nichts. Und dann kommt erst mal Düsseldorf und Schalke 04. Und es ist ja nun auch so, dass jetzt im sechsten Jahr ist man jetzt dabei. Die Konkurrenz war sicherlich schon mal härter. Also ein FC Köln war schon mal dabei, ein VfB Stuttgart war dabei. Da war sicherlich vielleicht Platz 1 zumindest schon mal nominell fest vergeben. Das ist jetzt dieses Jahr anders. Ja, ich glaube, zu meiner Meinung über Tim Walter muss ich nicht groß sein. Es gibt einen Sticker in der Fanszene, der mit Verlaub, Herr Walter, aber unsympathisch ist. Von daher sind da die Sympathien und unsere Antipathien klar verteilt. Ich wollte noch einmal, weil es auch den FC St. Pauli in der Saison schon betroffen hat, wir hatten es ja jetzt schon öfter bei verschiedenen Vereinen mit der ominösen ersten bzw. zweiten Hälfte. Da ist es nämlich genau umgekehrt zu Hertha BSC, von dem wir es eben hatten. Der HSV würde nur die erste Hälfte zählen, wäre man 14. Also mit dem Abstiegskampf und was die zweite Hälfte angeht, ist man auf Platz 2. Das durfte ja auch ein gewisser FC St. Pauli leidvoll erfahren, als man im Derby am Bellantor 2-0 geführt hat und dann noch 2 zu 2 unentschieden spielte, was sich auch ein bisschen wie eine Niederlage anfühlte. Aber gut, das nur meine… Achso, und ich nehme tatsächlich im Vergleich zu vorigen Jahren nicht so viel Unruhe wahr, wie es schon mal war. Und ich glaube, hätte man jetzt gegen Nürnberg verloren, wäre es schwierig geworden für Walter und, wie du gesagt hast, Kevin, auch für Jonas Boldt in Kombination sozusagen. Weil, wann, wenn nicht vor der Winterpause hätte man diesen Schritt gehen sollen, müssen, können. Nun hat man sich dafür entschieden, mit ihm weiterzumachen. Damit ist ja klar, dass der HSV am Ende der Saison dritter wird.
Ja, genau. Wobei man da eben schon sagen muss, also es ist auch total interessant, dass wir jetzt beim HSV, hätte ich drauf gewettet, dass wir hier nochmal zu spätester Stunde, wir haben jetzt halb eins Uhr nachts und wir haben noch zwei Teams vor uns, aber dass wir da wieder ins Diskutieren kommen, das hätte ich gewettet. Weil das ist nämlich der HSV. Und ich finde, das macht es auf der einen Seite schwer, über den HSV zu sprechen, weil der HSV dadurch, dass er eben eine höhere Aufmerksamkeit bekommt und halt auch bemerkenswerte Geschichten geschrieben hat in den letzten Jahren, das hat einfach jeder mitbekommen, deswegen hat jeder eine Meinung dazu. Wir haben jetzt schon über so viele Trainer hier gesprochen, also mach eine Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen-Befragung und sag ja, wie stehst du jetzt zu XY? Du kriegst zu 80 Prozent die Rückmeldung, keine Ahnung. Bei Tim Walter wirst du wahrscheinlich ein Ergebnis von 100 Prozent, die eine Meinung haben, zurückbekommen. Und das macht es gleichzeitig auch manchmal, finde ich, schwer, über den HSV zu sprechen, weil ja, man redet auch über Sportliches, und das Sportliche spielt ja auch eine Rolle. Und da kann man Tim Walter definitiv kritisieren, und da ist nicht alles gut und so weiter und so fort. Und gleichzeitig wird aber auch ganz viel immer über Nichtsportliches gesprochen beim HSV. Wir haben jetzt auch schon viel über Dinge gesprochen, die nicht sportlich sind. Ob das Mobbing? Nein, das ist einfach so funktioniert. Das ist so eine Unterhaltungsindustrie. Aber ich möchte nur einmal kurz darauf hinweisen, ich verstehe, dass das HSV-Fans das zu viel ist. Und es ist dramatisch gewesen, wie man in den letzten Jahren nicht aufgestiegen ist. Aber ich möchte kurz darauf hinweisen, dass wir jetzt fast 4 Stunden aufnehmen. Und jetzt erst sprechen wir über den HSV. Also es ist nicht nur Jammern auf hohem Niveau, sondern ich würde auch sagen, ich weiß, dass sich das natürlich leicht sagt, als derjenige, dessen Herz nicht gebrochen wird, wenn man nicht aufsteigt. Das ist mir völlig klar. Aber dennoch, irgendwie muss man das auch umarmen und sagen, wir sind in jedem Jahr mit dabei. Und natürlich, wir kriegen die Häme kübelweise wieder über den Kopf geschüttet, wenn wir aufgrund einer Falschinformation schon des Tornets auseinanderschneiden und dann nicht aufsteigen. Aber ihr seid auch jedes Jahr mit dabei. Wir haben jetzt schon über einige Teams gesprochen, Hannover, Nürnberg und so weiter. Die wären dankbar, wenn die überhaupt mal in einem Jahr wieder mit dabei wären. Der HSV auch natürlich, weil er die Mittel und so weiter hat. Das war schon eine richtige Anmerkung von dir, Yannick. Der Kader hat natürlich noch eine besondere Qualität. Aber das ist schon auch etwas, was man nicht unerwähnt lassen sollte beim HSV.
Man hätte jetzt halt die Chance gehabt. Deswegen als Steffen Baumgart jetzt dann quasi von… Also ich hätte gedacht, das könnte der neue HSV-Trainer werden. Weil A ist Steffen Baumgart HSV-Fan. Und zweitens war der schon mal sein Paderborn, war vom HSV umgarnt worden. Aber da man das nicht gemacht hat, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass man mit Herrn Walther jetzt bis zum Saisonende mindestens gehen wird.
Ja gut, das sind natürlich Gedankenspiele. Da hast du recht, wenn man so drüber nachdenkt. Aber gut, sie haben sich anders entschieden. Der HSV hat alle Möglichkeiten. Zwei Punkte sind es aktuell. Rückstand auf einen direkten Aufstiegsplatz. Und auf dem liegt Yannick, das einzige Team dieser 2. Liga, das noch ungeschlagen ist. Der FC St. Pauli 8, Siege 9, unentschieden. Da wurden die Punkte liegen gelassen. Und dann eben keine Niederlage. Die beste Abwehr der Liga mit Abstand. 15 Gegentreffer nur. Und mit 31 Toren auch einen sehr guten Sturm. Aber dennoch hat man nicht nur die Herbstmeisterschaft liegen lassen, sondern generell jetzt im Endspurt eine Unentschieden-Serie gestartet. Aus den letzten fünf Spielen waren es vier Unentschieden in der Liga. Unter anderem das sehr emotionale 2 zu 2 gegen den HSV. Halb voll oder halb leer? Wie ist der Zustand deines Wasserglases?
Ja, aus Transparenzgründen kann man ja sagen, als du die Einladung hier zu heute Abend oder zu dieser Nachtsession ausgesprochen hast, war mir noch Tabellenführer. Da konnte man noch nicht wissen…
Als bin ich schuld oder was?
Das hast du gesagt. Nein. Was ich damit sagen will, das war ja wirklich denkbar knapp am Ende. Und dass Kiel dann nochmal so einen Lauf hinlegen würde, hat ja auch kein mitgerechnet. Und dieses Phänomen der Unentschieden ist ja auch nicht neu, wenn man die Saison des FC St. Pauli verfolgt. Man hat ja auch in den ersten Spielen zwar zum Auftakt gegen… also auf dem Betzenberg dreifach gepunktet, aber danach gab es ja auch eine Unentschieden-Serie. Weshalb man sich da erst später in die Gefilde aufschwingen konnte, in denen man jetzt zu finden ist. Und ich habe ja so, als ich meine Takes zu den anderen Vereinen in den letzten vier Stunden so, ja, habe ich ja auch immer mit St. Pauli-Content sozusagen unterfüttert von daher bleibt jetzt, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr so viel Neues zu sagen. Und wenn du natürlich, wie du hast es ja in der Leitung gesagt, wenn du das Team bist, was in diesem Kalenderjahr erst zweimal verloren hat und das auch erst in der vergangenen Spielzeit und nicht in der aktuellen, also für alle, die es noch nicht irgendwo gehört, gelesen haben, es ist nur eine Derby-Niederlage in der vergangenen Rückrunde und eine Niederlage gegen Eintracht Braunschweig, die dieses Kalenderjahr an Pflichtspielen des FC St. Pauli prägen, wenn man jetzt von der Liga spricht. Und ja, das sind sicherlich alles Dinge, die werden, die sind ja auch durch die Gazetten und durch die Medien gegangen, das werden ja die meisten Leute einfach alles schon wissen. Ich brauche das, weil er es ja auch regelmäßig betont, dass für Fabian Hürzler erst mal wichtig ist, dass hinten die Null steht. Das ist jetzt leider in dieser Saison erst fünfmal geglückt. Sonst war immer mindestens ein Gegentreffer dabei, selbst bei so Kantersiegen wie schon gegen den erwähnten ersten FC Nürnberg oder auch den jetzigen Tabellenführer Holstein-Kiel. Die hat man damals auch mit 5 zu 1 nach Hause geschickt, aber eben auch ein Gegentor gefangen bei fünf eigenen Treffern. Ja, halb voll, halb leer, wie gesagt. Du hast es angesprochen, diese neun Unentschieden tun natürlich irgendwie weh oder sind teilweise auch unnötig gewesen. Das war ja ganz am Anfang im Magdeburg-Segment, dass sich beide Seiten bis heute nicht erklären können, warum man da sich die Punkte geteilt hat. Und da gab es eben einige Spiele, die spitz auf Knopf standen oder mit einem glücklichen Treffer. Es gab ja auch zahlreiche 0 zu 0 Spiele mit einem dreckigen Treffer. Kevin hat es eben auch gesagt, dann muss man auch mal ein Spiel dreckig gewinnen. Dann stünde man jetzt in der Tabelle sicherlich anders da. Nun ist es, wie es ist. Wie gesagt, das ist ja zum Großteil alles nichts Neues. Das hatte ich ja auch jetzt in den letzten Stunden schon öfters angesprochen. Von da habe ich einfach nochmal ein paar Zahlen mitgebracht. Die sind mittlerweile vorgestern bei uns im Blog erschienen. Ich habe ein paar davon rausgegriffen. Da sind noch wesentlich mehr Zahlen zu sehen. Ich würde einfach mal damit anfangen, dass wir das laufstärkste Team der Liga sind. Mit über 2060 Kilometern allein. Ein gewisser Marcel Hartel, unser Top-Torschütze übrigens, mit acht Treffern hat davon 216 knapp abgerissen.
Ich müsste ganz kurz sagen, dass es eine absolute Simulation ist, dass Marcel Hartel mein Top-Torschütze irgendwo ist.
Und es ist die zweite Simulation, dass er im Pokalspiel auch mal 18 Kilometer gelaufen ist, oder? Mit der Verlängerung. Was ein Wert sich noch nie gehört hat in einem Fußballspiel.
Ich glaube, er hat sogar schon mal mehr als 18 Kilometer gelaufen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Was hat der für ein schlechtes Schnellungsspiel?
Da kann ich ja auf unsere aktuelle Monatssendung verweisen, wo wir Fabian Hützler auch zu Gast hatten, der dann auch noch ganz viel über seine Prinzipien, die er den Spielern an die Hand geben möchte und überhaupt seine Philosophie noch mal ausführlich spricht. Und da hat er auch gesagt, weil es eben auch auf diese Laufwerte von Marcel Hardl zu sprechen kam, dass er da jetzt auch nicht immer –also er müsste nicht so viel laufen unbedingt immer, aber er tut es halt. Und ja, so kommt das auf jeden Fall zustande. Dann hast du Max vorhin schon mal irgendwie –ich weiß gar nicht mehr in welchem Segment das war –aber die zugelassenen gegnerischen Torschüsse angesprochen. Tim hat da eine 7,19 stehen, was die beste Defensive seit Beginn der Aufzeichnung in der Saison 15, 16 ist. Ich habe es leider im Artikel nicht sehen können, wo er seine Daten her hat, aber ob es nun 7 sind oder knapp unter 9 oder an die 9 ist, ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr guter Wert. Du hast ja gesagt, nur 15 Gegentreffer in 17 Spielen untermauert das ja auch. Fun Fact, wir hatten es ja bei Wiesbaden auch schon von Standards. Man hat auch als FC St. Pauli 8 Treffer nach Standardstreffer erzielen können, davon 5 nach Ecke. Sollte man meinen oder könnte man befürchten, dass das vielleicht in der Rückrunde die Gegner auch irgendwann durchschaut haben. Da reicht es teilweise einfach, dass zum Beispiel ein Carole Metz Irvine frei blockt und dann Irvine das Tor erzielen kann. Das ist auch mehr als einmal der Fall gewesen. Dann ist auch schon die Zahl gefallen von knapp 290 Torschüssen. Das ist der Spitzenwert der Liga. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Knackpunkt. Dabei liegt aber die eigene Torwahrscheinlichkeit nur bei ungefähr 10,7 Prozent. Und da ist nur der VfL-Osternbrück schlechter, was also quasi die Ausbeute oder die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines zu erzielenden Tores nach Torschuss angeht. Aber um vielleicht mit einer positiven Zahl zu ändern, der Expected Points-Wert liegt bei 32,6. Damit ist man Ligaspitze. Danach kommen Kräuter-Virp mit 29 und der eben besprochene HSV mit 28,2. Das waren einfach so ein paar Zahlen, die die bisherige Hinrunde nach dem, was man eh schon wusste, vielleicht noch ein bisschen untermauern.
Ich würde das gerne noch ergänzen mit einer Frage, die ich jetzt weiterreiche. Ich habe heute das Sportradio 360 gehört, die aktuelle Big Show. Da war Stefan Himpel unter anderem zu Gast und der hat gesagt, es sei ein Fehler, den St. Pauli zum wiederholten Male begehe, dass man nicht früh genug mit einem Trainer den Vertrag verlängert habe. Und jetzt habe Hürzler eben schon das Interesse anderer Vereine geweckt. Und er hat auch gesagt, das habe schon zuletzt mal Unruhe reingebracht und hätte auch eine der schlechten Rückrunden mal erklärt. Würdest du dem zustimmen? Und ist es tatsächlich ein Thema, auch für diese Saison?
Ja, also ähnlich wie es mit guten Spielern ist, die irgendwann Begehrlichkeiten wecken. Eva hat es ja eben davon, dass irgendwie jeder, der in der 2. Liga irgendwie aufhält, im Winter zu Stuttgart geht. Natürlich weckt ein Hürzer, der seit er da ist, nur zweimal verliert mit dem Verein, den er übernommen hat. Weckt natürlich Begehrlichkeiten. Ich glaube, angespielt wird da auf den Winter vor zwei Jahren quasi, als Timo Schulz so ein bisschen. Dann ging es irgendwie um Unzufriedenheiten im Team. Da ist auch ganz viel nach außen gedrungen, was nicht nach außen dringen sollte. Da war es unter Timo Schulz noch alles ein bisschen wackelig. Ich kann aber auch vollkommen verstehen, dass man da jetzt… Ich meine, was unterscheidet einen Fabian Hürzler von einem guten Spieler? Machen wir uns nichts vor, wenn das jetzt nicht klappen sollte, auch wenn die Hinrunde Bombe war. Und Kevin hat es eben gesagt, wir spielen immer eine Runde gut, eine Runde schlecht. Und wenn wir nach Kalenderjahren spielen würden, wäre alles super. Dann wären wir regelmäßig Gast in der ersten Liga. Tun wir aber nicht. Von daher müssten wir jetzt einfach hoffen, dass man, wie Michi es ja auch gesagt hat, stabil bleiben in der Rückrunde und da zumindest durch gute Ergebnisse, da wird sicherlich auch mal die Niederlage dabei sein, dass wir da oben mit dranbleiben. Und dann sind ja immerhin noch 17 Spiele zu gehen. Und dann wird man sehen, was am Ende dabei rauskommt. Genau, wie wir uns da nichts vormachen müssen, dass gute Spieler oder sehr gute Spieler, wie eben unser Top-Tour-Schütze Marcel Hartel oder ein, weiß ich nicht, ein Johannes-Ergestellter, ein Jackson Irvine, wobei ich da so ein bisschen die Hoffnung hab, dass er sich einfach zu sehr in die Stadt verliebt hat, als dass er gehen möchte. Aber dass dann gute Spieler oder sehr gute Spieler einfach weg sind, wenn du nicht aufsteigst. Und da kann ich persönlich nur für mich sprechen, dann würde ich es auch einem Fabian Hürzler nicht verdenken, dass er sagt, okay, ich habs mit euch versucht, es hat nicht ganz gereicht. Ich versuche jetzt mein Glück in der 1. Liga bei jemand anderem. Das könnte ich ihm persönlich nicht übel nehmen. Nun, du geistest ja auch schon wieder durch die Medien, dass jetzt irgendwie im Winter schon mal was passieren soll. Das glaube ich persönlich nicht. Oder das schicke ich auch ganz viel. Hoffnung mit Eva hebt schon die Hand dazu. Also wie gesagt, Unruhe hin oder her. Ich glaube, wir hoffen einfach alle, dass Fabian Hürzler uns in die 1. Liga führt. Und was dann die weiteren Wege des Vereins und des Trainers Fabian Hürzler angeht, das muss man dann in der Zukunft sehen.
Ja, ich würde noch ganz kurz einhaken. Ich glaube, was aber sowohl ein St. Pauli als auch ein Fabian Hürzler nicht unterschätzen, ist die Identifikation, die Hürzler natürlich mit dem Verein hat. Weil also ehrlich gesagt hat man bei Timo Schulz, den fand ich auch einen guten Trainer, aber man hat eben auch gesehen, dass über den natürlich auch viel mit über Identifikation mit dem Verein gegangen ist. Weil ich könnte falsch liegen, aber ich würde jetzt mal behaupten, seine nachfolgende Trainerstation wäre super erfolgreich. Auch weil ihm natürlich auch ganz anderer Kredit oder gegeben bzw. nicht gegeben wird. Und ich kann mir halt schon vorstellen, also ich glaube schon, dass ein Fabian Hürzler auch woanders erfolgreich ist. Ich glaube aber auch immer noch, dass ganz viel von seinem Erfolg bestimmt auch mit Peter Neumann zu tun hat und den kenne ich wiederum sehr gut, weil er Co-Trainer von Uwe Neuhaus war. Und ich glaube, dass man das auch immer noch nicht unterschätzen darf, wie wichtig so ein Duo ist. Also Kevin hat das eben in der Kombination Dani Scherning und Steffen Baumgart angesprochen. Aber ich finde das immer so schwierig, weil ich glaube, das ist auch immer –es ist eben nicht wie ein guter Spieler, weil einen Spieler, der findet, glaube ich, für den findet man eher immer einen Platz in einem System, als dass man für einen Trainer einen Platz in einem eventuell schon vorhandenen Kader findet. Und ich glaube, das weiß auch nur ein Hürzeler. Und auf der anderen Seite, Michi kennt es sehr gut, dass man auch aufsteigen kann und dann trotzdem die ganz guten Spieler weg sind. Also ich glaube, es ist immer richtig schwierig, glaube ich, zu sagen, da gibt es irgendwie den einen Weg. Aber ich bin tatsächlich auch sehr gespannt, wie es läuft. Ich kann nur sagen, man kann sich mindestens zwei Niederlagen erlauben in der Saison und trotzdem aufsteigen. Weil Avina Bielefeld ist nämlich einer der wenigen Vereine mit Darmstadt 98 in den letzten Jahren, die Herbstmeister geworden sind und trotzdem aufgestiegen.
Da sind wir wieder bei irgendeinem Statement von vor dreieinhalb Stunden oder so. Nein, also was ich ja eben vor allem damit meinte, ist die Begehrlichkeiten oder die Möglichkeiten, sowohl für Spieler als auch für Trainer, dann höher klassisch zu spielen bzw. zu trainieren. Die Identifikation hin oder her?
Es ist trotzdem eine sehr, sehr spannende Situation gerade in der 2. Ich werde dich jetzt nicht zu einer Prognose hinreißen. Es wird auch an Kleinigkeiten hängen, aber das St. Pauli so spielt, wie es spielt, finde ich bemerkenswert. Ich hatte auch das Glück beim 5 zu 1 gegen Kiel dann im Stadion zu sein. Da habe ich mir auch das gute Spiel rausgesucht. Also es kann nicht komplett an mir liegen, dass der St. Pauli jetzt ein bisschen Probleme hatte. Aber es ist eben auch interessant, wie unterschiedlich und in manchen Dingen auch ähnlich sich die oberen 5 sind. Nehmen wir die oberen 6, ich will natürlich unbedingt Paderborn noch mit reinnehmen, ist ja klar. Aber Paderborn für Düsseldorf, HSV, St. Pauli und jetzt gleich sprechen wir über Heustern Kiel. Alle haben ihre Besonderheiten, sind sich aber in manchen Dingen auch einig. Also es ist ein guter Fußball, den man von vielen von denen sehen kann. Es ist aber nicht der konstanteste Fußball, den man eigentlich von fast allen von denen sehen kann. St. Pauli ragt da ja fast noch raus, dadurch, dass man wenigstens nicht verloren hat. Aber vielleicht bringt uns das auch schon zu Heustern Kiel. Vielleicht ist das jetzt dann tatsächlich die Überleitung schon gewesen. Denn unterschiedlicher könnten die Bilanzen ja kaum sein. Wir haben hier ein Team mit 33 Punkten, das hat gar nicht verloren. Und wir haben ein Team mit 35 Punkten, das hat schon viermal verloren. Aber weil man halt elfmal gewonnen hat und nur zweimal unentschieden gespielt hat, ist man jetzt Herbstmeister geworden und versucht jetzt natürlich in die großen Schuhe von Arminia Bielefeld zu treten und dann auch aufzusteigen. Kiel, 33 Tore geschossen. 23 Tore kassiert und Yannick hat es gerade schon gesagt. Eva, es war dann doch eher überraschend, dass Kiel jetzt dann von der Tabellenspitze aus in die Winterpause gehen würde. Das hat mit einem Schlussspurt zu tun, der es in sich hatte.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Vor allem, also man, ich wirke gerne über, also man hat die letzten fünf Spiele gewonnen, aber davor hatte man drei Spiele ohne Sieg. Man hat gegen Osnabrück nur unentschieden gespielt. Das scheint irgendwie auch so ein Ding zu sein, was sich ein bisschen durchzieht. Man hat gegen Magdeburg im Pokal verloren und gegen Nürnberg verloren. Also auch Teams, wo man erstmal, wenn man jetzt auf die Tabelle guckt, sagt so, da wäre vielleicht auch ein Sieg eher drin gewesen. Aber man hat jetzt eben die letzten fünf Spiele gewonnen. Man hat einen Vereinsrekord aufgestellt. Man hat noch nie 35 Punkte in der zweiten Liga in den ersten 17 Spielen der Saison geholt. Also es ist ein Vereinsrekord. Und ich glaube, das hat vor allem damit was zu tun, dass einzelne Spieler und allen voran, Jan Fieter-Aab, den ich glaube Halbfußball Deutschland durchaus schon wieder vergessen hatte, und so ein bisschen müde gelächelt hat, als er dann zu Kiel gewechselt ist, ja einfach einen absoluten Lauf hat. Also man muss einfach sagen, Kiel hat es, glaube ich, und wir haben da immer wieder darüber gesprochen in den letzten vier Stunden, und es ist einfach sehr, sehr gut geschafft, eine sehr, sehr flexibler Mannschaft aufzubauen, von was einzelne Spieler können, von was für eine taktische Aufstellung, erst mal so Rapspielen, bis hin zu ja, wer kann denn ersetzt werden? Und man hat eigentlich diese vier Spieler, man hat Fieter-Aab, Benedikt Pichler, Luis Holpi und Steven Skripski, und die wechseln sich irgendwie immer so ein bisschen ab, wer denn jetzt dran ist mit Tor beschießen. Und gerade Benedikt Pichler ist, glaube ich, ein Spieler, der jetzt, wo er wieder da ist, sehr, sehr gesehen hat, wie sehr letzte Saison gefehlt hat. Da war er ja wirklich größtenteils verletzt. Der bringt einfach eigentlich genau diese klassische 9er-Funktion mit. Also der bindet einfach, nervt einfach den Gegenspieler 90 Minuten lang, ist da unermüdlich, ist für, ich glaube, sein Alter auch schon relativ, ja, erfahren in dem Sinne, was er machen muss, um den Gegenspieler zu nerven. Luis Holbby hat ja gerade auch nochmal seinen Vertrag verlängert, 33 inzwischen, aber auch super wichtig für diesen Kader, was man glaube ich auch nicht, also auch so ein bisschen, die Mannschaft, so ein bisschen der Lost Boys, also von Spielern, die man eigentlich schon so ein bisschen abgeschrieben hat. Also sowohl Steven Skripski als auch Luis Holbby, also im älteren Segment als auch Fita Arb, im jüngeren Segment. Und ich glaube, das kann man ganz eindeutig auch Marcel Rapp zuschreiben. Ich muss sagen, für mich war Kiel letzte Saison ein absolutes Mysterium. Ich habe Spiele von Holstein Kiel wirklich nicht gerne gesehen und ich weiß, dass auch Fans von Holstein Kiel Spiele von ihrer eigenen Mannschaft nicht unbedingt gerne gesehen haben. Da auch liebe Grüße an Pike und generell 1912 FM. Mit denen wir auch im Zuge unserer Saisongeschehe für den 2. Bundesliga-Podcast gesprochen hatten und die immer gesagt haben, ob Marcel Rapp jetzt die richtige Idee ist, wissen wir nicht. Gleichzeitig ging das auch mit Kritik an Uwe Stöver einher. Jetzt haben wir die Situation, Marcel Rapp hat Anfang Oktober oder Mitte Oktober seinen Vertrag bis 2026 verlängert. Der wäre im nächsten Sommer ausgelaufen. Gleichzeitig verlässt Uwe Stöver im Sommer den Verein, aber dem war wohl relativ wichtig, dass man eben diesen Vertrag jetzt schon durch hat und dass er gleichzeitig auch dem Verein lange genug Zeit gibt, Nachfolger zu suchen. Also es steht dann durchaus auch doch einen Umbruch im Raum, aber zumindest bleibt man mit dem Trainer. Und ich glaube, ja, Marcel Rapp ist jemand, der immer als Erstes in der Kritik steht. Das habe ich schon auch so vernommen. Also er ist immer schon der erste, auf den geguckt wird. Und dagegen glaube ich jetzt auch schon wieder so ein bisschen das Gerummel los. Das finde ich sehr interessant, weil im Forum stand das Zitat, wenn Kiel nach der Herbstmeisterschaft nur Fünfter wird, stört das hier niemanden. Und ich möchte tatsächlich die These ausstellen, dass ich das nicht glaube. Weil man war schon mal Herbstmeister, 2020, 2021 glaube ich, dass man dann damals in der Relevation gegen Wolfsburg gescheitert. Das war auch noch mal andere Zeiten, aber ich glaube schon. Weil nochmal, es ist diese Was-wenn-nicht-jetzt-Saison so ein bisschen. Und ich glaube, dass ich die Erwartungshaltung in Kiel wahrnehme, dass man so schnell auch immer wieder unzufrieden mit Marcel Raffa war. Vor allem gab es Kritik, dass er so lange an der Dreier-respektive Fünferkette festgehalten hat, obwohl das immer wieder eher mit einem Kader war, der wohl eher Viererkette spielt. Jetzt wird so ein bisschen klar, Rapp will eben diesen total flexiblen Kader, würde ich jetzt so von Blick auf außen sagen. Also er stellt im Spiel echt viel um. Und da muss man sagen, das gelingt ihm größtenteils ganz gut. Er ist damit ein paar Mal eben auch hingefallen. Aber ich finde einfach dieses ganze Team echt interessant. Dafür, dass auch irgendwie dann ein großer Umbruch war.
Ein Riesen-Umbruch war es sogar, oder waren es nicht zehn Abgeordnete?
Ich glaube, 16 Spieler wurden ausgetauscht. Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist wirklich dieser Mix auch zwischen –also unter anderem musste man ja einen Hauke Wal ersetzen, als er zu St. Pauli gegangen ist. Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist da Colin Kleinebekel, den man, glaube ich, als Originalliga-Mannschaft, also der U23, quasi hochgezogen hat und der ein absoluter Stammspieler ist, der eine Sicherheit mitbringt, einen Tom Rother auf außen, der da, glaube ich, in den letzten Spielen auch immer wieder Commander so ein bisschen verdrängt hat. Also diese ganze Mannschaft ist so ein ganz wilder Mix zwischen jungen Talenten und dann eben so jemand wie Finn Porath, der seine Erfahrung mitbringt. Also da empfehle ich es wirklich jedem, sich das 1-0 gegen Hannover anzugucken. Es ist ja das letzte Spiel, was wir jetzt hatten. Wir haben die 3-0 gewonnen, haben Hannover eigentlich auch keinerlei Chance gelassen. Also das schickt Tom Rother, Finn Porath mit einem Ball auf die Grundlinie, wo du eigentlich denkst, was sollte der Ball, wer soll den bekommen? Und Finn Porath erwischt ihn, glaube ich, gerade so auf der Grundlinie. Und im Zentrum steht dann Timo Becker als Außenverteidiger, glaube ich, eigentlich. Und erzählt uns das 1-0. Also sowieso das Flügelspiel von Kehl, finde ich unseres bei interessant. Aber auch eben, wie sie immer wieder durchs Zentrum, also die Seitenverlagerung etc. Es macht wirklich, um darauf nochmal zurückzukommen, sehr, sehr viel Spaß, Holstein Kehl dieses Mal im Spiel zuzugucken und das Maserabdus geschafft hat. Extrem gut. Ich fand es auch sehr interessant. Es gab, ich glaube, vom Mitte Dezember ein Interview, wo er beim NDR sitzt. Und er wurde natürlich auch ein bisschen aufgezwungen mit seinem Dialekt. Also und gibt dann auch ein Interview mit seinen Co-Traineren Alex Hahn und Dirk Bremser. Ein sehr junger Co-Trainer mit Alex Hahn und ein sehr erfahrener mit Dirk Bremser. Die auch so ein bisschen sagen, sie sind immer ein bisschen dazu da, den euphorischen Maserabdus zu bremsen. Also, dass sie dann mal sagen, wenn er da mal zu positiv ist, so. Jetzt holen wir dich mal auf den Teppich der Tatsachen zurück. Das finde ich sehr, sehr interessant mit anzuschauen. Und ja, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe zwischendurch mal nicht so ganz viele 2. Liga verfolgt, weil irgendwie war ein bisschen viel. Aber als ich jetzt wieder reingeguckt habe und ich dachte, hey, warum steht Kiel da? Und dann habe ich nochmal angeguckt, dass der so, okay, krass. Also, das ist Fußball, den kann man sich wirklich extrem gut angucken. Und eben durch diese Flexibilität gerade in der Offensive finde ich, stehen sie da am Ende auch sehr zurecht, auch wenn es defensiv bestimmt immer wieder Probleme gibt. Aber auch das macht dann vielleicht am Ende so ein Fußballspiel interessanter.
Alex Hahn war übrigens der vorhin erwähnte Co-Trainer, der gleichzeitig Spieleanalyst war.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, also ich finde es, wie gesagt, ich finde da, also Marcel Rapp hat nämlich auch gesagt, wir wollen vor der Saison, wir wollen Fußspuren hinterlassen in dieser ausgeglichenen Liga. Das haben wir zumindest mit der Herbstmeisterschaft schon mal geschafft. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass da eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung drin ist, dass man zumindest in den Top 5 bleibt bis zum Ende der Saison. Und ich finde die, wenn, also weil man eben diese, ich, ich, ich, es ist wieder etwas zum Unwort des Tages, Flexibilität hat, dann darf man das auch durchaus erwarten.
Okay, also ich habe viel gelernt unter anderem, also irgendwelche Bob-Teams, die haben Anschiebe im Team. Bei Heustern Kiel hat man einen Bremser im Team und da wird dann auch schnell mal der Hahn zugedreht, damit der Rapp nicht durchdreht vor Euphorie. Es ist fast 1 Uhr nachts. Wenn ihr jetzt nicht noch was… Ich habe quasi jetzt gleich dann das Gleiche jetzt nochmal für die 1. Wenn ihr jetzt nicht noch was ganz, ganz Wichtiges zu Kiel habt, dann würde ich doch vorschlagen, ich sehe, da die Frage stellt sich nicht. Dann würde ich sagen, das soll es jetzt gewesen sein mit dieser Bundesliga-Vorschau, mit dieser… Nein, nicht Vorschau, das war ein Rückblick. Ja, ja, stimmt. Das sind alles Details, auf die kann ich jetzt keine Rücksicht mehr nehmen. Also, liebe Leute da draußen, ihr müsst bitte alle vier Gäste mit Liebe überschütten dafür, dass sie das gemacht haben. Ihr habt es gemerkt, wie gut vorbereitet alle waren. Ihr habt gemerkt, wie lange diese Sendung war. Ihr habt sie auf erhöhter Geschwindigkeit gehört. Wir haben es in normaler Geschwindigkeit eingesprochen. Es ist jetzt sehr, sehr spät. Ob Kevin jetzt wirklich noch bei Twitch streamt, das möchte ich doch arg infrage stellen. Nein, er schüttelt panisch den Kopf. Jetzt geht es für uns alle in die Heier. Und diese Sendung wird auch nicht mehr heute Nacht erscheinen.
Ich habe nachgeschaut, wie wir über Ragnar Acher gesprochen haben. Und wir haben die Sendung Ragnars Rache genannt. Ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt, als du das vorhin diesen Versprecher hattest. Das kenne ich irgendwo. Ich habe nachgeschaut in unsere Sendungstitel.
Was soll ich sagen? Mir hat gestern jemand ganz begeistert ein Video gezeigt, wo einer der öffentlich-rechtlichen Kanäle ein Pop der Baumeister-Wortspiel gemacht hat. Und dann habe ich einfach nur mein Handy gezückt und habe die 2019 erschienene Folge des Rasenfunkes gezeigt. Pop die Baumeisterin. Es ist ein Full Circle-Moment. Hiermit schließt sich alles, aber was ich gerade sagen wollte, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, überschüttet bitte alle Gäste mit Liebe und Dankbarkeit dafür, dass sie das hier gemacht haben. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank euch. Sollte euch das nicht gereicht haben mit Infos zur 2. Liga. Auf rasenfunk.de/fußballpodcastgibtes eine Liste aller uns aktuell bekannten Fußballpodcasts. Da gibt es auch eine große Sektion zur 2. Liga. Da würdet ihr jetzt noch mehr finden. Aber jetzt für den Moment bleibt mir nur noch euch zu danken. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Yannick vom Millern-Ton. Danke dir, lieber Yannick.
Danke, Max. Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Aber jetzt ruft das Bett doch auch langsam.
Ja, also man hat es uns allen, glaube ich, ein bisschen angemerkt. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Kevin Bublitz. Danke dir, lieber Kevin vom Pardercast natürlich. Ach, meine Güte, ey. Na gut, aber das ist ein hartes Video. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ja, danke dir. Und danke an Michael Fischer vom 4. Flachpass. Danke dir, lieber Michael.
Sehr, sehr gerne.
Und herzlichen Dank an Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 11 Freunde täglich Podcast. Danke dir, liebe Eva, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass mein Corona-Brain das alles durchgehalten hat.
Aber absolut, dass du dich hier durchgeschleppt hast, ist sowieso. Also, wenn wir diese Hingabe von allen Teams sehen, dann steigen sie alle auf in die 1. Liga. Das ist doch dann die Traum-Bundesliga für viele da draußen. Ihr lieben Hörer und Hörer, unterstützt den Rasenfunk, rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Wenn ihr wollt, empfehlt uns sehr, sehr gerne weiter. Gerade diese Sendung wird ja jetzt eine ganze Weile nicht schlecht werden. Also die kann man gut verteilen über soziale Netzwerke, in Messenger-Diensten und so weiter und so fort. Und geht gerne auf rasenfunk.de, wenn euch sonst noch so interessiert, was wir machen, denn es ist so einiges, was wir machen. Bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkfolge.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knauser.